gueuler fable émission quoi va je pense
que c'est une émission qui est
dangereuse en fait quand tu as de la
chance il y aura pas de feu ce soir mais
il ya une autre émission ouais maths
mais ça va tu peux le faire que
[Musique]
ça récupère moins tranquille tu tolère
de faire juste max l'émission a tous
voila
avait fait 13 ans d'émission est très
dangereux parce que là c'est l'émission
on ne peut pas dire le nom on va faire
un fou très attention ça reprend dès
demain quoi
j'aurais très peur coiffe
l'émission qui réveille tes voisins
ouais c'est une émission qui se fait mal
à la gorge pour le mouvement palmarès de
l'émission j'ai cru à une corona quoi
fin c'est très dangereux quoi j'étais
très heureux que michael youn me refasse
ses conneries que
j'ai même pas tu sais comme le morning
live betting morning light quoi avant
qu'il ait donc il est très heureux il
fait le con
normal quoi
oui bah fidèle à lui même va très bien
bravo
du coup tu es très heureux ouais
voilà c'est cool j j'ai pas encore j'ai
pas encore vu tu vois je suis
complètement bloquée avec les candidats
et le corona quoi tu vois je ne sais pas
le temps de pas le temps de savoir qu'il
ya ludique de l'argent le chat
d'ailleurs il a il fait déjà des chats
quoi ben moi je fais autre chose pour
les coques vous tous
ces jeunes quadras tout envoyé dans leur
dialogue a été nuls et que plus cerise
ita 6 passes j'adore le tennis dans
adinfo que je voulais faire
mais j'ai peur de le dire non
alors attends à tanger en train de
mettre le reste
ça est très bien les gens étaient en sus
à rien avec l'émission de l'émission
théorique de match c'est fantastique
ni la nouveauté à faisons
avant la wii enfin fut le 38e coup tu
tues tu n'as pas joué ce que tu n'as pas
joué il ya 38 ya pas de vague mais
qu'elle va être forte ce n'est pas la
casse bien
très beau très fier d'eux mad de mathieu
cornette avec valoir caruana après oui
tu n'as pas lu le fichier c'est une
honte c'est incroyable tu types de
fichiers
il se rappelle de rien comme d'hab
comment peut-il avoir ce niveau ouais
c'est vraiment beau parce que le truc
encore great ue qui sera avait pas les
trucs de digby raid s'était vraiment 25e
coup quoi
comme l'autre est très prévisible tu
avais que ça a révisé son parfaite et ça
c'est très normal ce serait 25e coup
d'une autre ligne 8 a pris par surprise
peut-être c'est tolérable bon limites
mais mais la blague comment comment être
aussi nul comment ne pas avoir de
mémoire comme sa faim tu comment ne pas
savoir lire quelque part
c'est grave quand même
ça prend la maternelle
comment être 2800 avec un tel niveau à
l'oeil et eurent beaucoup d'inflation tu
sais vers l'iran même dabara et 1,2730
pour te dire pour te dire une amarre a
quand même pour sa défense juste comme
ça ça fait quand même quinze ans que i
les vingt-sept quelque chose que oui ça
te prouve bien ce que veut vraiment dire
27 justement très justement c'est normal
tanit aurait dit ce à quoi tu as dit
justement ça prouve bien ce que je dis
depuis longtemps en dessous de 27,50 ça
joue vraiment pas du tout
très nue
alors du coup aujourd'hui on va faire le
il va y avoir du jeu partir ouais donc
il ya max contre sacha
berlinoise je pense 1 mais du coup c'est
pas réputé alors
bah si mais apparemment fins et récolté
par une personne voit qu'il a réfuté les
autres ne savent pas nager les autres ne
savent pas voilà c'est la tuant trois
quarts entre joueurs celui à bas
tarifs ou encore la berlinoise pour te
dire papa te dire
ok bon c'est parce qu'ils craignent mme
allen 10 on dit qu'il a vu l'a plus
drapeau quoi 10 milliards n ya plus rien
ding contre guiry
balding aller dit il regarde le tournoi
avant chauffants fond moi je mettrais un
hangar où un joueur d'open fois nul mais
bon pourquoi pas au gnouf par la logique
aussi
et 41 dépôts
top car alain qui a réagi en champion
voilà un dépôt qui auront passé sous
silence un spa sont dira complètement
une chose différente ton et marc me
faire se pâmer quoi ce serait fou que
maxime gagne le tour des candidats alors
qu'il n'était même pas censé le jouet
vrai ce serait beau quoi il ferait une
cramique quelque part web et/ou uden
marque tout ce qu on les kramix et
beaucoup à gagner du champion du monde
en perdant en demi finale oui mais s'est
jamais qualifiée pour rien à bah
non mais c'est vrai que l'affiché avait
regagné parfois mais en fait mais bon il
ya camille animal ce qu'une grippe à qui
s'est un peu pas lui rendre oui mais bon
tu n'es pas je n'aurais pas dû jouer
non que je sais pas pourquoi tu resteras
voulu jouer contre lui
c'est à dire qu'ils étaient nuls non
mais non mais non bassila que je shirov
comme c'était normal chirac il déjà
perdu une fois de sa vie est donc là
pour le coup
un enjeu financier ou un truc comme ça
donc
de quoi raconte tout ce qui s'est passé
avec ramic
commencent à tomber juste c'était en
98-99 par là il ya eu un cycle pour se
qualifier pour affronter kasparov en
match amical perdu contre shirov dont le
cycle quads ont du goût bas il va pas au
bout shirov gagne le truc est donc
chirac vainqueur doit jouer kasparov en
match
médiator a dit non beaucoup trop nul je
joue comme crâne ipd choisissons son
challengeur
jouer contre quelqu'un qui savait
déplacer les pièces pc ion l'autre oui
mais bon en même temps pourquoi tu fais
un cycle de qualification en tout cas
mettre direct ramic comme disait à
l'époque que faisait ressentir est il a
vu il ne connaît pas la prise en passant
vous est compliqué de lui expliquer
pendant les parties sur un trail et donc
du coup bas match question grave ni
cramique à gagner
donc il est devenu champion du monde
comme ça est ce qu'avec cramique la
dac oi un verbe qui rime avec nick avec
son web à quelque part non mais après je
veux dire il n'était pas illégitime de
jouer parce qu'il était pris très fort
mais un duceppe a qualifié
de l'argent c'est beau corps accueilli
la cram nique et voilà la cram n'y
tiennent bon après ça qu'est-ce qu'il ya
eu après cramique il a défendu son titre
quelquefois quoi donc contre nico
la crème n'est que sa mère
et puis après ça ouais mais il a gardé
son titre quelquefois contre les cocons
topalov il l'a perdue contre allende
ces autocrates quoi je vais te
dire ouais tu peux juste jouer shirov
tranquillement bons mots normalement tu
allais gagner et puis
[Musique]
c'est vrai même envie de truc marrant
c'est qu'il y avait de la blague lors
des derniers candidats parce que même là
il a joué les candidats sans se
qualifier
mais
mais au final ouais c'était pas si
immérité qui veulent numéro trois
mondial à ce moment là
voilà
donc la photo de zing wave riding web
dit il veut plus être en faute au milieu
claude par apollo plus rien
désolé fabre g la nourriture sinequa
manger donc les ducaux seconde sérieux
c'est en train d'arriver là parce que ça
fait j'avais plus de dix ans j'avais
plus rien là donc je vais me faire un
drive bientôt je crois ouais ça manquait
ça manquait de testostérone et de lait
viande rouge dans mon
frigidaire
je suis un petit peu tu vois ces
histoires est un peu un peu bonhomme un
peu chaud tu vois j'ai envie de te dire
histoire de l'histoire de ce roman tu es
là tu veux pas manger des kebabs avec
tes petits doigts alors non non non je
blague partout l'entrecôte ya des choses
comme ça mais j'ai vraiment pas pas
manger ce qui va pendant deux ans à
cause de la vidéo de l'autre idiot quoi
c'est extraordinaire j'étais tellement
heureux de ma connerie
c'est comme ça il faut surtout dans le
dos au moins qu'au plus que jamais
et toi non plus banon mais le jour juste
aller faire les courses c'est plus qu'en
bon je veux du saumon s'était pas
pourront faire des petits toasts c'était
pour me faire des pâtes un peu avec la
crème de ça tu peux prendre ne soyons
pas trop de haute qualité mais non j'ai
refusé de prendre les côtes plus fun que
tout aille mais tu as vu la vidéo du
club lou est bloqué mais bon on peut
dire que tu as été pourri par les
marques bas complètement parce que moi
j'ai goûté aux autres
ouais
bon du tout à tomber aux mains trois
hommes
mais ce qui est déjà arrivée puisqu'il
est arrivé en retard
ma ville dort
[Musique]
jusqu'à 16 heures ils sont fous quoi
hésiter à 15h54
j'ai fait ce qu'il fait en fait non mais
ça c'est un truc ça reste quand même un
truc assez spécial pour moi fab
c'est comment tu peux avoir envie de
jouer aux échecs toute ta vie si on
tournoi tu arrives tu à dormir que tu
penses que face à face à bien une
obsession en fait ça fait penser à la
série joue que je regardais hier j'avais
fini après la saison ça y est il arrivé
là il ajouté mme paul parce que je veux
dire ou pas femmes web est ce que tu es
vraiment mais s'il y avait une vidéo de
du précepteur
qui disait qu'il y avait quand même une
différence entre l'obsession et l'amour
bah oui mais ce qu'est ce que du coup
quand enfin je sais pas quand tu joues
un truc que tu fais et ce que chantait
pas obsessionnel en quelque sorte
paturel je te fais de la philosophie
comme je pense sont tous obsessionnelle
ouais donc en fait peut-être que tu
comptes font apparaître
que tu te dis j'aime le truc et où je
peux pas m'en passer en fait t'es
complètement obsessionnelle des échecs
quand on arrive au point de plus dormir
la nuit c'est problématique
des tripeux validé
30 ans de vie à faire que ça pour
essayer d'être champion du monde ou au
moins de jouer le titre se dire que
c'était pas points
will obsessionnelle
mais en fait non love bien ça et puis
les malades ministre est mal quoi qu'il
fasse
ce que jenson
ouais mais c'est de la fusée comptoir
pas mais bon on a quand même le droit
après quatre jours de deux jeux de faire
de la philosophie de comptoir surtout
qu'on va se taper une berlinoise donc
complètement ses lancers c'est la petite
finale de la berlinoise
mais maxime qui la jouent bien
normalement il l'avait bien pressés à
riga
[Musique]
et donc au bureau mon gros talent la
berlinale dont on vous avait prévenu
avant même que la partie commence oui
bon du coup aux yeux rien d'autre chose
attend on attend 4 demi que ça valence
encore deux trois coups bas ça a balancé
dureront huit et c'est
ce à quoi cet attelage cinq forages si
ces compagnies peuvent rouler on a déjà
vu que j'en attends de minutes que ça se
passe ok boy ou alors tu as bien mais
toi d'aller de saison juste la première
je crois la première fait le truc c'est
que ça avance tout seul sur netflix du
coup je crois que j'ai fini la première
fois en gros il vient de tuer sa copine
blonde quoi mais c'est la presse afin
d'apprendre c'est se mettre d'accord et
du coup il revoit l'autre fille qui
revient mais en fait je pense que c'est
un mirage sais pas quoi
bon il a bien faire re 8
mai les mirettes j'essaie donc pas ouais
ça va ça vient après moi tu as j'avais
pas besoin de joie che enfin jeu j'avais
vu la première saison il ya longtemps
voyage je crois que tu es sorti il ya un
an et puis là j'ai vu la seconde il ya
quelques mois vous êtes une qui posent
entre les deux décomptes ans après je
sais pas si en faisant tout d'affilée
c'est aussi bien ou pas dur à dire ouais
j'en disposerai qui l'a tué il a tué la
meuf kong oui mais en fait je le savais
dès la première seconde dès la première
seconde phase est pour l'instant
c'est le but de la série enfin tu sais
que ça va arriver tout le monde quoi bon
coin des raiders tu sais quand même que
ça va arriver dès le premier épisode
sauf si elle s'en sort mais c'est la
nacion quoi c'est une saison 2
bah oui parce que tu as créé une saison
2 tu sais comment ça s'est passé
ce que bns s'est pas levé son absence
bah oui et non le pur d'à côté
tableau de bigmat banni je sais pas
pourquoi pour 86400 seconde
bombe séparés sont découvertes chaque
look out façon j'écrirais un juge mais
les pls des trucs comme ça qu'est ce que
je voulais dire mais je sais plus
et pour la peine en plus sa série est
pas terrible au final
non mais vraiment non ne regardez pas
non c'est pas mal mais c'est
à dire c'est comme casa de patel quoi
ouais bah c'est beaucoup trop prévisible
sais tu sais tout ce qui va se passer et
il ya beaucoup d'incohérences et
scénaristique aussi
bah oui oui ça c'est trop simple quoi
former un local qu'ils oublient ce
machin marie c'est bien ce que je sais
il ya trop de
d'un cohérence scénaristique
est d'ailleurs tu penses que
ça ok j'ai raison laisser le bocal dans
le truc pour te mettre fin au
[Musique]
débat et qui pas de reçu
une balle au dessus des partis concept
d'autres plus d'un an ça commence à 12
heures donc
des torcols sol après très bien bonfoh
de cette
hyper ans mais en fait le truc c'est
faux pas se regarder pour avoir une
cohérence pile-poil genre à ce moment la
foire des watts world des trucs hyper
bien écrit nick hamm quoi
pas d'excellents mais après tu vois des
scieries détente est ok il est de 3,1
cohérent si un petit suspens à machin il
faut pas s'arrêter là ya pas de 3 en
cohérence oui
surtout le truc et une incohérence en
fait
non mais j'ai en fait c'est absolument
rien de cohérent c'est ta tribu encore
on en est sûr c'est un peu too much
ouais mais c'est pas grave enfin faites
pas c'est pas le but du truc
mais du coup ça fait sortir du délire
bah c'est la même que great 5e nepos
exactement les mêmes bah oui je te
dirais même une fois va revendre une
truie oumma on attend on aura le temps
va faire en c3 purpan ces trois
moines qui l'enchaîné christian génie
permise par oui c'est la même partie
juste donc le joug des trois jours mais
j'ai trois jours il connaît tous par
coeur
mais est ce que ça peut faire un nul
genre en 20 minutes au nom maximy lénine
après ça peut peut-être faire nul en 20
minutes 6
à noter
il avait pas eu match quatre femmes à
s'il avait joué h 4 6 ici excuse fosse à
l'acte fausse alerte rouge en train de
rentrer les coudes on se base tu vois
pour pouvoir faire fi des brunes sur le
truc et te dire que ça va bouger mais
[Musique]
la pelouse période sauf aussi mais j'ai
4 c'était ça qui ont prendre '
son âge si ce papier payante y en prend
à tanger mauvais un petit à petit chez
ce point comme evans avait de faire les
allers-retours sur ton écran que c'est
une soul
tournament
les grilles
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient une idée
max un enfant brosse une
île je porte quelque chose ma famille
mérite choc il a confiance en ses
analyses en tout cas
et away donc en fait eu deux partis de
l'opposition va 3 sûrement avec le
niveau il ya deux jours mais elle n'est
pas encore dans la base je vais acheter
un
[Musique]
dont l'une des nouvelles contre naka
mais j'ai quatre c'est pas le coup qui
avait joué né pauvre l'unef airwatch de
a vengé
4,4 direct il ya eu deux parties pour
l'instant la base c'est maxime grande
maca et guiry come back à ses larmes
d'un athlète quand il se passe quoi
après mais c'est pas ce combat ce
passage et objets et n'a qu'à sur czech
comme contre maximy les jeux call you
7-6 7/1 speechless je pense et contre
conques diri à autant de questions à
zagreb donc il ya quelques mois
d'affaires grecs
[Musique]
donc françois et philips est le coup le
plus sérieux que ces loteries l'agent du
let me go enfin d'un calibre très au
sérieux comme la compétition l'espi de
chasse ou quoi donc avoir
les cordes et vite c'est un coup bas
ça paraît juste logique en fait je vais
changer une tour ouais mais
je me questionne
le questionne sur
[Musique]
sur la tourache 6 après qu'il ya
peut-être un peu loin je sais pas mais
c'est peut-être jouable pourquoi pas en
fait autour des buts n'ont pas de 6,6
iman triminio qui ont comparé du bullet
avec la partie longue regrets mais
s'avoue pas si mal ont dû l'être bah en
fait tu as la position qui a lassé très
théorique ces jeux aux candidats à la
variante où on va il se trouve que
nakheel avait joué
la vie jouer en bus la troupe maximum en
speed chasse et c'est une cohésion il
prend au sérieux qu'il a envie d'y aller
donc ni c'est pas des bulles apte à
jouer h 4 h 5 tours h3
tu viens de s'endormir
possible possible mais le truc c'est sur
quel point f7 les gars bon admettons un
coup holanda auquel se fait roi prend tu
es fou prend f6 je te fait cavalier
prend et j'ai gagné une caisse noire
en fait il faudrait au moins que les
blancs ont échangé une tour et qu'ils
puissent rentrer avec la torre subtil et
car il est prêté sur aka aouélé prend
aussi ses atouts réussissent donc il ya
ma découverte non non non mais tout ça
tout l'idée de cette tour en justice
et si tu bouges lecavalier tu perds le
pirate froid à présent
donc
mais hautement c'est intéressant je vais
voir ce sujet des analyses sur ça
quelque part
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu as là dessus le
questionnaire mais je pense ce passager
m 7 / jamais nulle part non non c'est ça
on rentre pas les noirs ont solidifié
activer leurs pièces et qui vont se
créer un pion de l'autre côté aussi
quelque part parce quand à bouger si
c'est chiant ça à tenir la tour à la
défense de ses 2
mais on
ne peut pas arriver à gagner en force
alors
alors compliqué
mais la great food qui croient en cédant
takashi saito h6 comme matin en fait
la partie
théorique mais loin de là ça va jouer
longtemps ça va être stratégique ok il y
aura pas d variante très
très tactique ne vient normalement des
attractions roi ou quoi ça va être un
autre style de jeu mais mais c'est pas
si mal juste en fait évidemment si
compliqué à suivre
c'est parce qu'il ya de plus excitant en
général pour le public etc mais ça va
pas faire mieux comme ça
ouais
ça pète
ça peut être passionnant quoi
bon enfin non c'est passionnant si tu
rentres dans le détail que
c'est pas notre style non nous on veut
des des grog
c'est quoi son attrait pleutre
ballon mais évidemment mon gros du
spectacle quoi non mais je pense que
beaucoup de coups son job pour les morts
le roi est fluide de naka et coûte
vraisemblablement c'est pas mal mais
j'ai manqué cette voie en bulles est
peut-être plus principal
mais c'est que c'est le meilleur coup
d'après leur dis quand même caillou set
il a joué en dual track peut-être il a
amélioré après sa partie de rouen
longuet s'est dit bon en longue jupe
hummer m problème ça a été fait dans
l'autre sens
comment ça il ya d'abord eu le bullet il
ya un an après il a joué le truc bah oui
alors de l'autre côté créé simon bullet
je garde de mes meilleurs coups ouais et
puis bon ballon train de se préparer
r je n'ai que deux heures pour trouver
quand on joue et je veux pas me faire
surprendre elle joue
et qui l'armée le truc c'est que rich ou
claude jours a joué avec roy de fuite tu
te souviens il a amené le roi en g8 oui
sur watch de dépôt du septième coup
laférois de fuite
avec l'idée en fait droit et fit c'est
de libérer la case ou huit portes à
tours dont tu trouve une utilité à ta
tour à ta seconde tour et tu peux qu'on
s'est un peu après c'est aux 5 kerry
plaisir d'un autre côté que maxime a
sûrement préparé roi et udaf huit ans
disait vouloir essayer de transposer et
qu'il a peut-être unités ici et donc
quelle idée de caballos adsa juste pour
vos parents maire c'est de relocaliser
le cavalier qui donc quand même cinq a
plus rien à faire
sur le cloud qui casse son contrôle est
donc juste tu te bats
tu te barres le 7 pour rebondir en d5
ou angers si c'est parfois mais souvent
des cinq b6 c4 une fois que cette
structure là parce que les pions sont
doublés et c'est sa peine vl qui leur
revers à 4 surtout à carhaix vide
abyssal steps c'est ça qui est le plus
important mais ouais donc qu'est ce qui
est des cinq qui est bêtises qu'ils
essaient 4 c'est une très bonne case
contre calais parce que tu tapes de
faiblesse de 5 à 3
ok c'est ça l'idée du cavalier 7 mais
bon tu as peut-être le temps de faire
que timbaland ou qu'ici c'est villa qui
a fait le fichier de greccio que je
comprends qu'ils aient confiance en ses
analyses
non me voilà bon c'est tout vous faites
quoi dire d'autre donc ok le seul
président mais je pense qu'il faut au
moins à réfléchir une cinquantaine de
minutes pour être bien sûr comme y faut
quoi et peut-être même 50 sur ce coup et
25 au prochain tu sais pour assurer quoi
ce que je pense qu'après à partir du 27e
tu peux déjà toujours en quelques
secondes ce sera très très simple qua
non mais je pense qu'ils peuvent soit
très longtemps des incidents vivent
peut-être peut même aller faire une
petite sieste histoire d'être bien en
forme comme il faut pour bien réfléchir
après marc mais surtout que là il ya une
heure 44 ils ont déjà joué 17 coups
contact 20 coups en 1h45
tu peux bien dormir
c'est beau quand même de dormir pour les
partis c'est un vrai truc hein les gars
il s'écrit tout cas vraiment dormi ces
terres en deux pendant la partie il ya
licha qui demande si après roy et
philippe quel point le système consiste
c'est pas mieux pour les blancs en fait
jacques te dire non alors certes on a
répété plusieurs fois que le tandem tour
fougue fort pour cavaliers
là c'est quoi le problème en fait c'est
que notre aux choux avec les blancs
c'est un génie il est auto bloqué par
nos pions lecavalier a plein de gasoil
et ne va se balader et je trouve que les
blancs ont beaucoup de faiblesses si on
parle en terme d' îlots ils en ont trois
cas pas dans les normes de
catherine
ménard notre côté alors ok t'as tour 17
mai ses passagers
oui je vais faire toerseth ou bon si
j'ai bonne ou prodige fameux tour s'est
vite je m'en fiche du matin crapa deux
fois je t'emmène au moins 8 je te fait
qu'il ait cette quête des 500 fermes ta
tour soit la bouffe
pas vrai si ta puce di lota plus endroit
pour aller faire y soumettre clabaut
s'ils notent des petites villes privé
devrait
donc s confiance par un avantage
donc en fait non 86,2 pas trop les
blancs il
gère la tour à 8 qui a du mal entre en
jeu la tourache 6 on sait pas ce qu'elle
fait mais si les noirs s'organise c'est
pas mal en termes de structure depuis un
moment c'est mieux prévoir 12e trou
qu'il est blanc peut faire c'est
peut-être viser à me surpasser à chaque
jour
mais bon ok lointain tous à faire
franchement j'y crois pas trop à cette
position pour les blancs mais bon non
plus mais ok mélanie donc on va voir
oui j'ai vu me rées dormir en
championnat quand il jouait en national
avec cergy pontoise non mais c'est bien
d'en rire on est parti en fait qu'ils
dormaient murray
n'aurait rien dit morey non non
il avait vraiment murray en fait oui je
sais il ya que moi il a fait froid et
fit vraiment quand c'est pas traîné non
non c'est toi banon les y réfléchit non
mais je sois sérieux quoi ton qu'il a du
temps il va réfléchir réfléchit à
réfléchir peut-être dans une une heure
trois quart d'heure tu verras bref ils
ont fait un tour du côté chantier ou wii
et les jouets des cats à l'epo a pas sur
le d'ouverture on peut se questionner
non mais déjà avec l'anglais l'autre
jour il ya des endroits dans ce qu'il
faisait déjà il a eu qu'un devis
millions d'euros pour se préparer
ce n'était pas assez pour changer
d'ouverture temps mais pas trop non mais
je passe pour manquer de voir où on en
est et puis après on peut revenir si tu
aimes c'est pour voir déjà
non mais ces lignes principales de
nom en fait comment dire tu sais après
qu'est de rock rock les 6/9 vous
attend ils me disent que ça passait pas
parti sur youtube live attend de seconde
phase et
ses 107 partie sur youtube aussi en fait
ben s'écrit actuellement directement
visé la chaîne jeunesse comme
international
mais
[Musique]
attends
ça marche ça marche on est bien d'accord
ça marche bah moi je sais pas je sais
pas de mon côté mais sur ce que je vois
sur ton écran ça marche j'essaie de mon
côté pour rejoindre sur
youtube
[Musique]
bah moi ça me dit que c'est diffuser une
pièce comme usher phase i ou si jamais
pour être sûr à 100%
on de 4,1 sur un français machin ouais
on est là on est là mais alors à temps a
juste un petit truc femme je jouais
johnny d'un chat non et non non ça c'est
trop les gens voient passer c'est sans
ses marchés en fait non je vois je vois
partout en fait désolé mais je dois
faire un petit haïtien qui a moins de
monde que la dernière fois c'est bizarre
je vous mets le lien soul
bah je sais pas pour qui en fait tout le
monde
mais ça bizarre que ça il ya moins de
personnes que sur les diffusions
précédente sur youtube et donc j'imagine
d'avoir des gens qui ont vraiment
prennent pourtant il se trouve que ça
marche
[Musique]
nous émettrons soir ça marche
ça marche ça marche
maintenant après peut-être dû
revendiquer de type e avec certaines
personnes désolé garantie tant normes et
donc c'est bon
merci à merci les gars c'est un problème
de notification probablement à
exactement
exactement bonsoir affable désolé tard à
couper non
je finis remontent au veto du coup
je c'est pour ça que parfois je suis un
peu salée quand les gens me disent ça
marche pas ou un truc comme ça servette
a tellement souvent des fausses alertes
casas mais en pls
non mais bon en gros ce qu'il trouve une
marche pas de lui-même et marche pas
bien c'est une façon
non mais c'est pas ce que je veux dire
je veux dire par là que parfois ça n'est
en tl s
ça n'est en pls
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai que je vois
qu'aujourd'hui avant il ya moins de
monde que d'habitude sur le cul voilà
c'est ouf un peu importe si les arènes
vont bien mais quelquefois dans les
abonnements ya rien à fiche et dwayne
ont mis à peut-être un bug youtube après
mai mais le live et le live est parti
mais c'est ça le plus important
surtout il est parti surtout il est
parti 5 1 mais j'aimerais surtout étonné
si jamais tu prend l'habitude c'est
qu'une partie et que se joue à 12 heures
est ce que bon il nous dit fou pas un
vote positif oui je sais mais bon du
coup
thomas ces genres en temps normal le
dimanche la ligue 1 bon ba ty matches de
15 heures un match de 17h
j'ai pas de motifs sur le téléphone un
ballon à ben merde et le match om ben
ali rien santé qui a joué donc en fait
tu savais de base qui est le match tu
étais là chez toi bien comme il faut tu
avais mis tu t'étais vers 7 à petit
diarrhée tout à temps le match est à
balanod tiff du coup je vais pas la télé
quand même assez bon studio à la
nautique n'est pas arrivé voilà 17h foot
à la boutique arrivant par mr d'une
match à 15 heures du coup tu regardes
veut le résumé quand même pas deux jours
s'est passé c'est très dommage
ouais donc juste pour revenir sur
cela parce que cette grünfeld
ouais donc contrairement à l'autre jour
on a élu food et de
baboo bouffe ou des deux donc on a
expliqué car 3d du fond ces trois là en
fait carnaval à une principale il fait
ou 4 et donc on voir la structure avec
des points donc cette pudeur pour les
blanches avec des 5 ou quoi donc fou g7
ok il joue la ligne avec fous ces quatre
à en développer le cavalier pour qu'il
vienne à eux deux et pas qu'ils aient
trop 3ème de clouage ouais
c'est 5 qui a lieu du coup mieux qu'en
f3 pour pas se faire clouer
les crocs kaïs et 6 fautes 3 et tout ça
pour dire que fuji 4 est quand même une
option pour les noirs et c'était le
sujet du débat dans les matches
karpov caspar à quoi la vente de ces
villes parce que c'était joué a sévi en
fait trois sets c'était fou g4 f3 cassin
et karpov il faut croire que cet organe
mis un pion et turf étrangers 4 mais il
ya une pression sur le centre
d'excellence c'était le débat
après sûr qu'il ya cinq les blancs pour
objet de prendre un peu de recul et le
fou et genre food & 3
etc décédé fois au cices et là en fait
il ya tous peuvent qui n'est pas le
parti en jouant des cinq fils en la
qualité
tu peux faire f6 si tu touches aux
fouilles à foicy sanguine direct la
qualité
est ok avec bénéfices puisque on a
construit notre gros centres et les
normes pas pu mettre sous pression
talent qui est à 5m bls qui et c'est
très bien placé
ouais donc ouais il est si sûre frein
pour point de me plaindre parce que des
pro 2 6 4 l'homme prenait 3,6 idiot et
juste vous jouez pour les compressions
ecublens
métaux grifols deux parties avec ça pas
mal et petit à petit je sais pas
l'enfoncer sortie de mode se fout g4
alors je sais pas si objectivement c'est
quand même vraiment du pôle et blanc
quoi mais en tout cas ça a pas l'air si
simple j'en pratique et nord sont plus
dirigés vers des cibles
idées sur des français 5 en général
c'est pas de reprendre c'est juste de le
jardin de cesser à tout quoi et sur ces
bab tokyo - mais tu as toutes tes pièces
active
tous les quatre un plan alerte revenir
sur les cases cailloux 5 10 à 5 je sais
pas dur à dire mais tu vas jouer à fond
et il ya largement assez de compensation
ok donc car en appelant ces cinq là
c'est normal et prestataires vrai je
suis pas au courant de la main la
théorie quoi juste ça je peux le dire
pour
nous que l'histoire de cette ligne
on me demande quelle différence entre
karen y ait eu deux époux 3
c'est juste une autre variante n'en a
donc fait avec d'amd 2g à tourcoing
ouais c'est autre chose d'autre
c'est juste complètement autre chose
dans ses passes à la ou ccd ça est un
machin qu'est
ce qu'on fait tous les quatre ou pas
aussi
je veux pas sûr quand je faisais 80 dans
sa main
mais tu vas faire ses
basses toi pas très bien mais bon il y
avait redonné de reprendre
bizarre et je poste un homme juste à la
théorie comme ça on chez domus
esquiverait paru logique avec les noirs
c'est pour ça que chaudement
[Musique]
du coup vous voulez jouer au 8e 1
donc c'est possible bien sûr
mais pas vraiment jeu au niveau
bon en général les noirs cook est ici si
peut-être on se pose et du cou
ça se fait qu'ils aient saisi ce qui est
de toute façon ça va être plus ou moins
jeunes et si fait d'amener de la disant
ouais comme des deux méthodes alcan
m21 ok tu peux mais peut-être j'ai
cherché ici sur les drogues les cieux du
président attend église que ton soit
beaucoup plus fort que le mien j'ai un
peu baissé le tien
ouais ça y'a de katie souhaite peut-être
fait plus précis plus soir sans badge
attaques des 4
mais c'est sûr qu'il y ait deux jeux
roxy je laime blessures non
brad b6 la partie ouais oui au pire ça
transpose qu'enfin je crois qu'il ya pas
c'est pas la fête mon avis dont vous
parlez c'est s'en fout c'est quatre ans
fête des fous autres au septième ouais
mais là c'est complètement autre chose
bah ouais enfin toujours en effet quatre
un jour mais l'idée c'est que tant tu es
fou 3 pour évacuer la tour 1 en b1 en c1
tu as tout enlever de la diagonale et
tue c'est autre chose mais c'est cher
c'est juste une autre variante jarre ses
cinq tours c1 ou un truc comme ça c'est
un autre monde quoi c'est à notre tour
mais fo 3/8 jeté ma façon je connais pas
spécialement je crois que c'est que de
faire ce débat
c'est même pas une vraie variant entre
hockey moyer tour c'est un cas 5-fu des
trois lames décès dont c'est assez
logique car il veut aller taper le pion
des 4 way
juste pour dire b si c'est pas le grand
coup mais c'est jouer
c'est un peu la mode quoi
dixième à des guildes des dames c'est
cette d'abord ok
peut-être qu'il a d'autres ambitions
pour saddam mais ça a été jouée par par
des bons matches mais pas en train
d'égaliser en force et si ça
d'avoir une idée fabiano forcément bon h
quatre nouveautés en tout cas mais je
dois dire il n'y avait pas de très gros
joueurs car première heure j'ai toujours
pensé à tout repenser un tour sévices
qu'il a fait h5 pas je dis ça parce que
j'ai l'impression quand échange les
tours encore
j'ai du mal à voir de la tacc pour les
blancs perso je la ressens qu'il ya très
peu de pièces
toi je ne discute pas juste prendre
prendre et peut-être même faire un coup
comme dams et 8
alors est-ce que
ce qu'on joue la finale
bon mon avis vous plantez une épine dans
la justice il va faire ça ça et ça
fouette fit tu dois
est
ok
mais ça ressemble pas à ce genre de
final quoi déjà view des noirs iphone 6
fawcett qui ramène un peu le roi mais
qui leur fût elle fixée avec ce pion là
le cabinet raffour sur g5 non mon avis
il n'y a pas de grand problème pour les
noirs mais
tu peux jouer la montre
bien sûr c'est un petit plus pour
libérer je garderai bien les dames
qu'avec les bleus ont tenté en fait mais
sachez va ce monde ou personne
mais du coup tu vas faire quoi
également en trois
occasions mais j'en ai fait foi et fuite
c'est que je vais aussi cavalier ces
quatre
noms peut-être on ne peut pas faire ce
qu'on veut
ou alors ok en échange les dames on se
laisse échanger h6 d'alors
admettant je bouffe ouais
ça dépend si on veut le cas et faire un
dessin qui est des quatre points brahim
et on vous prend ouais mais bon moi j'ai
pas lu ans d'expérience de ses positions
mais est ce que on peut jouer sur les
pièces noir ou courte il valait à 5 qui
nul pourra virer le foot 17 et le
ramener en b sat on va perdre du temps
on commence par une majorité sa patte si
simple les avancées et les blancs ils
veulent te faire du cahier des quatre à
voir le roi qui va plus vite au centre
ou à tarif 3 ou 4 qui s'est pas beaucoup
le remonte petits trucs comme ça
toujours surveillé 6,1 kg cinq jours qui
t'arrive parce que h7 peut être en pls
non mais c'est un petit plus c'est vrai
un peu plus tard pour les blancs après
comme je dis moi je suis pas une fan
avec les noirs et je joue pas des cas
très clément donc j'ai pas l'expérience
ses positions donc je peux pas te dire
exactement à quel point c'est mieux ou
quoi ça me semble plus agréable vu comme
ça mais je sais assez probable que
ça rentre l'attend à mon avis
honnêtement bah ouais tu sont vus qui
vient de jouer tour consistance et villa
park et en français
non oui il l'a pas fait mais
bon ok il veut juste débroussailler les
tours quel ordre ils proposent certes
aux français en trois sets 7-6 ok ça
stoppe des 5 ça se comprend
six parce que non mais une fois la fuite
quand même donc on fera pas des 5 et que
les blancs mais ce qu'on peut jouer trop
de choses
franchement j'ai du
mal à croire que ça puisse poser
d'énormes problèmes après la tête
analysé la faune et voilà l'affairé
difficulté 1 en tête le roi noir là
j'aimerais bien gardé les allemands fait
il sera jamais 100% sec je dois
organiser de fer ou cinq plutôt qu'à de
0,4
à voir enfin
qu objectivement ce sens est allé pour
les noirs oui mais
faut voir
au caire guarding c'est nazi
ont fait pareil que tout à l'heure je
passe
rapidement le début de partie grisou qui
réfléchit toujours un mais un sens vous
avait prévenu
jusque là c'est tout est connu on venait
d'apprendre que des allégements à la fin
mai ouais donc c'est une vente de
catalan
baï qu'un pion isolé ouais ok
bon mais le truc posé une question sur
des 4
as tu prends il peut reprendre du pillon
mais si ces records assez d'options très
bon si les femmes sont ces sites arrière
mais bon ce n'est pas la mienne hors jeu
voilà déjà vu des partis comme ça qu'ils
faisaient des nuls à
ses pions c6 qui semblait donner un
avantage mais au final ça donnait pas
grand chose c'était parce qu'il a ce
mobile oui oui je fait cette science
c'est quand les blancs de mettre une
pièce en c5
alors en cavale ouais ça c'est toujours
pénible
on en est loin
mais peut-être ok je sors tout ce qui
est processus
est ce que ces trois éléments
et
je pense très égale
dames c'est simple foncez pas mal
d'un v6 shirts doit aller mais qu'elle
prend des cinq qui apprend
cet ouvrage 5 a plongé de un peu mieux
et c'est peut-être juste égal mais
peut peut-être prétendre à un petit truc
un jour ou pas mais bon tant qu'à faire
quoi faire perdre mc5 interdire ça
ok donc ça on va dire on va voir mais
guérissant bien préparé
sa féminisme et l'aller tout le film est
intéressant
ouais c'est intéressant ça ouais j'ai
six jeux dans une des ventes qui te
force à vue des quatre et clémence te
pas de son trou noir
oui ce fameux truc que tu connais pas
par al
oued hockey
ouais me semble que
j'ai pour toi qui es leucate aussi
battant mais l'aja joue à cinq
combattants donc s'acheminer vers une
partie à mpl ding ding annuel plutôt
position là on va de choc en la position
cents à 5 mois genre cahier de
recettes ne s'est pas enfin je connais
alors de couper trois mais disons qu'on
va souffrir cinq baies 3
caves et leucate je crois que c'est le
bon de cool
bon tu te places au centre en général
les blancs ils te font genre tous les
deux ou quoi parce que et c'est 3
forcément oui ça arrive qu'il y ait des
sept
cas les h4
qui a aidé deux dames des deux faux 6 4
tu es là pour ça vous fout prend fois je
crois en toi et
auquel genre truc tu vois c'est le genre
de structure ce la veille compagnie quoi
c'est assez solides pour l'un
alors là la différence c'est qu'on a
fait à 5 kits façon et pas un mauvais
coup dans leur structure
dubé 3.5 qui fondent les deux bombes ont
fait juste les blancs se développèrent
un coût plus vite les noms j'ai un coup
utile parce qu'à 5 s'est jamais mal tu
peux faire à quatre
exactement tu affaiblis le pion b3 ou
faire à trois un moment pour que le four
b2 savent plus trop où aller mais par
contre est-ce que qui avait lieu au cap
ça reste une option comme d'hab ou pas
ça reste à voir on attend de moins pour
devoir
oui
ça peut changer un truc
bon après la mission n'est pas juste
qu'un haut cadre on jouerait à 4 et donc
c'est un peu différent de ce n'est sur
la rente donc je pars là bas oui car il
ya quatre ans quoi qu'il en soit pour
les blancs
à presque effrayant h4 le truc il va
t'aider à faire au 4 mai il est mal
placé tiens on va regarder tant le
ramener parce qu'en fait si jamais on
pouvait plus tôt le mettre en jeu 5
touchez pas aux on serai plus satisfait
mais d'un autre côté va chasser le fou
et permettent de faire le 4 c'est ça
voilà donc se hâter pour du combat passé
souvent sans oser chacun tard armand
tout ce que tu veux en claquant des
doigts
tu donnes pour gagner quelque chose
c'est l'avantagé partie pédagogique
après
sélection les gens te donnes tout quoi
bon prendre
donc voilà
mais ça pareil hein je pense y ait eu
beaucoup de parties à mon avis à quatre
c'est le coup je peux l'être chez qui un
peu la bastille de te dire attends je
vous fais un petit tour des stades
hongrie choo qui a réfléchi depuis
presque une demi heure non maintenant
ils 12h39 les ajouts toutefois avant
donc oui plus ou moins
bas j'avais prévu 45-50 minutes c'était
une blague mais c'était pas moins grave
en ce qui concerne a battu vannes et pau
c'est exactement ce maladie prise prise
dams et 8 h 6
donc ça va être la finale dont on vous a
parlé d' inc rna niche qui est france et
6 des français 6 c'est ce qu'on vous
avait dit aussi tour c'est un tour b 8
bon allez il analyse à fond et à mon
avis analyses égalisé assez facilement
qu eric
frey faut voir parce que geri pour
l'instant juste il va pas impressionné
par son niveau de jeu ces prépas sont ni
qu'alain sait très bien ce qu'il fait
mais
mais après dans une partie qui va durer
ou quoi il peut essayer de de crédit
soucie pas trop tu vois un truc long
terme on a vu par un grand groupe
l'audition qui allait très bien non oui
mais plus ça allait moins ça allait et a
fini par perdre un pion et sylvain
gauthier plus précis le baptême est
finalement
donc disons-le à l'ouverture se passe
bien pour lui il a aucun problème ce pas
dire qui va faire nul en sifflotant pour
autant
non mais ça veut dire qu'ils égalisent
et
oui
bon je laissais un peu la partie de du
joueur français en grand écran et foot
comme au foot dominer n'est pas gagner
échec égaliser n'est pas fair nul qu il
peut encore perdre juste son niveau de
jeu
c'est encore possible ça reste dans la
normalité je ne saurais même pas très
étonnant d'ailleurs
excuse pour te le dire femmes excuses
donc à la blague tf qui disent qu'on
pour faire défiler à partir de maxime
là tu as le temps un
way excuse pour te le dire ceci une
trace de ben laden évidemment excuses
mais des fois il te dit des trucs très
gentils en plus fantastique mais il
s'excuse quand même on ne sait jamais
excuse bas courtoisie
[Rires]
ça c'est une berlinoise innovantes
cliqué tout cas déjà joué il ya trois
jours et g4 c'était pas le coût auquel
était confronté mon bien sûr il a pris
en passant c'est logique parce que si la
perception h c'est justement pour lutter
contre ça parce que si tu laisses f4 f5
ouais c'est toute l'idée où il voulait
plus s'entraîner et et voilà
dur à gagner excuse pour te le dire mais
ton match a été très bon mais il peut
vraiment vous sortir une phrase comme ça
je te jure il peut tenir un tel truc il
est très désolé de te le dire quand même
excuse pour le lui dire tu vas ouvert
une bonne bouteille de vin ce soir
bref vous excuser aussi s'il est pas
d'accord avec toi
justement
c'est aussi beau que c'est justement en
fait nous et menaçant justement
l'existence et vos dents mais en fait il
est logique le justement saisir c'est
juste que tu dis quoi avait en fait il
veut dire justement pour te contredire
aussi
mais quelque part en fait c'est que ce
que tu as dit est tellement con que tu
es censé comprendre que justement tu
attends en fait
mais oui mais c'est un peu comme une
fausse annonce à la belote quoi
tu peux faire des fausses annonces il
est vrai par ton jeu de cartes tu fais
comprendre à l'autre
bracke n 10 mais je trouve même pas
d'équivalent en russe en fait il laisse
en douce et expressions bah je sais pas
justement que c'est ça qui est le plus
beau
là c'est son propre langage comme ouais
bah m'excuse pour te le dire ccvo quoi
c'est moi te dire un truc gentil après
c'est tellement il a attendu
escuses
bon alex nko'o jouer à quatre dont
quelques coups que l'on s'attende à et
qui est le nom du truc
sk d'aller devant les chiots il part se
promener s'affaler faut aller sur le
live de la fidh pour pouvoir le le voir
sacha ne joue plus bas bon là ça reste
dans la normalité quoi ça fait une
justement bonne du milliard qui
réfléchit tête 35 minutes moi je pense
qu'on peut s'attendre quand je dis 50
min tout al heure et 25 minutes juste
après j'étais dans la vérité un
bain
ben lobb
mais si on n'a plus les pendules si si
si on les a c'est juste après le coup
elle se met en avant à jour comme comme
tous les autres jours en fait
on a les pendules juste
elle tourne pas pendant les coups elle
se met à jour après que les joueurs
jouent
sacha est mal non c'est théorique
après peut-être une idée sympa pour les
blancs avec maxime
justement à une idée pour mettre en
difficulté dans ce cas en tout cas on
verra bien mais l'a pour l'instant
d'après tout ce qu'on connaît
l'historique des variantes et tout ça
bah écoutez
y'a pas à dire et ça ne se joue juste
ils te disent avoir mauvais karma il
amène là nul il est possédé par l'esprit
de guiry c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois que
tu commentes c'est que des parties de
merde 1res et de maquis jeu là c'est
impressionnant quoi
c'est un crâne enlevé les deux par
ailleurs partie très intéressante partie
3 tu es arrivé petit nul insipide contre
guéri
une berlinoise
c'est extraordinaire ben cependant qu'il
fallait que l'an dernier
non mais c'est pas mal c'est le
calendrier qui te fait en fait mais
c'est impressionnant penchard c'est
vraiment incroyable j'ai de la chance je
vais pas commenter tous les jours donc
de temps en temps ça serait intéressant
demain c'est yannick on va avoir une
belle partie voilà
non mais c'est vrai mais après tout on
peut pas dire tu es un chat noir parce
que c'est des nuls et c'est pas des
mauvais résultats bah c'est bien quand
la plus incertaine oui mais c'est quand
même avoue que c'est extraordinaire
ouais ça va
mais t'en a pas marre tu te dis pas j'en
peux plus quoi
souffre j'aimerais -
valiant ni peut-être qu'il a juste
besoin de se poser se remémorer tout sa
prépa elle est inquiète avec reach façon
oui mais c'est possible en plus qu'ils
sachent le coup qui va jouer mais qui
réfléchissent pendant une heure je suis
sûr on va te dis ce que je m'aime bien
sûr mais il le fait tout le temps et je
sais pas pourquoi il fallait par contre
ces maladies
non mais c'est une maladie
c'est sûr que c'est maladif
c'est ce qui va jouer mais il a envie de
rester tranché pas bon il va réfléchir à
réfléchir
non mais attends je vais pas à quoi ils
pensent qu'à ça sourit je pense même
plus la position
quoi sert de réfléchir 59 tu connais le
coup il n'ya que sacha un qui le fait
bah ça sert à rien en fait mais qu'est
ce que tu veux te dise
pas d'être kitsch au fond ça calcule ils
calculent ils s'entraînent et après il
peut je sens et notre séquence non mais
j'en retiens je peux pas expliquer c'est
le seul mec au monde à faire ce à quoi
après en france on avait un mec comme ça
c'était son tour au mans
c'est exactement ça a été tout un tas
une note après vingt coups il y avait
une minute à la pendule ou deux il
jouait tout m pour
ses incroyables mais il pouvait enfin
qu'est le pire qu'ils aient faim
en terme de deux trucs comme ça c'était
un match par équipe
il avait les noirs ils jouaient contre
c'est que c'était le mec s'appelait dieu
ouais donc et lui il adorait jouer h
trois premiers vous
bon arrive la partie joue h3 bon sens
toaff
il a mis 50 minutes à jouer 5
mais pourquoi pourquoi bah c'est pas il
conserva calculer toutes les variantes
les ouvertures possibles quand est ce
que je crois c'est utile ou pas utile
est-ce que ce que s'il veut
5,4 joue une écossaise inversé ou en
espagnol je sais pas il peut te faut pas
été comme big show qui pourrait faire tu
joues à acheter
ouais c'est je sais pas jarre mois gt5
ou des sapins vraisemblance j'ai fait re
5 je pense mais
[Musique]
écoute
s'en fout ouais mais surtout qu'en plus
tu le sais qu'ils jouent ça tu peux y
penser avant quoi mais ça trouve il
avait pensé avant mais si oui je veux
bien sûr et c'était comme ça mais en
plus pareil sans toi je vais très bien
les attentes
obama il joue plutôt aux échecs quand je
sais pas s'ils s'étaient mis à faire du
backgammon à fond je pense que les mets
peut-être champion de france il est bon
dans plein de jeux mais il a été
champion de france deux ou trois fois
dans sa vie les années 90
il était grand maître et voilà moi je
jouais avec lui pendant quelques années
au club de montpellier début les années
2003 2004 par là mais très sympa tout
doucement mais aux échecs tu sais bailly
l'aï voulu réfléchir
imaging ridge qui arrive avec une demi
heure de retard à la partie je vous le
vertueux il se remet à y refaire une
réflexion 58 non mais en fait s'il avait
s'il est arrivé avec une demi heure de
retard alors j'ai plus vite pour lui ça
change pas grand chose c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il est aussi ferrand blitz
d'ailleurs
ni sa note
justement il m'a dit qu'il s'ennuyer en
fait tant les partis mais je sais pas
c'est un peu contradictoire en réaliser
en fait gris touche dermatite été super
actif et loubards des coups partout
non mais il a assez contradictoire dans
sa manière fait je peux dire tout et son
contraire fait remarquer justement
vraiment fait remarquer que ce qui dit
parfois en conférence de presse c'est
pas du tout la même chose que il te dit
quand tu as fait une soirée avec lui
donne la confiance de poids s'il veut se
marrer fait
sortir de trois punchline comme il aime
bien
oui
mais j'ai remarqué que
c'était ça pouvait être assez
contradictoire ce que ce qui t'a dit et
ce qui va regarder conférence de presse
peut-être que la vérité c'est encore une
troisième version quoi il n'y a pas de
vérité
soyons sérieux fabien ibiza fils qui
met du coup away difficile à dire
je sais pas peut-être qui sait même pas
lui même nom même suivant qui sait pas
lui même
mais là en fait ouais donc ce qu'on
disait cette position a eu lieu deux
fois dans la base deux fois n'a qu'avec
les noirs qui a fait une fois en
réfutant bull est content maxime et une
fois qu'ils avaient lieu cette
withers a longuement il a vécu ça devant
maxime génère quand jules est les rois
et free quand on leur montre qu'on ne
guérit
donc on rappelle qu'à les eaux cette
l'idée c'est que ce qu'edf 5 fait plus
rien donc on l'enlève au pire on passage
en plus on attaque un peu h3 et le k way
pour rebondir notamment en d5 publicis
puisse éclater ou angers 6 parfois pour
s'en prendre aux curieux 5 ouais mais
j'aime bien ces quatre cas ce qu'il est
inattaquable
tu peux le mettre à la main ces capteurs
non mais je tu le tiens
tu as tu le tiens sans rien faire ouais
donc l'inattaquable il attaque à trois
il attaque à cinq qui peut être
renforcée par des 500 villes et les
cellules ça casse parfait tant
qu'ils avaient les bloqueurs devant les
pions et ses terrains et les north
active et c'est donc logique doit faire
ce plan après c'est assez chronophage
que tu prends pas mal de couples
cavaliers y
il est lent à déplacer mais
c'est le bon plan polmar
donc les blanches cvac ce qu'ils veulent
pousser h et gênant
on va du curieux de cette partie parce
que les peaux à très mal jouer la
position
il était très mal payés mal contre comme
quelque chose qui a toujours il ya trois
jours et
après peut-être sais pas si idiot tu
viennes du temps je sais pas comment
enfin mais c'est hyper concret en feutre
un maxi en fait c'est sûr qu'il est bien
préparé il allie tiennent à lui passé du
temps dessus etienne c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs bas-rhinoise marqué
leur vie ce n'est pas didier un truc
comme ça et ça fait un très lent je vois
la tour lehman oui mais c'est juste pour
un peu illustré et kelly bessa qui est
très mal tu n'as pas tout le monde est
mal mais c'est juste pour illustrer un
peu comment ça peut se passer avec une
ligne ce mini ordinateur est
oui mais bon
mais dans le coup et maxime il doit
avoir des idées comme ça juste très
concrète donc difficile à expliquer
parce que bon on n'a pas lu une sortie
et puis on n'a pas fait le même travail
en amont mais donc je suis curieux de
voir parce que
c'est intéressant se disant vu la
pression comme ça j'aime bien
aimé moi aussi mais déjà le 2 c'est
plutôt bien pour les tenir après c'est
sûr qu'ils étaient très concrètes
qui peut inclure à sa crise depuis un
moment typique mvl des choses comme ça
non mais sûr que
great show qui doit dire la même chose
que nous il va jamais trouvé ce cri
l'idée mais il va quand même se dire je
vais réfléchir une petite heure quand
même
bon après tout qu il a quand même dû
réviser ce qui va jouer non pas un zerg
et maxime joué 4 maxime c'est un des
joueurs qui rentrent principalement dans
la finale de la bernoise il peut refuser
des fois il l'a déjà fait d'autres
lignes mais fier de habanos elle a
jamais embêté d'y entrer dedans donc il
accepte le défi et un puce great show
qui s'est dévoilé il ya deux rondes en
faisant ça compte dépôt donc en fait en
plus que tu en vises est
évidemment tu dois avait près avoir
trouvé amusant mais at-il réviser son
cher
et en plus c'est la journée de repos
hier
ouais non mais
quel jeu c'est juste aux scandinaves on
sait pas pourquoi la plus cynique dati
connait tous la plaie chine 1 c'est beau
comme cette histoire de berlinoises
réfuté alors que les genres égalise
encore en force
non mais tu ne sais pas
c'est marrant quoi bomber goûter un
caruana aussi une petit avion il n'y a
pas un tueur a pas de finale du courage
si
c'était ou qui a pas changé dans l'arrêt
mais c'est bien sûr et pas de finale
justement fouet fuite des cinq ou six je
ne t'ai change pas les dames en c1 et
maintenant tu n'es change solidarité c3
beaucoup de mes pages
jaunes est déjà présent ce qui fait
juste parce que l'excellent jeune
mannequin
oui c'est marrant les prépas de caruana
m'ont semblé plus tranchante avec les
noirs qu'avec les plans
avec les blancs il a défoncé avec ce
nouveau come back des six qui et b5
machin à moi ça me chef 3 c'est vrai
aussi les clés noires au bacon bio s'y
met la plus de soucis elles ont fait un
truc qui n'existe plus ou moins mais il
se cachait a été noire avec des gars il
est il a eu à préparer contre eux dit
mme est d'ailleurs alors c est qu elle
fait un mode quand eto'o sur ce sac on
ne sait pas de quoi il sait pas lui même
non si tu te dis ça égalise au 38e coup
quoi enfin d'accord enfin c'est
compliqué mais il pense que ça va mais
que caruana a mélangé son fichier
sur mon nom mais en fait quand même se
souvenir tout bien sûr son insecte des
prend re ca 4 5 4 mais il arrive réviser
s'il a t'il vous vers le fichier une
seule fois dans sa vie quoi mais c'est
quoi le moment on sait déjà qu'il y ait
fugué en
ph 6 très mal joué
mais carey léger si sûr
j'ai besoin que je vais me doucher
j'espère que grisha aura joué
en fait après il nous fait une pause
maintenant ou de la pause soit après
1h30 de jeu j'ai eu différents mais ça
sera la même chose prends ton temps
quand même un monsieur pétrole je pense
que tu as le temps là il doit être
à peu près à 50 me traite jamais
vraiment je sais dit 50 minutes j'aurais
j'aurais visaient même avant un bain
peut-être
tu te mets la petite musique la petite
bougie tranquille et les petits celles
et tous dans l'eau devient très beau il
revient dans une heure il a toujours pas
à jouer il lui reste trois minutes à la
pendue
c'est vraiment rond dormi
et 10 qui lui reste 57 minutes donc ça
veut dire qu'il réfléchit avec les 40 il
à 47,8 de réflexion la
cfu en
mai organisée mais j'ai l'impression que
personne n'arrive à profiter des
designers de gris tout prix mais il est
capable de te faire ligne numéro un de
leurs dix pendant dix coups
donc peut-être qu'en fait ils jouent
parfaitement tu as not c'est un vrai
problème
bah en fait apparemment ça fait tilt et
des mecs au début ouais après sa vie du
ca pour moi c'est comme tous les
meilleurs coups c'est comme ça c'est le
vip
mais genre maximy watch plus comment
parler de web os est vrai qu'au début
c'est hilton le mec à 35 jours des jo
plus loin de l'ordi est encore encore
encore bref juste eu cet iphone qui voit
la fin du 8e art pas de charge pas je
t'aime moi non plus
mais c'est vrai tellement énervant
mais c'est le sale au monde quand même à
faire ça j'aime jamais vu ça de jeu chat
on peut hélas parce que une nouvelle à
twitté pendant la partie mais s'est pas
levé avec une scie nadja rouge ce qui
évidemment c'est pas lui tout seul qui
allaient twitter
mais du coup je suis en train de me dire
non ça va genre à me dire est ce que tu
as le droit de faire recruter quelqu'un
d'autre sur ton twitter perso
mais oui un de gens qui ont quelqu'un
ils sont jamais sur twitter votre jeu
c'est déjà pour pas se polluer la tête
ce sont des insultes ou je ne sais quoi
peut perdre du temps à faire un truc
mais ces quelques mots j'ai bossé à la
fidh bon ça va durer très longtemps mais
je leur ai proposé de mettre des
téléphones
aux joueurs des téléphones
qu'ils soient contrôlés et où qu'il soit
bloqué avec que twitter c'est faisable
technologiquement et que les joueurs
puissent vraiment aller twitté pendant
la partie nasa bolides et du
confessionnal mais beaucoup mieux en
fait parce que j'avais le confessionnal
en réalité pas faut être sur la vidéo et
par personne va les regarder un extrait
vidéo que vous avez posté fin il faut
faire le montage le machin jardi alors
que le tweet c'est très marrant tu peux
les affiches et immédiatement à l'écran
le mec peu trop laissé beaucoup plus
drôle pour l'idée n'a pas été retenue
mais peut-être dans 15 ans quoi
valide est excellente avec quelqu'un de
stockgroup basse l'approprier oui bien
sûr enregistrer mon idée
oui j'ai proposé ça ya très longtemps
j'aurais dit oui c'est beaucoup mieux
votre confessionnal ils m'ont dit non
bah t'as palmarès du confessionnal ça
n'existe plus enfin moi je dis si
c'est beau quand même
et en plus ça aurait été bien le
problème c'est que l'autre vois ton
tweet non mais tu peux organiser un
téléphone et faire développer une à
plein mais tu crées un compte où tu
voles aux personnes
non sur leurs comptes perso en fait mais
juste ou alors tu écris ton tweet sur un
truc est ce l arbitre qui le tue pas
voir les arbitres qui twitte pour toi
non mais enfin il suffit de créer un
compte où tu follow personne c'est juste
des gens de suivre tu souffres
l'auberson saison mais c'est hong kong
joueurs c'est pas ton compte ou tu perds
m pas du tout pas du tout l'idée c'était
de développer le twitter et les réseaux
sociaux des joueurs pour qu'ils aient
plus de sponsors occident alors perso
non mais tu lis les deux comptes non
t'as le compte pendant les parties et à
leconte ou tu rends compte que tu viens
on va vraiment un conte tu twittes
vraiment sur ton vrai compte en fait
ouais mais ok c'est wolf invoqué la
folie trouve une appli où tu n'as pas
accès aux trucs aux autres tweet battu
l'année
mais je veux dire c'est pas si dur de
faire un compte ou duflot personnes
aussi oui mais l'intérêt c'était de
développer pour que les joueurs aient
des sponsors et que ça rapporte de
l'argent à chaque en fait est que veux
tu as ton compte perso retouche
automatique les trucs que tony c'est
possible ou alors tu pourrais juste
écrire le truc tu aurais un fichier note
t'écris la note elle a envie de faire un
copier coller et il le met sur son
twitter falgère ya quinze mille manières
de l'organiser
by gens c'est très facile à faire
non mais c'était vraiment une très bonne
idée ça aurait permis de faire un peu de
buzz et puis du coup c'est peut-être
marrant pour les gens qui sont sur
twitter qui suivent pas les parties ça
leur donne envie de jeter un coup d'oeil
fin
non de confessionnal beaucoup mieux
salut seniors du jeune
pharaon ya mille et une manières de le
faire c'était vraiment une bonne idée
mais ça pas été
justement
mieux le confessionnal
donc
qui est guéri ça bouge un peu c'est
intéressant
une fois devoir je pense gris
noir et de bronzage sont
ces thématiques terre
oui mais en fait ça me fait penser un
bond de la tâche
de l'inde du beauf tout ça tu as
minguettes juste faire h4 oui mais c'est
typique de ce total nous le
souhaiterions parce qu'on fait tout
arrache la à l'onu ou de l'ue attend
juste un truc et là il n'ya pas d'armes
français s'estiment et non pas un je
sais pas pourquoi mais c'était possible
il l'a pas fait
mais je pense qu'il ya un énorme at li
commune juste trop de
temps la vie s'est passé fouet f5
admettons bah disons je suis assez vite
déjà
développé
le droit bordel
de paralysie
ça m'étonnerait spécial homme c'était
pour montrer
[Musique]
qu'il n'a pas appris la fêter ses trois
dates en mai ouest ligne mais oui qu'est
citron et se développe il se dirige vers
à 4 et s'est ouvert aux deux
à temps les gens ici fascht 4s que si je
veux juste car elle est à 4
il est maintenant est-ce que ça j'ai
idée d'homme g4 damage cinq compagnies
ou ch 3
ou les deux
très actif intéressant mais cette
pénible
mais digne ok ça peut peut être dans son
élément
j'ajuste chaussures sarenza ça va même
très bien
[Musique]
mais je sais pas du coup si on préfère h
3o
grh quatre noms mais mon chauffage saint
come on ou doit faire un jeu 4
pour aller vers des quatre mois ça te
coupe la dame
le stop peut-être les délais cachent
trois parce que possible qu'après
quelques 4 ce dernier est un mythe
option h3 trop mauvais donc elle a
souvent l'a interrogé
est ce que dame g45 où on fait juste fou
17 et compagnie
et jardinage cinq
tours bicis
jo désolation nordine je suis content
mais à 14 soit 6e mais on n'a même pas
de contrainte
alors attendre me dis que ça a joué du
côté de sacha bouquet mais on reviendra
pas faim comme tu vas peut-être aller
voir ça chaque année il ya découvrir le
vieux stade h4 il a joué comme dakar du
latin ouais
bon ben maintenant on est reparti pour
20 minutes ou
franchement si fait 50 et 25 jours était
quand même très visionnaire couple est
membre
de l'otan mais
si fait beaucoup bu autant ça veut pas
dire qu'il y aura gaffe de getxo
nom met d'ailleurs en fait il est même
pas mal autant de tous
malgré sa longue réflexion c'est en fait
la cadence 1h40 plus 36 secondes par
coup ce fait vous avez deux heures pour
le 40 coups donc la moyenne ces trois
minutes par coup
oui nous il avait 18 coups 18 fois trois
minutes ça fait une heure cap de
réflexion c'est ça ouais mais c'est nier
quand même un peu mal content que
56 minutes 1h51 donc ouais mais si on
compte que généralement l'essai du
premier coup d'une partie vont quand
même assez vite il est quand même un peu
mal au temps mais c'est rien du tout
surtout que ça peut devenir très facile
à jouer dans six sept coups
54e ça
mais il lui reste une heure quatre parce
qu'elle a et 30 secondes s'accumulent et
bien moi je les ai compris comme ça non
mais sans doute années 30 secondes qui
vont arriver après
moi j'avais compris ça comme ça quand tu
l'as dit 1h04 j'ai compris que oui tu
rajoutes le temps de venir
bref ouais bah écoute shebab un brassard
n'a pas grand chose à dire de plus sur
ce cas on retourne sur le c'était juste
pour voir si la plage quatre pieds de
ses vrais partis ou c'est nous qui avons
bougé alors c'est la partie belle saison
au guidon je m'attends à alger mais ça
qu'on a peut-être le temps de checker et
parce qu'on a des trucs qu'on n'est pas
prêt si pressé mais qu'on peut pas jouer
pour l'attack du coup peut-être juste
sous 17 et on va défendre le tube
touax est
je serai un spécial
noël blanc apprécie ou pas ouais je sais
jouer à trois maintenant
alors à 4 pourquoi ça
qu'est bon si cgh le problème on va
faire un g20
ou h3 je sais pas mais
non ça
alors à temps est-ce que les dames c'est
5 je pouvais faire à trois
mois le ca très
bon vous peut avoir de souci les dames
tard le 5 ce qu'on peut repartir et du
goût
alors je sais jamais jewel trop ça que
c'est une bonne question
ça peut dans une partie comme ça où ils
prennent le point clé blanc essaie de
défendre ne typique buuren qui a pas
peur
puisque c'est vrai que c'est bon pour le
monde du mal à venir en jeu
moi ça me ferait peur perso mais bon
ouais mais il n'est pas plus autre union
ça reste un pion
si tu défends tu as gagné mais
ça peut être genre de scénario qui
arrive un stuff
j'attendais à caroual a pesé ouais c'est
pas passé grand chose insisté ic3 il a
fait cai ces cas
là je me demandais un truc
c'était
ok c4 g7 vous pouvez faire des points si
bien décrit cette fougue et
4,9 autres places et un terme à terre
kessé car je pensais vraiment bien joué
parce que sur food et catherine talleu
sainte c'est simple ouais mais l on
attendait ce que c'est fini pour autant
soit on veut qu'ils aient ces trois
mêmes
[Musique]
qu'elle a indiqué p 5
d ça c'est bien mais bouffe choississent
pas mal tu vas être changer ça coince
ait eu à faire nul à mieux faire même si
son but sur un yatch six noms tout le
monde y est assez nul ça saigne et
larissa foot proposait donc qui est fou
des quatre peuvent non mais l'arrêt
d'autres non mais je monte à 2,5
qu'est-ce que plusieurs d'autres
faux f4 et sur re5
c'est ça le
hockey est âcre actions passées protégé
était peut-être content
web on prévoir ce qui est dit si son
bloc et compagnie mais d'aden entre hugo
blanc surtout chauve 6
alors attendre et se dire que sur
web
non c'est peut-être quelque chose pour
les blancs quand même car je préfère les
blancs mais
bon au moins encaissé 4 déjà les mieux
placés peut-être pas le temps de
concéder cinq noms mais clairement c'est
un avis c'est plus simple à jouer avec
les blancs mais je pense que
fondamentalement les noirs avec un peu
de précision ils s'en sortent
ouais ben c'est comme toujours en fait
ouais six blessés je ne sais pas ok wang
wang hao ok donc c'était la femme à 4
joué il a encaissé
25 comme métro à talbisseh qui est née
cette ouais j'ai vu que ça existait elle
ne peut pas prendre vsat parce qu'il est
tombé mi temps on
doit être encore plus ou moins c'est
vrai que cette histoire je veux dire
c'est débarquer sa part eric mais je
pense qu'ils connaissent pas moi ou il
sait à peu près ce qui se passe mais qui
a aidé cette île cd way quelques parties
cdc des trois ans
ouais bon il ya cinq parties dans la
base mais
papa pas de stars
bon normalement ça va pas les normes non
je parle français mais pas pour les
noirs maintenant j'entame prend 1,4 bad
as me prends un café l'addition je me
pose pourquoi
je crois tout ce qu'ils veulent faire
plaisir tu es tu veux faire un tour
c'est set mais a
admis m admettons même je fais un truc
massif jeu mais a tout enlevé huit
membres et ça va très bien pour le symbo
nul probable
est encore là on nage et même pas essayé
de jouer peut-être là ya même plus fort
que l'ordi te dis pas de faire ça a été
de faire un tour à 8 pouces et trois
cavaliers éviter surtout en 17 qui est
des six regarde c'est joli concept qui
est p 5 une foule d'autres ici
ce genre de scénario probable non mais
je crois que ça va facilement
et c'est même pas le seul coup un
génie qui prend ses trois tours pensée 3
et e5 ouais ça c'est pas facile 20 c'est
possible et du temps on va passer mes
deux fils images
je pense et des moyens plus simple de
jouer sans heurts a donné un pion non
mais il ya tout un tas de variantes qui
égalise d'un homme c'est
visuellement se
feront d un toit de tata classe tu m'as
trompé deux
noms mais ça se voit que c'est pas la
seule manière en plus c'est juste avec
voulais dire c'est que même sans quoi
ils donnent encore égal à l'embarras du
choix faut juste pas se tromper
non non ça va se passer de true crime je
conçois les deux parties les plus
intéressantes du jour c'est vraiment un
caruana dépôts et dingle guéri et
peut-être maxime enfin peut-être maxime
le rythme de jeu fait que se passerait
il va se passer des choses comme ça
voilà certes ça fait
plus d'une heure maintenant quand on est
plus ou moins au même endroit alors ok
il a joué cavalier c'est qui était une
décision mais je reste à peu près dans
la même position
mais je suis assez confiant pour maxime
quand même
j'attends de voir ce qui se passe
donc voir ce qui se passe voir quelle
est l'idée de maxime qui est ce qu'il va
faire ces deux variantes c'est un axe
est ouest
appareils
pour le moment
allez pour les noirs mais bon le fait
qu'ils réfléchissent autant ça veut dire
qu'ils s'inquiètent d'un truc mais
surtout parfois vaut mieux rentrer un
truc que tu aurais joué
et avoir du temps pour contrer la
nouveauté au moment où elle arrive
plus tôt que te mal autant je
trouve ça vraiment qu'à l'intérieur
je sais pas ce qui
en tout cas h4 c'est une nouveauté
officiellement la fsg 4 contre nac en
bullet
quelles sont les missions de mv lycée va
essayer de pousser ses pions g à achat
pour création passer et jouer sur le
fait que les pièces de great choc soit
mal développée
en gros 1
donc on va voir
les gens pensent encore qu'il prend 1,6
gagne du matériel mais attends moi aussi
ça est donc on ne pourra pas prendre la
torah h6
maintenant
mais je dis mal à voir exactement le
comment on va avancer les pieds et puis
faire rager deux tours à charge 5 g 4
l'espagnol papou vraiment du temps
bref deux tours h1 la ressource contré
par des fous des simples donc je sais
pas
exactement mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
imaginer la moindre décision de les
prendre le stis
de temps prend disons mais les pions
j'ai 4 h 5 et ses quatre jeux qu'on veut
aux cavaliers
on essaie de me tall paul roy mais c'est
d'héberger 5 h 6 à un moment un truc
comme ça servier au
carnage a suffi tourtes et 8 ouais j'ai
bien compris le problème
alors dit quoi il y tour des quatre ans
car ces cinq soit
d'ailleurs kg 90 mans
dont il faut se faire b6 dans ce cas si
cela oui on va te fait ces cinq en
sécurité c'est entouré d un schéma par
contre un truc et brt sur boursier com
c'est un de ces web mais même en
décembre et puis il ya besoin de faire
baisser pour visiter ces quatre opéras
et je suis un blocus sur cate blanchet
sarrance plus d'une heure tu donnes iota
non le problème aussi pour d'autres la
plénitude de choix
après donc calé cinq sud devant des
barbares pièces ou que marc est je pense
un coup très décent
je sais pas s'il y avait un vote mais je
n'en s'il n'a pas une idée à base de
sacrifice de fiancé le croire quand même
ces clans de l'infection qui est pour
9,4 ouais mais là encore je pense à la
plénitude de choix est ce que c'est si
mal de faire qu'ils prennent qu'un
droit c'est pas un truc comme ça et on
aime tenter non
pardon même à sac alors oui
un bref un nom c'est important mais bon
c'est pas un coup difficile à trouver
quand tu joues bah tu aurais fait tout
de suite pour la peinture la fuite et
tu consommes c'était plus la
donne en fait je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'options paul main je
sais pas quelle est la meilleure dur à
dire c'est très subtil mais tout est ok
quoi semblables mais il ya sûrement
maxime il connaît son plan il sait ce
qui va tenter de faire et on verra c'est
beau quand même si l'idée de la prépa
c'est de dire on l'a tout égalise très
bonne idée il va réfléchir pendant
longtemps
ben non mille et une idées je sais pas
ou parce que et yann ibos ils ont des
bons ordi et et dieni joue là bas
rhinois ça fait quasiment vingt ans j'ai
donc
il connaît très bien les qui détail qui
tue utilité souvent pratique donc même
si lors didier galy sec devant un
échiquier tu va galérer parce que ça
être oppressant psychologiquement ça
c'est un truc machin bon
ouais
en cas sur les critères qui vous
permettent de dire un moment de ré
précis de la partie et noir ont égalisé
pas juste on le sait une analyse quoi on
se rend compte que les noirs sont pas
plus mal au peuple mal
que les blank plus vraiment moyen de
mettre les noirs en danger ou en tout
cas ils ne les mettent pas plus en
danger que eux mêmes de leçons
comme ici par l'impression que n'est pas
alors il vient d'avoir hacké ces quatre
ans quatre dames français 4 honnêtement
là j'ai l'impression que les noirs
commencent à vraiment complètement
égaliser mais bon t'as dit encore des
trucs concrets et je pensais ciardi
dames des jeux secs d'amd a un truc avec
fougue et 4 mais je vous rappelle
quelque chose
il faut des quatre
indiens un
état pas le temps de prendre ce cas
d'amd huit fois et fuite et aux sept
sages avait pas vu à temps la siame
encore damas dame inquiète à me prend
enquête je repars le
[Musique]
et la bande à mener dont il vient de le
jouer
c'est tony karon ans et déjà tout
regarder déjà dans ce truc états on
n'est pas aux choses qui arrivent à s'en
sortir je pense n'est pas
si tu prends il me prendre du cavale et
le changeait pas son visage hors effet
des baisses et le roi un peu fun c'est
pour les plantes après à quel point
c'est si grave je sais pas mais
c'est entame le
plus c'est que tu as jamais vraiment
pouvoir mettre le fond en d6 en toute
sérénité ce que j'en ai je sais pas vous
mais cette mat
bon
ben je n'avais pas vu que dame des deux
était possible je pensais qu'ils
voulaient car tu vois
mais bon même la position vous regarde
elle enfin quand je dis vite fait avec
ed qu'ellison qui fout des 5 e d si on
fait juste d'hommes b4 et d'amd 6
d'amendés 6 us pour les histoires de bas
je compose une position comme ça je dis
pas à visiter de quoi jouer et aucun
intérêt à le faire mais bon ok
ok j'arrête 6 ou
presque est ce que à quoi est-ce qu'on
est exempt est ce qu'il ya un plan clair
pour les blancs après ça et que la dame
peut aller vers bessette un peu taquiné
les pions là bas laurent blanc est plus
en sécurité
et 6 jets paper fin je veux le faire bon
telmex si je peux pas me tente c'est
peut-être un peu bloqué ray
est ce qu'une finale comme ça juste par
curiosité
ou on attend plus ce que tu penses c'est
gagnant ça pour les blancs
je pense pareil 5 peut-être
des droits pour voir
quel con c'est pareil trois bourreaux
enfin j'ose un roi doit se reprendre
aujourd'hui un bris
l'hérault d'étranges
cherché autre côté des fous ça devrait
gagner 100 est d'accord je pense que
c'est beaucoup
de mineurs on n'obtient pas céder leur
fournir les des way venir aider à gauche
à droite
bon
c'est pas dit que c'était juste par
curiosité pour voir à quel point on ne
pouvait donner du matin avec les noirs
non mais du coup c'est important
d'arriver à juger ses positions et que
le pion dépasser qu'on peut bloquer
parce que si j'en ressens une sorte de
forteresse alors ils m'aiment parce que
c'est la tête si c'est un peu chiant et
salers avec dams et 2 d'amis ici enfin
même si trois de ses six ans
on pressent un peu faut chercher autre
chose et que non
c'est pas faux
il s'est pas enterrement simple la balle
est dans le camp de dépôt donc
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi
donc genre ok alors d'idylle food et 6
ne sais pas du tout s'il ajoute
en plus déjà les noms mais j'aime
beaucoup non mais plus je regarde déjà
ça ça ça va ça on voit
mal ce truc là ouais mais bon je crois
que ces versions améliorées de l'autre
oui oui mais cependant est-ce que c'est
pas un tout petit peu pénible quand même
notable mais le cou aux cinq surtout des
six juste nous qui te fait très peur
peut-être rentre pas là dedans à cause
de ça
parce que faut prendre des points
tu dois venir et continuer gens en leur
disant foot fait d'un match 4 contre
attaque mais ça c'est de s'assurer
jamais
donc ça c'est très simple est que
l'armée dit oui bon ça c'est bon ça fait
nul tu apprends à te fait roi prend la
tête on s'en fout tu vois bien voilà tu
fais chier toi ça avec leur nez et puis
après tu répètes ce que tu as déjà vu
mais tu rentre pas là dedans alors ça
c'est juste impossible
ok à moins de vaud qu'est ce qui fait
juste bravo ce sera fantastique de sa
part et il me restera le note de 10 mai
du coup si ça c'est vraiment le meilleur
coût pour les noirs et que tu peux pas
le jouer parce que tu veux pas
c'est un peu chiant du coup carla va
presser un peu
ouais ouais non c'est une bonne prépa de
caroil à
condom ont coûté griffe que ça toujours
pas à jouer on va jeter un oeil à ding
ça toujours pas joué non plus
vieri qui voit la pré carré lieu de
s'est mis à réfléchir enfin j'ai envie
de dire il connaissait bien jusque là et
où angao alors il a fait quoi il a pas
aussi
la parution pour le moment
kelkoo un tout une star y aura 6 bon
peut-être pour doubler tout reprendre un
4-3-1-2 je sais pas un peu mystérieux
mal de trous mais ça aille dans le sens
en plus quand tu prends un cas de toute
façon si tu reprends tu vas perdre un
tract à tour quoi
bon ne prononce jamais possible il ya
autour des 6
à trouver les tempêtes mais moi je vous
allez rester à tours c'est
comme ça j'avais vu ce passage il est
tombé 6 mai autour du site est très bas
du cou ce programme là
on aura quatre et tu renouvelles la
nasse tour des six programmes et du goût
de tous je bats web ont gagné trois
tours b 8 terme à quatre tours à 4
donc c'est toujours le constructeur kb
steelcase et 4 tuent presque partout
mais comme ça me semble loin loin loin
de là mais la plus simple du preneur
c'est pas faux mais ok
mais je suis pas je suis étonné bien
étonné par le cou au tour à 6 alors nous
demandent quelle est l'idée de la
nouveauté de maxime h4 je pense fait
c'est pas des pions qui était attaquée
en a je crois tu devrais tu le défends
tout bêtement et carélie des cinq
viendrait jour mon revient donc
c'est beau quand même d'avoir réfléchi
mais il arrive chez 1h25 au final reste
non américain qui voulait ferme est bon
là maintenant on va comprendre l'idée de
maxime ça va nous aider oui c'est là
qu'on arrive à comprendre l'idée enfin
il va nous montrer son disais quoi
pousser un don qu'il est le pion c3
c'est parce que c'est ce qu'on avait
regardé ces exactions subies à regarder
des français 3 tours détroit alors ok
question parce que pourquoi en vue de
parvenir en d5 déjà mais c'est ce qu'on
regardait et tour f1
et quads la
nature qui arrivera f3 et le curé vii un
peu en danger
il
y avait sept
je fais des conneries faim pendant
peut-être te prendre dès à 4 x 3 découle
tour quelque part c'est sylvie où tu eu
droit de san
mamés ok on sent qu'il ya une petit
potentiel pour faire ses cadres pour
machin mes clips et est d'accord bon ok
donc prendre ses trois tours détroit
machin ok c'est un problème donc faut
peut-être jeu autre chose avec nanard ne
pas prendre
mais à vrai dire du coup tu pourras
faire ces quatre avec tempo
on est peut-être penser à des cinq dans
un message à la casse et 5
5 ans et peut être même pas si mauvais
juste abysses de cavaliers dans place me
donne des signes ans c'est ça qui va pas
faire grand chose non plus juste à
moosch mais ce père ce mauvais et c'est
peut-être même des herbes
ce qu'a lire sur tourne autour des 3
peut-être du pouf
ouais non c'est bien une nouvelle
question jeu parce que 10h10 de kébé 6
juste on fait notre plan durant ses
gardes du coup c'était bien vrai oui
mais est-ce que g
12h44 vas-y bouge à tours joue pas ou
quelques pas
ouais
et en concert les primes sur des way sur
b sat aussi
bon alors que les stickers pour sa part
un maillage 5 normes et angers si j'aime
pas été tranchée
mais là je ne peux pas nick est
bon qui est tombé vite enfin norman
nato geht c4 etc et prend le sis
a plus défendu on peut pas trop toucher
au four à se rendre aussi s'en servir
partout mais elle rendu fou qui varient
venger ses avantages blanc c'est
ça a l'air assez pénible en fait
très bien bah en fait si t'es pas obligé
de défendre ces trois déjà sur
gruissan /
du coup du coup du coup je fais chier
moi je la sens bien pour maxime ça là
bas si gris ciocca font encore 20
minutes la pub 10 minutes et que ça va
être compliqué ouais pas le truc c'est
que qui a aidé 5 pouces et 1 c'est plus
ou moins ce qu'on avait imaginé nous
observe on avait pensé on s'était dit ça
peut être ça l'idée puisque mais il a
pris en c3 il accélère bon certes il est
prévu en fait j'espère et qu'il n'est
pas prévu et que ils doivent à notre
athénaïs top après moi
tu peux t'attendre à tous
tu sais avec des telles
tout est possible
mais il va se reprendre tempo là le truc
c'est qu'il se sucrent il faudra prendre
la très bonne décision parce qu on a vu
qu'avec les blancs on voit l'idée c'est
de doubler sur fr2 mirande et peut-être
faire du caillou quatre fous g5 donc il
ya pas mal de jeu dynamique et typique
est typique son jeu en fait je dynamique
fine un pion mais tu es là et leur 18e
recommande de faire incarner les
accablons un cavalier mevel évidemment
nos peut-être cette annulation bref on
va te faire des cinq
tours f4 et revenir vers b 6
mais je peux le comprendre tu contrôles
ces cas du coup tu installes ton fut un
des cinq qui protège l'option
est stable ouais mais bon mot tu pas
sorti comme le monde
c'est choquant
non mais en fait normalement grille tout
cas déjà plus ou moins d'alice déjà
pression peut-être pas celle là
précisément mais il doit plus ou moins
savoir laisser top à mettre en place je
vais juste par curiosité à avancer un
peu fade
c'est chaud hein c'est vraiment chaud
pour les noirs je trouve
5 rue 6 kg cinq tours
f4f 4 et revenir à m6 web
mais ça c'est quand même quelque chose
un peu troublante improbables
vont tenter de faire g5 h61 jours non
ça doit rester encore dans la normalité
je pense pour les noirs mais mais de
justesse comment jouer cette ouverture
quand tout le monde sait qu'elle est
réfutée
non mais moi je suis victoire de m
viennent je ne sais pas
c'est possible mais c'est très possible
il écoute lui les danses après pas tuer
les narcos s'étaient répandus donc oui
c'est vrai les trucs à faire après
si j'ai toujours trouve les meilleurs
coups je pense qu'il ya un nul mais il
faut pas le trou
c'est beau quand même que great chou ça
peut être aussi dans la prépare encore
simplement ils contemplent mais c'est
possible c'est possible si ensuite en
fait non mais c'est vrai c'est vraiment
possible
mais c'est parce qu'ils contemplent ont
fait sur facebook
elle se dit oui ok pas très respectueux
pour le public de faire nul en dix
minutes en gens tous les deux tempos je
vais faire semblant mettre un petit
suspense à la partie
bon mais là le truc c'est que on peut
peut-être un poil à rester là dessus
dans le sens à rejouer vite ouais on
sait jamais normalement oui oui mais
jalili peut pas mettre une demi-heure
pour son coût vice et puisque
[Rires]
tout est possible il est chef bon juste
enfin enfin tout petit tour mais après
ça devra accélérer alors il a fait
comment pour le coup je vais mettre un
coup de boule à zéro un besoin je prends
des cinq dépôts et va peu de
probablement entrer dans quel dessein
dessins que des dont on vous parlait
étudiante au doctorat
ding et carré lieu de foot et set et n'a
pas tenté de faire l'état mme c5 et des
cadres comme vous avez dit comme on
avait tenté il hamid karzaï en f4 et à
vrai dire il peut y avoir des idées à un
jour d'échangés les dames et revenir en
c5 avec le caral
et hao wang os abbas a pas bougé après
tout raciste non je pense qu'on peut un
peu restée la fapen sur la partie
joueurs français
qui est toujours porteuse qui est en
train de s'emballer femmes
bah ouais ça s'emballe
bon
locke leur préférence pour cavaliers à
quatre ans
de toute façon lorsqu'il a fait qu'il
est français 3 il savait bien que
maximiles le tour des trois quand même
non
peut-être pourrait-il et celles à tour
pris ce nom mais satan est quasiment sûr
par exemple tour d2 ça fait aucun sens
un
spread un con
mais je sais pas je regagne de réfléchir
une heure tu prends ces trois et tu vas
re réfléchir dix minutes mais laisse le
faire
non mais je peux tu comprends rien
pourquoi tu fais ça
il contemple et heureux bon c'est pas en
fait c'est lui il est dans son monde
non mais il a parlé de sa partie qu'on
ne sait plus qui contre les pocher plus
qui oui et ils y ont dit oui la partie
peut être ennuyeuse je sais pas quoi
donc à part regarder les échecs aïe ça
j'ai failli gagner
c'était un dépôt je pense non ces
condoms vieux
ah oui ces contes en gallo bâ il a fait
ça française des changes la fin c'était
la betterave thiam
démunis font en d2 d3 tous ces échanges
et
non mais sans rigoler la partie était
vraiment intéressante en réalité
mais bon je n'aime pas les échecs
comment faire
mon tour des trois écoutes
révélées à quatre ça semble
le coup préféré désormais les musiques
et les cinqs pas leur kata kata mais il
y avait déjà quatre meilleurs mais ça on
avait compris à des problèmes avec des
ces quatre noms mais éventuellement
il ya un deuxième problème je pense avec
le client des 5 c'est que tu solutionne
pas le à 4 x 3 totalement un sage des
touristes venaient
donc c'est aussi
bien des tracas pour ça je pense tu
laisses la caisse des cinq pour ton fou
analyse ces cadres étaient vite à 4 x 3
donc pour toutes cette raison pour
toutes ces raisons là c'est ça fait sens
de préférer les à quatre pattes ou
témoigne un peu du jeu mais bon de faire
ton retour bien c5 v6
est fou qu'on lance la reine ah oui
j'oubliais
arènes à stream qu'on ne s'était pas
assez longs la mer fois je la met sur
deux heures les gens viennent repart ce
qu'ils valent donc la hache lui dit kaka
toi toi oui oui peut-être mais donc du
coup les orques stevens carrefour des
cinq gagnants tempo chantent à tour est
bon voire tabou j'ai un secret mais au
moins il déstabilise un peu eux oui je
sais pas
du coup c'est un tri-nations deux heures
aujourd'hui ouais ouais
je veux leur trou
nous sommes à deux heures ils ont dit
trois fizeo ça franchement ouais mais le
truc week-end c'est que
3 + 0 sa vie fut quand même pas mal de
gens qui sont moins forts et qui comme
préfère avoir cinq minutes donc c'est
trop +26
4 + 1 3 ans j'ai mis 5 + 0
5 0 c'est bien quand même
103 plus de 5,0 à la fin de la partition
pas grand chose tu as un lien de la
réunion veut déjà émis j'ai mis dans
chat
moi je vois ce point comme life machin
truc ce qui aura toujours des gens qui
seront pas contents de la cadence 5 + 0
ça permet de faire un truc entre les
deux cas entre les gens qui veulent leur
jeu buts en dix minutes ce qui joue ans
3 ceux qui jouent en une seule page pour
5 0 c'est le
sait la croisée des chemins femmes ouais
ouais donc nepos a conduit vraiment le
thème des 4 on n'était pas sûr
3.554 5-0 je perds autant rêver 3 +250
réalité c'est la même cadence en gros
même c'est plus lent 5 cluzet ronde
ouais parce que 3 + 2 dont tu as tes
trois minutes maîtresse deux minutes de
rab barbaro 5 et 2 secondes par coup
pour havas 120 secondes faut au moins 60
coups c'est pas c'est pas toutes les
parties quoi
bon moi je suis un peu un galant scène
j'aime bien les trucs sans rajout je
trouve que les rajouts sait plus rien
toi aussi ouais je me bats
enfin je trouve que c'est de
l'assistance comme c'est de l'assistanat
gère ton temps cois farhad juillet
j'aime bien tout
existe c'est plus que leur âge ou de 14
heures début de la crise passe pour les
raye quoi
je passe sur arroux joueurs sur 36 pour
le moment ça rentre ça rentre
donc max tourner trois évidemment ça
joue padding ça joue pas plus après
cavaliers f4 ehouango il ya eu deux
trois arrêts donc tu as il reste un peu
dans cette logique de te faire faire
tour à 8 si jamais tu veux doubler à
l'ail a même souhaité faire maintenant
regard femme est fourbe et 5
ha oui donc le 3c double trucks et tu
protèges bien ton pions et tu pourras
faire fois à troyes un jour
et tu veux faire flouer fin est en
prendre à la tour ouais donc tu forces
quasiment dame prend 1,4 et du coup on
se demande à quoi servent tous racistes
m'a redonné un tempo emile pions le 3me
besoin dans le tour à 6 et très
soupçonneux
peut-être pas assez pour perdre mais
soupçonnant vraiment quoi bah oui c'est
obligé de faire des 1.4 a juste perdu un
tempo et 3g c'est un coût qui était dans
quasiment toutes les variantes quand la
tour vient en deuxième comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans certaines variantes
l'option sera plus attaquer et le fou à
venir vers f1 et b5
très soupçonnons
non profit laxatifs suspicieux de ne pas
retient pas au vocabulaire
très
bon malgré tout qu'ils envoient de
réfléchir sahara fait 5000 déjà au
minimum non on a eu le temps lancé
l'aréna de faire un tour des stades de
faire ton tweet
est déjà lui restait 20 minutes ou 15
minutes
ça fait huit minutes de réflexion
comme elle est vraiment en train de se
suicider ou dessus et que
à un moment donné ça ne tient plus
à un moment donné je sais pas
mais c'est quoi son histoire de chaises
les tout va bien et chelsea sont pas
trop confortable banking the tourist
tout comme portail balkany fils au slip
ouais ça va faire un truc un peu moins
confortable sinon une connerie boissons
nord mena mais bon il s'endort quand
même oui cette chaise je me suis même
endormi
dixinn tudip là quand ils voient ça il
pète un plomb et je pense que tu
ça c'est impossible de suivre une partie
en tant que supporter de gluck
il lui faut une chaise de fakir nous dit
qu'il ya 80
comme c'est vraiment incroyable
tehran incroyable
ce cavalier bleu qui comme kasparov il
préfère les chaises dur
est ce que j'ai un classement actualisé
du tournoi wpt éventuellement mais on
regardera peut-être un petit peu plus
tard pour le moment il n'y a pas de pas
de résultat
va rester un peu sur les parties
parce que je passe je pense juste que ça
va bouger est quand même assez vite la
côte est gris tchouk façon il reste que
17 minutes tard maintenant
non mais vraiment donné il faut qu'il en
soit il va être obligé tout mais pas ou
alors il va tomber mais il va se passer
quelque chose
tu as quand même pas le choix un jour de
jouer
mais tu penses que max il va prendre
aussi lui à un moment donné 40 50
minutes où il va
non le jeu sans doute là il connaîtra
encore pour dix coups c'est loin d'être
impossible c'est normalement tu sais que
ça va tomber là dedans car il lui prend
beaucoup en fait c'est juste le tableau
mais ce que t'as pas intérêt à un moment
donné de prendre une heure de faire les
deux dans dormir un peu gris choo-t
après devrait accélérer à fond je sais
pas je sais pas bah ouais donc tu
connais tu joues tu t'en fous on nous
demande il reste encore combien de temps
avant leur âge où il reste car il ya 4
il va rester encore 19 couvent
bon cesu tour 19 pouces ça va mais juste
barrett ils seraient censés avoir une
heure quarante aussi quoi
alors plus il a fait qu'il prend ses 300
pages pourrait pu comprendre tu prend
quarante minutes trente quarante minutes
titre est une heure ça je peux le
comprendre mais tu mettras 17 minutes
c'est
une richesse qu on nous demande qu'elle
prend 1,6 pour les blancs le truc sur
qui prend du cisci attaquerez à tour en
découvertes et à tourcoing insiste
coutume bouge ta tour et tu remets h le
pur de cinq ans plus à tour est bien
placé
bon normalement max va faire tous rêvent
3 assez vite
ses blagues qui nous dit est ce que guy
ritchie calcul plus lentement que les
autres joueurs n'ont pas du tout un
qui est plus être plus lente maxime
passé très vite mais je t'aime très vite
normalement
il n'est pas connu pour mal calculé
particulièrement creux
pas repris trouve les bons coups
tati connaissait
serait beau qui connaissent
maintenant des cailloux comprend pas que
mon jeu le temps
neuf parties vocales très abîmées
ceinture doit répéter
que palm vient de moi je sais pas trop
bah oui il faut suivre le club lead
stream sur check point com alors quand
du fesc y ait un lien est ce que comme
on le trouve ce que le stream est ce que
quelqu'un peut mettre jeux viendront
chat
donc une faute et dans le club lead
stream après tu m'intrigues le toit
facilement parce que ça reste un tournoi
thème privés sont là pour les guides
quoi voilà il ya somme globale rising
qui a mis le lien nos lionnes aussi donc
voila vous voyez tous le jeu français
plusieurs feuilles qui vont mettre le
lien est donc il faut s'inscrire au club
vit stream vous pourrez jouer très
facilement ce tournant
garder le pas trop loin quand même le
lien
quand ça sera c'est plus dispo sur l'asp
xv irlandais je sais pas je n'ai aucune
idée je veux tellement pas de ça
que je ne sais pas quand ils mettront
les tournées sur l'appli des capsules
s'inquiète et ce qu'on perd le vélo dans
ce tournoi ou pas ouais tu peux perdre
du et l'ol s'attend à classer le tournoi
officiel des intentions
moins de monde qu'à la fin on est monté
à 300 là on est soixante mais c'est vrai
qu'on avait parlé plus tôt et par un
effet plus de pub alors on est on s'est
plus concentré sur les partis
aujourd'hui aux femmes au final puisse
analyser c'est parce qu'il nous prend qu
on parle d'échec ce qu'on achète nos
chemises le monde ben non brigitte
pourquoi on en chemise bleue tous les
deux même le
ouais c'est marrant quand on se fait du
mouron chemise bleue par hasard
ouais c'est pourquoi
oui en chemise bleue
bon maintenant c'est max il va réfléchir
une heure
on dirait deux fixés les flics de
beverly hills et les filles de la
fouillouse web on surveille quoique
c'est bien qu'on finit
y y
d'ailleurs je sais très énervé devant
chez moi et de personnes qui discutent
et non il ya un mec qui est passé en
voiture l'autre il s'arrêter il a
discuté à cette fenêtre de voitures à
toi mais tu dois tu acheté un pistolet à
eau études et bombarde que à j'étais
très énervé
j'étais très énervé je comprenais pas
afin que font ces gens
essaient ils ont été discutés trois ou
quatre minutes aux mains
de gens qui mentent c'est possible ebola
faudrait il fait très beau et grand
soleil le ciel est bleu
[Musique]
découlent mais bon
bah de barback là tant pis
comment ils sont je sais pas comment ils
ont osé et eiffage étaient demande sur
mon balcon j'ai failli appeler la police
car j'en pouvais plus
je ne ferai plus
jk il y à leur accueil il ya un marché
en bas de chez moi elle tu devrais du
cinéma rex et qu'est ce que c'est que ce
marché
non mais en fait
c'est un marché ça va me ferait vraiment
où l'on respecte genre taille quasiment
1 1 à quoi je serais super long mais au
moins tu croises pas les faits un schéma
n'est cité sur les marchés pour être
entassés
c'est bien c'est très simple je mange
des fruits bio mais bon bah tel chrono
ça te perds tout de suite de son hôte un
meilleur j'ai croisé mon voisin aller
faire un petit tour à pied plus du
masters depuis lundi dont vous qui m'ont
quand même je fais un tout petit toit
j'étais très content j'ai croisé
personne je suis très heureux ouais mais
bon je vois mon voisin en rentrant ouais
mais bon il est allé au supermarché bon
moi je m'éloignais bien sûr mais dit il
je n'irai plus supermarché alors je vais
commander il y avait énormément de que
beaucoup beaucoup de monde en fait je
comprends pas ce qu'ils font les gens
mais en fait c'est bizarre de ne pas te
faire livrer alors que c'est un truc
facile à faire maintenant ou de faire du
drive pour ceux qui ont une voiture mais
j'ai fait ça c'était juste un mais même
ce que je comprends pas c'est comment
les supermarchés font pour être encore
plein dès maintenant géré dans le sens
où normands ils ont fait leurs courses
mais jamais il ya ça même s'il aborde
aussi des excuses pour sortir non mais
d'habitude
tu fais que tes courses afin tu bosses
la journée donc du coup c'est un peu
plein à le supermarché après fleurs à 18
19 heures ou le matin tôt peut-être que
les gens voyaient avant avant avant le
boulot ou bien aussi ça peut être un peu
plein les week-ends mais cher comment ça
peut être plein là juste à rien à faire
fait n importe quel moment et que je
parle à quelqu'un qui tue supermarché
plain pied peut-être pas tous d'être les
petits les petites supérettes ou poste
depuis tant que je sais pas non mais
après bon raconte ça s'est ouvert pour
pas mal de personnes son premier conte
s'alimente mai
mais un truc qui tourne pas rond ça peut
pas être blindé et qu'on évite les
contacts sociaux et tout ça
après ouais
il ya des bonnes stratégies pour faire
des courses et éviter les problèmes
c'est de mettre des gants le mec il
disait des gambettes elle par exemple sa
place l envie de gratter visage pas
touché au visage tu rentres désinfecter
course
produits d'entretien tu laves les
emballages machin tu l'avais gand va te
lèves toi et il dit oui même les fruits
et légumes je prends que des fruits et
légumes que je peut éplucher du coup
j'ai lavaud savons
gérer un site où ça
m'inquiète un peu fou mais ouais mais je
trouve ça intéressant fin pas tu
préfères des gens comme ça en fait
qu'ils prennent 0 risque qui ont fait
tous à un moment ça va aller quoi mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit je sais pas
à quel point c'est zéro risque ou 5 1
juste un
bon toi que trois jouées
ce mec ces femmes en fête
mais je ne m'attendais à un truc comme
ça peut-être non mais je pense que c'est
tout match c'est même plus utile à un
moment donné volant même contre
productif a invoqué maître du savon sur
les fruits peut-être pas mais même si ça
a bien fait de laver les emballages
avant de les rentrer de contaminer
l'intérieur
salon même savons sur les emballages et
tout bas pourquoi votre équipe
au pire ça sert à rien en fait disons
gok mal à faire des trucs qui au pire ça
va rien
cassé comme la cette consigne de dire
oui il faut pas surtout permettre de
masquer pas au pire je n'en sais rien at
il vous rendra comme un accessoire de
mode trouve très beau au camas côté
masculin mais le masque et ce soir ça je
suis sûr que c'est utile
mais au pire ça rend bête fait mal à
personne
monteux sont maintenant même pu en avoir
puisque ses priorités pour les corps
médicaux puis je pense pour la police
pour tous les gens qui bossent et donc
ça c'est normal mais si des gens ont des
masses qui veulent les mettre
au pire ça sert à rien au mieux sert à
quelque chose
un truc qui sert à rien au pire ça rien
aux chiffres
et donc comme théorie assez pour voter
les autres si on a infecté mais des fois
tu sais pas c'est infect
sur jours pour porter infectées pour se
manifester c'était jusqu'à 12 ou 14
jours d'incubation d'avoir ce que je lis
donc peut-être qu'après trois quatre
jours tu es très bien tu ta aucun
symptôme qui dit pas tout va bien
maintenant
donc déjà ça te savais rien que pour ça
ça tarde pas à toi personnellement mais
ça peut servir aux autres ce qui est
quand même le but de base qu'on tombe
pas tous malades en même temps quoi
alors comme les inscrire dans le queens
80 joueurs qui sont la reina et youtube
pour être franc il reprend du temps à
fond
intelligent et sait les invasions
toujours coté à sao feng où on pensait à
food et 5 fu les axes paris c'est
logique comment tu tu enlèves les
premiers prend 1,6
bref 4 tu donnes ton rêve cadre du
printemps seront cavaliers donc est ce
que tu veux pas faire un coup plus utile
que d'or perdue ce temps il semblait que
ça allait la position mais
basta mars et rennes est simple et blanc
veulent doubler la cie ont fait pas fou
si on fait pas fou des cinq ont fait
recette admettons ceni de ce que ces
grands
mais cette idée là ouais on recule le
roi et à ce moment là
ok ça s'ajuste leur pénible
c'est sûr que c'est terrible c'est pour
ça qu'on 0 f3 food et 5
dont lé nom vous est sûrement éviter de
se prendre ça le f4 qu'elle aurait été
si c'est vrai mais on ressent la
pression qui était un peu mieux pour
marc st onge
et 6 paraît logique
moi je joue bien on défend g3a et la
tourelle se retrouve mal
c'est
peut-être ce soir 1,7 à temps mais là
dessus comme ça
super cela revient pour les vans
je me demande si non mais c'est
peut-être mieux pour eux mais il faut
voir fou des cinq tours être 4
km et 6 tours à double tour gay parole
parce que on va dire qu'on se met on
s'expose il ya personnage de s'exposer
au tour g6 j'accepte wash 2 et c'est là
peut-être
trop par où c'est toi
par exemple pour des mises pour forcer
les choses
de mégabytes a gagné at on besoin de
crise toi aussi tu te battais tourache 6
tu perds ta qualité
c'est la crise
non mais ok faut pas faire trop de buts
bas à 5 comme ça vous à
17h écrivains ils sont mieux
- 5,57 france soutiendrait à 5 faut pas
faire
dire au bout des cinq sets 4-6 et b6 m'a
presque fait 5 s'apprête à
quel jeu jouent alors dit que ça va pas
que de ça est sûre ça
ça
as tu gagnes un accrochage sympa comme
l'une des bêtises des fonds vautours
ouais
pas maigri outil va la perdre c'est sûr
beaucoup trop rapide un chercheur
marianne trop de trucs là
et à trop d'idées
je sais pas mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que tu te met à mal autant plus tu as de
prendre une punk comme ça il va s'en
prendre aux ide c'est sûr bah c'est tant
mieux après mais tout ce que je veux
dire c'est qui ces prix le
truc l'autre jour à 30 d'activité en
l'homme avec nous oui ben kay prend 4
ok il peut se vendre sont des trucs
oui puis les restes non plus que 11
minutes enfin au bout d'un moment il
doit faire pour l'assassin ya retour f4
qu'aimer si c'est sur moi ils peuvent 28
non mais ça tu te prends pas
ça je pense pas qu'ils se prennent ok
c'est carré c'est trivial
bon ok villa il a une idée de défense
bref 4
mais vraiment forte on saute président y
toro f4 kébé six
tours à un doublé tour pour g6
or là je surprends québec
j'en prends
ouais mais ils sont fous il te dit j'ai
six
montres leroy machin g0 faiblesse et
ouais ouais c'est vrai qu'une fois que
tu l'as vu c'est logique non non ne vous
avez vraiment mais on a déjà vu des nuls
comme ça donc ouais bah topalov au mode
similaire oui donc en fait tout rejet 6
surtout pas rouages de vertou être
déjà tu évites ce plan à temps un génie
un truc
hu a donc c'était là ils vont ya quinze
ans j'ai oublié de remettre tous rêvent
4,34 et b6 est lui aussi sur f5
mais déjà c'est une émulation pour les
noirs parce que
at a gagné un temps à gagner un temps un
bon il aime bien les fous ces quatre
comme l'autre ordi je sais pas ce qu'ils
veulent faire avec ça
va dire
f2i là ok je comprends que tu fait tort
des victimes ventre
et en plus tu as tord 17 défendre ceux
ci s'y prend pas
on s'en va est objectivement c'est il
avait fondé 5 oui mais bon maxim choupo
tour f 4 essuie tour f 5 du coût direct
alors sa force peut-être pas québécismes
on sait quelle équipe 27 oeuvres des du
coup le dr f 5 tours des huit bureaux de
vote avec lille a joué
sous quelques formes d'arthrite orange
essonne
manger sain que c'est bien joué
bon ça sauve pas mal la position en fait
c'était sur un cahier quelque chose
partout des cinq si on fait un tour f5
ok direct le taux refi 4 c'est
d'ailleurs même le coup peut-être que ça
c'est qu'ils veulent en décomptant
minimes bien
il réfléchit il trouve plein de coups
possibles attends attends maxime a joué
il a fait tous rêvent 4
ok je pense fable qu'il va aller pour le
test car il est b6 il va faire tour f1
tour g63 h2 et va faire le test non mais
je sais pas ce que ça me sens même
dangereux pour le blanc d'oeuf temps
proche de 500 francs j'ai six trous
chaque vote réservé nord ne perdent plus
jamais tu as plus une idée un peu
et tu as quand même bon t'as un avion
pour la qualité mais structure blanche
assez pourri et je crois que les normes
peuvent jouer très safe au pire des cas
ils vont faire à 5 à 4 qui est sécable
et st
juste avant j'ai juste mis le direct fap
désolé de t'avoir coupée dans le sens où
on va tout de suite je veux voir ce
qu'est messi ça va être jouée vite tour
f1 ça va être vite je pense
et
seul essai sur le direct pour voir si
fait le tour g6 et là on expliquera si
ça ne convient
donc on n'y est pas
parce que quand même on est là pour
aussi pour pour pour voir ce qui se
passera au recto direct ce qui peut
jouer cavalier c5 aussi un
ouais bah oui mais il peut ni peut
donc arriver système le couple made in
assez naturellement
mais caistab la logique pour lui mais
maintenant c'est bon on comprend bien
bien des choses bien comme il faut
ok j'ai juste un tour du coup sur les
autres pour voir voilà c'est ce dont on
avait parlé on arrivait pas à savoir
c'était facile ou pas pour un dépôt mais
ça l'a fait madame ceux ci
[Musique]
ont trouvé là ok
ding
va dire en f4 plutôt de cavaliers en d4
- il aura droit de revenir un jour
ça va pour les noirs mais ding vous
stabilisez que ça dure longtemps
louvoyer mais il peut aussi commencer à
faire ça et remettre une tour ans ait
enfin je commence à penser qu'il faut
qu'il fasse gaffe guie guie guie
ericsson comme à l'iccn côtes ont réussi
un tour à 6 de trois mois j'ai
finalement compris que j'allais prendre
une vraie flins et dame prend je
comprends
ben c'est sûr que non monsieur eu qu'à
les propos lancés simple pourquoi wiki
et pendant que je jouais comme si tu
gagnes tu permets tu fais puis on prend
il doit être plus sûrement échanger des
tours ouais mais peut-être aidé de
recours 3 je sais pas les deux sont
possibles en tout cas avec celle qui a
fait une petite précision mais s'étaient
emparés ces noms c'est passé pour peur
mais se retrouve à devoir être moins
bien défendre bon ok tube fait déjà deux
minutes ans qu'il est là dessus
donc quoi puisque tornade des candidats
selon réussir une question lancinante
pourquoi yat-il quasiment aucun cas de
kobe 19 or c'est pourtant de sa branche
de chine
facebook n'est pas médecin ce qui donne
les bottes bons chiffres ou pas après
ils ont pris très tôt et vite fermé
aussi je regarde avec la msa ça va moins
vite mais oui va nous apprendre est pas
bon alors ce tournoi et du coup on a
quoi on à 114 voire un peu moins pour
mon canard foie mais ça reste français
mais oublie pas chaque jour on fera à 14
heures
et puis si je joue un
bon tour euh enfin c'est juste sur enfin
non sérieux remis est évident est
bloquée et maxime de qui peut changer
d'avis et page ou un truc trop forcé du
coup je suis très curieux
je suis très curieux femme qui veut
faire tour f1 tour j'ai six tours fc 1
que si nous regardons oui oui mais je
veux dire il il a fait tour est fin et
c'est le coup la fape c'est maintenant
qu'on va voir
bon je rajoute ses impôts tepa ou quoi
c'est le tan tient ses lacets sur ce
coup là que ça va jouer la femme c'est à
ce moment là les gars c'est un moment
vraiment importants de la partie il
s'y trouve toujours les six tours j'ai
cinq pattes on résiste avec menace ton
g5 sa cuisse de qualité qu'on peut leur
montrer du coup avec l'idée de faire un
blocus sur casse blanche les pions sont
sur noir isolé il n'avance plus il ya
plus de rupture le roi va revenir vers 1
6 ou
7ème bientôt la marge peut-être même le
cavalier en russie ce leroy recettes et
envoie les pions et c'est probablement
vrai les noirs qui peuvent prétendre à
quelque chose il a fait tout rejet 6 ok
c'est le moment de vérité de la partie
aux femmes on a attendu deux heures on a
attendu deux heures pour arriver la fab
c'est maintenant
salut de qualité fort donc soi-disant
tour f5 mieux mais faut ces capteurs
d'éviter ça va pour les normands
non non moi je sois s'étant rangés 5
pardon et tour f5 pour empêcher fous ces
quatre attaques la tour alors deux choix
soit on part de la colonne f mais du
coup on menace plus rien ouais ça à
faire de la ford et 8 devient devient
très possible retour de refaire h5 quand
même c'était une de tes idées on en
particulier dans ses pions mais on a
perdu notre jeu sur sur est alors je
sais pas ce que c'est si grave c'est
peut-être vrai mais si c'était possible
compliqué mais vous serez charmés puis
on prend cavaliers f7 battu une qualité
peut-être
ça peut être très chaud entraîneur
mais peut-être mieux cette version que
l'autre
salem fille et pour te rendre de plus en
l'histoire mais bon c'est très chaud
c'est encore mon peu importe mais tu
peux encore jouer on va dire ah
l'étoile 5 plus forts orages de jeux
pensait aucune chance de rien mais
sûrement tour f 5 pouces et 80 oui donc
si tu pars de la première lardons ce que
je voulais une visite menace tour d un
tu peux faire tour 17 tu défends ta
septième rangée
web ont acheté un creux ouais ouais non
mais c'est pas des dom est ok on met
moins en difficulté et noir qu'est ce
qu'on avait vu de tel enfin ça peut
quand même enfin être pas rien
n'aurait droit beaucoup de lignes des
d'égalité sont gagnants l'autre oui j'en
même la hache 6 ghz
mais bon tout le fou en fait blindés vii
il va revenir en russie sous quoi
mais c'est jouable si j'opte c'est
jouable pour les deux mais en tout cas
ok chaque fois on se prend pas pour
projet 5 qu'il a seul le truc a à vrai
dire je voudrais aussi souligner quelque
chose c'est que on va voir la parole
qu'on l'avait une séquence de coups plus
ou moins forcé après tour des huîtres ou
des deux et on peut très vite arriver au
32e coup et gris tubes pour arriver au
32e avec 6 7 minutes et cette position
là avec peu de temps sur la pendule elle
n'est pas si difficile à jouer non mais
bon peut-être pu faire une précision oui
bien sûr mais je veux dire par là que le
design of the great choc serait terrible
dans une position plus complexes qu'il a
16 kwh a joué avec 9 minutes mais là
c'est vrai que ça peut bien forcer les
choses
donc ici on pense que tout raid 5
et prix demandé
après on va pas regarder vraiment
qu'elle prend il la femme ou un sound et
on a parlé quelques rangées trois soeurs
d'être chiant parce que tours j'ai
d'ailleurs il après
h3
et on profite pas de la vie qui a mal
non plus
enfin il a joué il a joué tour avec 5
vient jeu max donc il évite aux cerises
aux caïds plus ou moins thème pour un
circuit encore dans la prépa
c'est chaud
bon gris juke qui va devoir encore
trouvé les coûts ah ouais donc la foux
c4 qui est pas forcé un coût que les
ordi mais bien et qui effectivement a
l'air fort
pour comme on l'a vu pouvoir s'octroyer
la colonne des ou quoi mais ok tout et
tout est complètement possible en
théorie c'est encore la préparer non
c'est encore la prépa et avec un c'est
sûr ils jouent vite ils jouent les
premiers coups de l'ordi de lilas etc
c'est sûr qu'il est dans la prépa
s'il a gagné les grands favoris max
alors attention albert il reste en
restera encore
dix partis après celle là mais il serait
bien parti il serait bien parti
après il ferait partie des favoris après
favori
c'est un grand mot quand même mais
il serait bien ce serait oui
il serait bien ça va très très bien
bon façon la great show qui va être une
enfant il a neuf minutes donc
pousser car
donc et ses parents
donc la vie de choc qui
sait pas il a passé une heure kwh à
30-40 sait pas quoi faire et maintenant
chaque 30 secondes sur le coup de niang
lors ni cj mi
mai
par contre que vlad m'avait dit un truc
avant le tournoi il m'a dit si gris tout
qui réussit pas à régler sont pas une
psychologie qu'avec la pendule à de
réfléchir comme un idiot il ne gagnera
jamais il tombe
par la condition sinequanone à ce qu'il
ait une chance de gagner les candidats
c'est qu'il arrête de faire sa
ba et il a dit sylvia regarde non il m'a
dit s'ils n'arrivent pas pour ce tournoi
là c'est qu'il n'y arrivera jamais
ils y arriveront ils à 37 ans alors que
ça fait
mais il m'a dit que c'était rédhibitoire
en fait de faire ça il m'a dit le
problème c'est que un jour il fait une
impression à comme kong comme contre
euro en garde mais on savait que ça me
côtoyé contrat avec thank you really a
en effet une imprécision et il rate des
demi point parce qu'il fait ça avec
mes lire mais pourquoi ils auraient ils
devraient avoir déjà un demi point de
plus les démolitions qu'il est oui il
m'a fait tu peux pas
tu peux pas rater tout le temps
non tu peux rater une fois mille
personnes mille fois une personne mais
tu peux pas rater mille fois mille
personnes
mais donc
mais
non ils besoin n'était pas gagnée en
fait t'es mieux 3 fin qu'on n'ait pas
été mieux avec les noirs denses de la
berlinoise ouais il a signé contre wang
hao il mettait la pression il n'y a pas
gagné contre les crimes que des cas
mieux vraiment et à puce 1 5 1 donc ça
fait trop
non ça fait trop
on eût dit un bon temps mais on te dit
pas pour bien finir être mieux tableau
autres troisième même second temps il se
retourne et on rêve de tour dès 8h 5,2
points d'exclamation attention
bref deux temps dès 8 h sound de
promotion bah moi je te dis tour bien
des gens croient
ajouté disant battoir
match 5 20 m 2 pour l'interrogation
plutôt bon
t'as le droit bordel à perdre le fou
c'est un donc non non tu perds tous mes
limites de points d'exclamation
non mais attendez vite on s'est pas fait
attendre mais du coup tous rêvent de
salaire juste bizarre ça c'est sûr a
tantôt crasy qui avait pris un set quand
non non je pense pas
dans la première on regarde white white
satin
et je leur dit souhaiter visage
synchronisation ait sollicité le coup de
hache bagdad après tout c 4
je sais pas ce qu'ils racontent cinq
contre cinq
mais il faut prendre fin et ça valait
long terme car le sac avec la tourelle
de
bilal pas d'accord quoi si on ordonne -
3 donc je
pense qu'on verra verser regarde rage
d'autour h6 bon c'est vrai qu'il faut
montrer un truc
cai province at c'est vrai que ça défend
h5 s'attaque la tour métrage cette game
de chris kelly et ça te par sortir sinon
il te bloque la défense en zinc le flou
f1 est attaqué le physicien pendant
l'attaqué vous des cinq tours h1 ça va
être une menace et g6 aussi un coût mais
surtout et 3ème étage et 6 1 il attaque
la tourte attaque le cavalier sans tête
tout est bon alors un moment il ya trop
de choses
mais je veux juste c'est quelqu'un qui a
interverti
non non c'est pas meilleur que magnus
panier c'est à dire que nous on
jolie gemini là pour comprendre la
position c'est le 4e tour en zinc machin
et donc pendant vous me disiez les coûts
h5 de pointage au quotidien c'est quoi
ça j'ai lille a sous les yeux je lui
demande rien à dire qu'il ajustera
détourage 7
les tours h7 ces voix là sans ordi c'est
quand même autre chose
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on pourrait faire
essayer de faire sans ordi on dirait
plein de conneries ça peut être
intéressant aussi
par yvon tu passerais que des
forêts plantées je pars dès
on se fait planter par des dépôts de
tactique mais bon pour parler de la
position dans son ensemble comprendre ce
qui se passe comme ça c'est intéressant
aussi
pèle du fonds comprend jamais quoi donc
c'est un peu le problème
après ces longs du coup tu fais des
variants de suite des mauvaises variante
jamais rien qui se passe
c'est un peu c'est un peu l'on veut
quand même j la partie et comprendre ce
que les joueurs doivent trouver
bon et si on vous demande pas de faire
les deux je pense que c'est un peu ce
que cherchait sans laure dit avoir gardé
dira oui je n'ai vraiment rien compris
au film et sa mélodie
jeff 6e ou
logique tu attaques est à tak
tak moyens ici quand même passé ici par
vox curé touré fuite
bon encore q park hôtel restaurant
jean rabel look et b ci se défend la
torah vite même si notre quinté il n'y a
pas de vrai
nom mais tours 1 c'est logique en fait
une fois qu'on a tous d'ailleurs une
fois bruit que tous rêvent de ça allait
passer de coups qu'on a regardé m'ont
alors dit recommander plutôt tournés en
de base mais je pense que tu vois c'est
plus logique parce que tu veux faire
réussissent ils en tulle - ça me paraît
plus logique il est apte linkin des
qualités en inde j'habite à leur sainte
m c on va voir a vu grand et du tour dès
8h cinq tours âge s'ils se saisissent
des quêtes et puis on prend un café
c'est très possible que ça arrive ça
m'est encore incertain
c'est invisible dans proches sans gros
problème 7
et
réveillera revenir au rêve si ce jeu
c'est pareil
jean rapides ont envie de surprendre et
les blancs parce que je sens que j'ai de
l'activité
mais d'un autre côté si les noirs se
stabilise ça peut être hyper dangereux
j'ai quand même beaucoup de pions un oui
dames 1 3 pour les non s'il le veut
l'espoir c'est d'aller gagner j'ai leur
un turbo c'est
ici le cas mais le coeur ayant existé je
pense que tu vois plus jamais jamais
dans le hockey mais c'est énorme mais
bon c'est dur ce
point de côté je préfère avoir une heure
trente dans une position pareille que
quelques minutes en
tout et ouais bon que coûte lille a
signé
les mieux tour un
corps d un deuxième coup préféré
skipper du sens pour éviter les toits
des vitres ont battu bien
fort bien c'est pas comme pâture mon
pote
meta - le truc de jouer this way et puis
là alors là les noirs c'est le festival
il ya des coûts
potentiels à foison des a5 à des coups
comme ça trammell qui en 17 le coup
préféré de l'ordi
lors des deux tours h 6 min sam à 13
très soupçonnant ça j'aurais jamais fait
non c'est bon on va tu viens de vie
rangée 6 pour viser g3 tu repars tout
seul en face du foot tient donc ça ça
m'étonnerait mais une autre idée qu'il
aime bien ses seins
se libérer une case cinq courses et 6
c à six mains ouais et du coup après tu
montres ton roi et puis te concerne
avance est à majorité s'il ya plus de
chances de trucs comme ça arrive en tête
mais rien de très clair vous en faite
une fois tu as fait h5 faut toujours
surveiller si h6 tarek parents pour
dévier le pion gfk ou 4 6 ou même
caillage sap tm
oui puisque le curry peuvent être
soutenus par le fou d'un autre côté
n'ont ils pas aussi à tout le monde
claquer une calloc'h quelque part sur un
cavalier ou quoi facilement d'ailleurs
du coup ça se complique un peu partout
et c'est benoit z sans fausse note même
temps d'un même plus fort que tout
rapatrier tous par
mois en force on dit qu'à une cape du
côté de dépôt
sur dante parfois effet damas trois
coups de chaud pourquoi ce run off mais
ce que notre pays c'est de faire dame
des quatre
actions suivant revenir en bekkat avec
la lame et insister
et tu montes d'amincissement se faire
obama des six
je pense qu'il va insister sur les
changes en fait ouais
alors va-t-on aller dit quoi on voulait
matelas d'avancé si si on peut mondial
jamais
water dance 2 et 4
dames b4 n'est pas ce qu'on réponde des
échecs on veut par tous
parce qu'on peut pousser des
ailes en 2006
compliqué
mais vous êtes des 6 2 me 6 faut s 4g
cinq choses
à cacher si
on a eu cette idée de g5 tout à l'heure
mais ça peut être fort à tout moment est
ok donc si ça suffit pas non je pense
pas que soigneur données pour les ordis
voir un truc je sais pas a priori pas
vous appelez se tenir
ding coup là ça a beaucoup bougé à côté
ding ferrand garde la tour de by f 3 à 4
sur 9 ans qu'elle était trois échanges
et les dames il a mille cas on sait ça
c'est mieux pour les bleus commencent à
prendre un petit avantage
ça ne va pas suffire à elle mais ça
ressemble à un truc qu'on préfère avec
les blancs parce que le cavalier sur la
case idéal on apprend là y'a longtemps
talent pions basse et à
des petites choses qui font que tu peu
pressé
ça va être assez mais ça tu peux la
jouer pendant un moment et kirill avait
un peu craqué comptons en gardant un
maintenant pas dans une position
similaire mais dans une position avec un
esprit similaire voire un peu mieux et
j'ai fait un peu n'importe quoi donc
attention et on a eu surtout droit à
trois est aussi important et le petit
chipeau fait dire nous le montrer dans
chat parce que du coup ça veut dire que
la toile va devoir repartir admettons à
cette somme qui a été sept ans retour
prend mais là
je préfère parce que tu bloques le pion
plus haut et tous les temps du sein mais
bon ça veut dire qu'il ya l'option qui
va pouvoir venir en a quatre et ça c'est
toujours pénible si lamentablement tubes
à quel point monsieur mieux pour nous
ouais
ça c'est sûr et wang hao bai quick il a
repris 2 sur fofana mambé 3 l'a repris 2
h il va reprendre à et l'autre assurant
mettre à tour ans et 8 j'imagine pour
venir jouer sur la colonne c'est le
droit kouagou qui allie main du coup
l'effet retour à satan suite et s'est
fait un petit truc ex à bricoler mais
bon ce n'est pas 2,6 g
mais ok le tour à 6 2 5 pouces je n'ai
pas aimé
il se retrouve un poil en difficulté du
du coup caruana dépôt
[Musique]
ouais
mais du coup c'est quoique l'on dise
donné notre dame à trop en fait si ces
dames à 3,7 témoigne la
tâche quand même pas rester à l'affût
des
6èmes c'est pas une décision facile à
prendre puisque tu t'en ailles la
défense du g7
ok c'est un druide ordeal vois tu peux
pas aller calme là bas non métalliques
moi ça me paraît logique surtout que la
leur vie à jean laffon mansart en
concurrence est d'amener un
nom mais je comprends il peut-être venir
un
epn arrive à bricoler année dont 6 mais
arrête je préfère jouer avec les blancs
surpression et sur ça et je pense que
vous cédiez un mail à ses différentes
aldana - oui mais j'ai en fait du coup
tan dung c'est très malin parce que tu
es tombé à -2 puis garde la poussée et
sur foot et si tu veux faire mon travail
et la zone ouais
mesdames un peu des deux je pense et du
coup ça peut devenir dangereux donc on
peut comprendre date d informer hockey
on retrouve sur maxime il réagit pas
pour le moment après fou c4 il semble
être finalement sorties du fichier
j'en avais enfin
enfin enfin
pour quelque chose
parce que ça existait un peu un enfer
pour le joueur russe bain ou peut-être
que etienne battu facile et jens voigt
ça me semble invraisemblable a laissé le
choix il a pas mis une ligne toulouse sa
douce a tout du bon mahias intéressant
où ça et puis à toi de voir
tout cas pas réparé
bonne prépa bonne prépa
bonne prépa et de maxime bonne prépa de
pas qui il est peut-être donnerai pas de
ghetto qui ajuste réfléchi pour rien je
sais pas en fait d'un dur a dit en
passant il a joué les couleurs n'ya pas
dire que
je pense pas qu'il y réfléchit quand
même si longtemps fabre
il alors mais où il était plus préparés
on vote parce que ma tatie se rappelait
plus
non mais vraiment c'est pas je peux pas
comprendre
batta une journée de repos tu sais que
ça va être ça la ligne
saint chrême
sept-îles ouvrir un pgm non mais ce que
je veux dire c'est une vraie phrase de
valdes jeux sonores mais ça serait une
chez par un quatre cavaliers un truc que
mad joue pas souvent ok tu peux te
surpris
il a juste à jouer la partie il ya deux
jours avec sim rentrer dans l'axé de la
berlinoise et à montrer ta ligne ok tu
sais que l'autre diva devises et de suco
normalement donc tu dois être blindé on
disait nouvelle mauvais en prépa et en
ouverture pour l'instant ça a l'air
d'aller bah oui tout c'est marrant il
joue exactement les mêmes sphères sûr
que d'habitude dans tous les tournois à
sans enjeu les becs légalise l'enjeu on
ne sait plus égaliser
non mais c'est tant mieux
mais non mais fait près pas le problème
de maths c'est qu'il a eu beaucoup moins
de temps que les autres mais arrive
après le truc en fait enfin faut quand
même pas déconner surtout de vivre c'est
que ça fait
je sais pas si cette fuite ans qui joue
les temps à l'élite
ouah il affronte les meilleurs mondiaux
dans votre niveau prépa il est blindé en
fait il ya moins pointu que guillery par
exemple ou quoi mais si c'est clairement
un des mecs les plus mieux préparés au
monde donc je mettrais au dessus par
magnus parce que il a cette capacité de
sart dribbler caruana
excellent aussi mais il y juste après
non mais tu vois ce que selon j'aimerais
bien parler situe à magnus on sait
qu'ils passent moins de temps avant ces
partis que les autres
encaisser des fichiers énorme il veut
être prêt pour jouer magnus c'est connu
il le dit et ça se voit dans son jeu
d'ailleurs est finalement loin de son
tournoi où tous les autres ils se
préparent comme d'hab certes ils se sont
infligé deux mois de près par mes à
s'entraîner à fond et y'a que max qui
s'est amusé qui a passé du bon temps et
qui arrive frais et finalement si c max
qui gagne le tournoi avant tout cas qui
menace vraiment gagner et qui joue bien
pendant les premiers jours est ce que ça
veut pas dire qu'aux échecs il ya trop
de prépa qu'au final les mecs veulent
trop réciter et que la meilleure
stratégie ce n'est pas celle de magnus
au final c'est à dire j'y arriverai ok
je perds une 0,2 d'évaluation sur l'ordi
ok mais pas de chance je préfère me
faire ça pour moi je joue mal quand
c'est trop je dois trouver cité mais du
coup est-ce que c'est pas la bonne
approche de josé saramago si
il vient pas je vous donne oui mais je
veux dire que sa préparation elle est
peut-être plus orienté il joue souvent
des petites idées des petits trucs oui
peut-être moins tu étais autant préparé
genre ta préparation à tous en fait elle
est axée sur un truc au lieu de voir
tanks et ses quatre heures de prépa le
matin tu t'en casse une heure et demie
d'une connerie un mail à exactement mais
j'aime que il oriente ses seconds en dix
ans les gars je veux pas avoir des
fichiers deux fois à réviser vous
trouvez des petites idées intéressantes
et après je joue quoi mais bon
franchement quand il a sorti hse nikov
vous a toujours
ce qu'il ya dessus
c'est quand même un gros truc con way
mais
ouais je sais pas j'essayais de faire
une relation un truc non mais je pense
qu'il veut pas jouer à mon avis un des
positions où ça se joue à la mémoire
avec s'il oublie un truc qui se fait
raser il est je pense qu'il a un fils
est secours quand même
oui c'est peut-être ça je pense qu'il
doit orienter sa préparation
différemment des autres quoi qu'il en
soit et ils cherchent des petites îles
et 200 mètres il va très bien cet
automne de sueur ou sajoo et peut faire
durer longtemps même sans avantage
objectif
parce que il a cette qualité dans le jeu
que d'autres ne peuvent pas mon patin il
a fait tourner à m ok donc on avait dit
quoi tour
j'ai le temps des 8 juin j'en ai vite
quand même là dessus je crois qu'elle a
vanté à écuries on aime raconter je
rappelle tour des cataractes ont réussi
ce système est ce que tant les entraides
d'ancrage pas nous on a envie votre
dalila mais
est-ce que
[Musique]
je peux a convaincu qu'il va jouer
autour des 8 mai un truc qui est
intéressant aussi c'est la prépa
decarone y'est
c'est ce que disait m'accueillir ce qui
est intéressant c'est que les deux plus
grosses près pas les plus compliqués du
tournoi c'est de guéret caruana ses deux
défaites pour le moment
est donné mais pas être joué dans le jeu
quoi ouais
ouais mais caruana en plus il pourrait
très bien face est un type de pression
il est bon mais il est mal tombé en fait
parce que ding a su se ressaisir in data
zéro erreur il trouvait sur une machine
de
loading mode machine qui peut gagner tu
peux tous les niveaux du record du monde
avec stephen carroll qui a pris quand tu
vois magnus qui connaissait toutes les
grandes parties de renan de tata steel
c'est quand même un mec avec une mémoire
exceptionnelle will hayes mais je crois
qu'il ya une émission télé contre les
trois ans il sera appelé toutes les
capitales du monde avec l'ordre dans un
mur et sion c'était impressionnant en
fait ce magnus il jouerait pose déjà
qu'il fera un autre truc très bien ça
c'est sûr ça c'est sûr c'est aussi
qu'ils doivent ses capacités là
c'est sûr si on en parle un peu fière
d'elle est ce que si tu joues bien aux
échecs tu es forcément intelligent non
ou avant-hier
des règles ici c'est suri la saru diouf
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
je
sais pas comment corrompt pas
d'intelligence pleins dire mais tu as
des capacités cognitives
gars tu veux pas être bon d'échec et ne
pas savoir réfléchir ou quoi enfin dans
un certain domaine tu peux être bon car
tu pourras dans des domaines un peu
similaire y arriver faire d'autres jeux
à
peut-être apprendre visite à retenir vie
de vin aura détruit coutu sera pas
supérieur sera intelligent ça va pas
dire qu'il sera temps la violence
sociale tu crois qu'en ce moment il
tourne bien et c'est ça c'est deux
choses différentes je sais pas donc
comment quantifier intelligence ou pas
mais en tout cas voilà les magnus il est
brillant
jusque des capacités c'est vraiment le
truc dans les numéros un mondiales au
vos fantaisies première liste c'est par
ce qui m'impressionne par exemple
juste il a compris comment marcher le
jeu mais faut comme beaucoup de russes
étage a pu maîtriser en fait mes mecs se
blesse la veille tu peux pas le mettre
dans ton équipe d'entraîneurs décide qui
jouera pas et jouera pas enfin sur
tuffeau faut pas être idiot faut
comprendre comment ça marche avait à
mettre les compos les joueurs comptent
rapporter des points mais beaucoup de
gens font et et puis voilà d'ailleurs
bon bah là il est plus tout le moins il
était une fois un monde est un moment de
la saison on verra la saison peut-être
le mec qui va gagner la fantaisie
il se trouve qu'il est bourré et on va
pas dire oui tchétchénie
on va dire oui
avec force que
non mais là c'était pas c'est pas moi
qui disait en fait je reprends les gens
qui doit incroyable ils m'ont un mondial
de tous et dans l'autre sens il dirait
pas ah oui ça parce que je fasse je
n'étais pas du tout les gens de faire
attention quand même nom mais en plus là
pour le coup les éboueurs ils sont
heureusement qu'ils sont là ils sont en
première ligne ils vont bosser il a
passé un petit peu plus fébrile a en
fait bah non mais je faut pas mal
interprété ce que j'ai dis quoi mais
c'est pour ça que je préfère être
recadré tout de suite tu vois ce que je
veux dire bioware vient d'arriver non
mais pour te paraître de t'exprimer
parce que ça pouvait être mal compris
quand tu vois je t'ai
je te fais un plaquage cathédrale vois
tu vois ce que je veux dire
non c'était pas un recadrage sais pas
c'était pas le mot que vous employez je
vais employer le mot que je te
permettait de regarder ce que tu voulais
dire en fait dans ce sens là mais je
sais pas quel terme employer le fond de
ma pensée voila voila je vais te
paraître d'exprimer le fond de la pensée
exactement
recentrage c'était le au
cadrage recentrage
non mais en gros c'est juste un métier
quand j'ai un les gens je dise oui oui
alors que
je crois qu'on est en fait un tati on
veut rien dire si rien n'est
donc plus que trois minutes trente pour
get you qui va tomber c'était juste
histoire de prendre un métier qui n'est
pas intellectuel de base à première vue
non te demande pas d'aller faire des
calculs quoi mais pas pour autant c'est
empêchera pas de gagner la première
l'école pas la fantaisie lit
il
attirait plus influent impressionné si
magnus il était libre en langage de
starcraft ii ou de league of legends ou
deux qu'on s'appelle le truc a été
entamée en mai tf1 il ya de la chance
aussi un petit peu mais tu vois league
of legends ou de starcraft surtout s'il
était numéro un gars de starcraft ii
parce que tu as el khil mecs qui jouent
au poker qui est très très loin bon il
était un des meilleurs joueurs de
starcraft ii du monde qui est un jeu
hyper compétitif et après il a été un
des meilleurs joueurs du monde de poker
et au niveau oui jouer c'était vraiment
pas que de la chance loin de là donc je
pars là que ça m'intéresse ça
m'impressionnait plus ils étaient dans
les numéros un mondiales pas la
fantaisie l'icm est dans un jeu non mais
j'en ris pour la compétitive pourrait
l'être si ce focus sur une chose
mais il n'est pas ni la wii l'époque
sony fait pas et enfin il puis après
tout on entend le prouver mais ça
m'étonnerait pas n'hésitez pas à re
faire dieu c'était starcraft c'est un
dossard 4 exactement
mais bon
peu importe
mais en gros oui c'est
des gens s'ils ont du temps à consacrer
à un domaine normalement ils seront
compétents dedans il a fait froid c'est
très riche qui n'a plus que 3 2 minutes
25 après ce coup
ça peut chauffer il peut la perdre et
tout cas oui bon ça c'est sûr il faut
tout peut arriver je ne sais pas ma
meilleure
grille toute personne il est pas super
bon gris chaud non c'est pas un mauvais
joueur mais c'est pas c'est pas un top
mondial
donc
non menant donc bon recettes sur mon
punch fautes mais
[Musique]
je dois pas te lit ni moins de l'ordi ya
japonais aussi qui est impressionnant là
quand il s'appelle le gars qui est
numéro un mondial en shogi et quel genre
24 et qu'elle quant aux échecs
ouais
pas kochi marche plus comme ils
s'appellent jeu
non mais c'est impressionnant parce que
là c'est quand même deux jeux ont ça se
ressemble un tout petit peu mais c'est
quand même assez différent avec un
numéro un mondial en 1 est quasiment
grand maître dans l'autre alors que vont
pas je trouve que c'est quand même assez
impressionnant
en haut de gamme ax claude par h5 et
jega très avancé
c'est un peu le plan qu'on avait de base
vaut pas pourquoi pas le faire
là c'est quoi la stratégie ce que kant
et max excellent vide certes eu le blitz
je sais pas
tu joues normal tu t'en fiches mangue et
moisson m'a toujours dit c'est que tu
joues normal peu important des garçons
i'm not to pas parce que tu joues
vouloir rejouer vite c'est la meilleure
manière de tout mettre à gaffer
après ça c'est un conseil pour les gens
lambda normaux c'est
peut-être que max il peut avoir envie
d'accélérer parce qu'il n'a sûrement pas
gâtés puisqu'ils jouent vite mais en
fait le temps que tu as gagné un
puissant pas au début autant l'utiliser
à bon escient après et six aides
publiques c'est comme l'autre ça savait
rien
non ça une s'exciter à vouloir faire mal
jouer l'adversaire en blitz en toi tu
réfléchis tu prends ton temps tu joue le
meilleur foot qui te semble
effectivement être le meilleur que moi
il avoue j'ai quatre faut six tours
f2eg café 5 g 4 essence h5 ça fait sens
je pense savoir se ressembler un peu
l'univers
gh5 g4g 4h cinglant aux savoirs semble
mais c'est pas tout simple à gérer pour
les marsouins du tout je pense qu'il a
gagné max jean plus tu peux avoir une
peau de banane avec 1 à 4 x 3 je sais
pas quand mais ça peut partir ou le chou
qui veulent partir par trois ces cinq
mains
bien
[Musique]
il reste 14 kw avant leur âge moi je la
sens bien on soit un tout petit tour
d'espagne revient parce que c'est le
moment chaud
damas 3 il ya eu d'annoncé de damas cinq
dames t1 et j'ai l'impression que
caruana il est juste en train de
dribbler il va menacer de pousser des
six travées sa d'amendé quatre mois je
vois bien fab il a gagné finalement
bas il va presser il va de l'avenir
pressé c'est un peu chiant à dingli
rennes c'est exactement les dix tours à
5 à 4 donc il va pétrole ni presse et
habiterait sociale et bangaly près ceci
est non non il ya de la pression et
c'est que les blancs qui presse les
blancs presse riz blanc presse
d'avoir peut-être que je recadre tu as
ta pensée thébaux pour que tu sais le
lendemain c'est
que tu vous dire quand il s'est beaucoup
donc d'un gris futuriste 14 quoi jouer
pour obtenir son âge où on nous dit h5
jouer à chaque jour non h5 pas joué
on a on avait giclé en dessous de nous à
tout moment si vous voulez avoir les
coûts jouer ou pas joué pour être bien
sûr d'être sûr sur l'échiquier du direct
et nous quand on bouge les caisses du
coup vous avez vous avez toujours
l'échiquier de de griche
et dwan
vlg gâte ses shows ouej étape tout
échoue en fait j'ai quatre s'échoue h5
c'est chaud moi j'aurais quand même
plutôt fâche 5,1 à première vue joie que
l'ordi sur ashley cafouille 6
mais bon il se comporte que la tour non
mais déjà ça
fait j'avoue aussi seul coup
foule trois noms mais font rares en vie
quand même kane et s'est dit seuls
footloose non mais sûrement ce lundi le
dit oui je sais
mais votre lettre fort 3d tout comme ça
que le nom parce que
h5 je pense que tu fais pas trop si tu
fais ta rage 6 je pense et j'ai bientôt
des g4 mais moi je jouerai plus dans ce
temple avec les blancs que j'écarte h5
verso voilà pareil mais bon
au tadjik a tout de suite et plus en
contrôle choses et quand tu as 5
ça c'est du détail pas évident
avec les noirs il faut quand même se
lever de bonne heure
ok il a joué max h5
normale loin tour agissent tempo c'était
sûr et là j'ai 4 est ce que tu étais pas
obliger un tu peut on dire effet g4
tempo
i9000 a fait on raconte qu'une patron
n'importe quoi
non
ouais là il presse y
est maintenant il faut qu'ils sachent
qu'elles ces tops de défense et mettre
en place mais c'est très logique avec
les landes a renvoyé les pions g et h
ouvrant la vie au tout début il ya deux
arbitres ça quoi effectivement
c'était le plan est il arrivé à le
mettre en place concrètement donc c'est
ça le plus dur c'est bien beau de savoir
temps car ça c'est très rien je vous
regarde la part de maxime vraiment
niveau de jeu de fou est ce que là il va
faire tout rejet huit coups de leur dit
elle peut faire tourner vite parce que
bas juste à tour abidal fait rien tout
la place de ce côté ça souffle est prêt
datant un petit g6 un jour
24h à chf 8 6 après le coup de l'île à
six pattes ou rejet vite il faut aussi
dans la position de la partie
mixez mieux
bon après il aime bien plein de coups
pour les blancs hynix faut aussi ce goût
qui tu semble plus possible
du bien qui me semblent intéressantes
parce que c'est ça qui me faisait peur
donc j'attends que vous aussi ce tabou
chemin et vous vous faites à torfou g5
royal tours f1 a woman qui comprend
trois j'évite tout rêve 7 qui a aidé 5
es tu bloques
ouais mais attendez encore tour 17 pour
faire tours fc est temps pour prendre 5
7 5 sur le goût quitte dim
non ça me parait a
battu à moi j'aurais eu très très peur
j'aurais pas dû roi g8 visionnement il a
fait tout rachat suite ok c'est un des
coups je t'enlève
diagonale c'est un cours pratique mais
tu commences à des idées et clément bien
on le comprend millas est à 4
j'ai senti que ça pouvait arriver un
jour mais j'ai
des gens fous et 6 x 3 échecs mais ça tu
es content elle a fait perdre mon temps
à faire recette déjà il rentre chez lui
le pion ratatat à mu à ton fric à se
voir s'il fait plein de choses bien
ça sent pas bon pour un cri tchouk bas
c'est dur la voie là là là là pour le
coup maxime vous qui réfléchissent à 4
je sais pas c'est bon ce cas c'est le
coulis là mais
cette année aussi ce qu'ils vont être
sympa à planter
tu peux aussi je veux normal de monter
des pièces je sais pas afin de faire
plein de choses à regarder un moment
critique c'est assez important que mais
regarde ce qu'ils proposent 2 6 7 6 à 4
man
est sûre pions franges et 5 x 3
3 8 et encaissé g5 bon ben ça y va pas
jouer trop dur
pas trop dur
ouais j'suis pas ça m'a l'air coup trop
dur ans
non mais à quatre geeks en fait si tu ta
l'idée de filer à cas pour faire soit
trois jeunes en foutiez points 4
comprend pas pas besoin dun camille au
passage que par agacer quand même
logique car elle y prend 1,4
oui parce que c'est quand même logique
sur fois à trois tués lors de ces 5
ouais mais le problème donc c'est que tu
fais toujours 4 par exemple kempé 5
mai ok ça c'est pas facile mais est hors
concours
tu comprends ton coin de sa tête le roi
robert d'où il vient pour congés cet
été tu bouges flux caisse est trouvable
ils peuvent maxime il peut trouver un
truc comme ça hein on vise bien dans son
style nature et par cavalli aussi parce
qu'elle prend c'est cette rouge
et 5,07 mater et du de pousser les pions
au passage un même par an moins
de matériel dans le sens où les noirs
ils ont des pions triplé je réponds pas
ta qu'une guérite et non pour ses armes
très gagnable
non mais un peu de finition
moi je serais quand même partagé entre
l'idée de faire un 4 rapidement pour max
dans le sens tu sens que c'est un bon
coup et que m l'otan pls et tu réfléchis
bien après
ou réfléchir maintenant est calculée au
cices aussi non médical tout tu fais des
coûts candidats jusqu'à 4/6 je parlerai
de sa fête du conte par tous et cela
parce qu'une demi-heure de la semaine
dernière
lorsque ses comptes jeter sur aussi
c'est qu'on y vint je suis d'accord avec
toi non si tu devais te jette sur à 4
parce qu'il est moins risqué
mais après d'être que si c'est très bien
aussi je sais pas conduire même peu
importe 20 mais je pense que la décision
doit être motivée par un autre couple
presque 10 robin saïda cas c'est quand
même très intuitif en bits ce jour et
tempo ouais bah c'est vraiment qu'on
voit que c'est un truc lee qui vont
être près du coup il faut que sa part
pris 6,95 intéresse parce que lui il a
plein de solutions
non nous a peut être là jean claude
moi j'ai envie de mettre une grosse
pression maximum
tu te lâches une demi heure que great
yoox on dormait là tu voues est fou des
deux mais je pense que food aid le truc
c'est qu'il peut peut-être faire à 5 c 5
way fait ces cinq surtout non apprête à
une autre tentative qui veut tendance à
te faire parce qu'il va faire
payer 17 maintenant les psys sont
peut-être d'autant plus forte
[Musique]
de leur prendre même torres à 100
mais fou du coup pour price est quand
même prise est fou c'est cinq jolies je
les croise trois et six fois en sept
matches
et roi des vite qu'avec cet échec était
prend la fuite serait
elle vous fait 3 td 7-6 8 saga c'est
très tentant donc on peut être enfin
qu'est ce tu vas faire quoi donc ils
obligés de faire payer à 4 way et
peut-être que du coup c'est un truc très
tentant pour les blancs de dire de faire
ça parce qu'il vient de à 4 illégaux
demain à l'ouest et que tu te tempête
pas donné le pion à 4 es tu de ta
lumière position ça tu peux le faire
parce que tant
il est vrai mais il est vraiment pas
loin de là gagner là je pense qu'il est
il a peut-être 70% de chances de la
gagner
à mon avis il est très très bien parti
je la sens très très bien mon femme
naïve il est bien il vient très bonne
prépa je suis juste étonné un peu de
naïveté de
riccione
je peux comprendre je blague pour
l'instant c'est nickel et
quel que soit l'état de la partie c'est
un fiasco lula pré palm beach ou
le soir je reste ne soit pas si étonné
que ça non mais tu te retrouves avec
moins de deux minutes à la pendule dans
cette position avec toutes les lignes
qu'on a montrées sympa pour les blancs
qui allait en force droite dans
ces jeux qu'on vendange
tête la première
non mais oui ben non mais moi ferait ça
bon on s'en fout mais la détrousser
jamais j'avais un prof peu près pas
seulement un prof de maths qui me dit
c'est est-ce que tu connais pas tu es
formule quoi parce que vont évidemment
je ne me rappelais plus bas tu es venu
avec la piste il coûte oui
mais c'est
que t'as rien faire en retraite elle
c'est un peu sa grille tout venant non
mais lui pour le coup il apparaît enfin
on sait quoi qu'il a été très
sympa ça sert d'être aussi sérieux en
fait
à faire ça
donc j'arrête il a juste oublié jusqu'où
tout
[Rires]
de son couteau
et même pour l'autre on a des doutes
[Rires]
dans le cas
d'un gang bang
ouais
on va avoir un très bon match ça il ya
plein de coups très sympa faux et 3
sympa à 4 sur le meilleur objectivement
aussi simple et n'importe quel flux
normal sympa aussi
pas de finale en découlant de la tra
sont déjà passés j'ai acheté heureux et
si jamais on peut on peut pas en france
on peut pas parler sur les échecs quoi
ya pas de tacler -ont mais si jamais tu
devais donner une cote à maxime là tu
mettras convient 1 30 ans 30
1 30 la victoire
1,40 à victoire 3,30 l'annuler genre
grichka 50 coiffe
non 12
ghetto qu'à douze contrats moi je vais
mettra plus là je vois pas dans quel
monde y gagne
baal et blanc prise trop sacrifier un
truc qui marche pas je sais pas un truc
bizarre 19 peut-être à côte c'est la
cote c'est les blancs perdre tout seul
en fait c'est pas c'est pas les noirs
gagne non intrants que la victoire
vraiment
aller 1,33 1,33 à la victoire
3,50 la nulle
et 19 victoires de gris truc
dans mes favoris
never goes bookmakers mais moi non plus
bordel bombay l'espoir dont douze
au caire mais caracas comme ça les gens
qui veulent jouer la surprise il me rase
pas jones --un nous
à terrats je veux pas les laisser tenter
la surprise et les rasets ils font ce
qu'ils veulent parier sur 12 possibles
ivey trimestre nul il met là nul à 3,50
voilà bah c'est pas bête ouais je pense
que c'est plutôt bien joué
mais bon ok
ça que l'habitant à 30 si on est
optimiste mais c'est peut-être vrai mais
ok à 1,5144 plus normal
serait pour de la m as tu penses 1,45
allez les cotes évolutive quoi bas après
ça a évolué c'est qu'en russie tu peux
parier sur les échecs s'ils veulent
utiles et ses volutes ivan graff est
fantastique ouais
donc
on va voir on va voir
ça peut ça peut ça peut ça peut gagner à
mon avis un côté à
côté français
allez les bleus
suite spirituelle je dire côte à la
place de corte un peu comme le suspense
pour le suspendre le suspense même temps
oui mais ce papier on n'est pas on parle
pas très bien français avec farah je
parle bien français même pas trop vous
temps on est des provinciaux
bat énormément amélioré d'une caméra
koulou quand on vous dit que tant de
bien
fab 144 p quoi voilà
vos côtes sont trop élevés il ya de la
dead money ouais alors attends si on est
à 1 33
ça veut dire que si c'était du 1 v1
l'autre devrait être à 4 si on voulait
faire des côtes on prend pas de
on prend pas de bnl observe que vrai
serpent fête va peut-être 1,33
la nuit on a amené à 3,20 et la victoire
de green shoe qu'à 12 c'est un peu molle
j'avais le mon truc oui bon ben ça va tu
as volé mon truc enfin bravo
[Rires]
bravo tu as le droit à ce que tu veux
dire qu'avec les autres quote tu peux
parier sur tous les autres merveilles de
l'argent et faf mais ces résultats mais
ils comptent y fit différemment et quoi
qu'il gagnerait
alors attends il dira aussi des
bookmakers rythme et 1,35 de 89 ouais
mais bon là et directe du coup bah ça
nous on voulait faire des côtes on prend
pas de commission quoi c'est on voulait
faire des quotas quel intérêt si
maxime et 4,5 la victoire à 1,005 là nul
12 la victoire des noirs
mais à 0,05 l'anil
qui peut
moi j'aurais pu
j'aimerais ne pas faire assez dans
l'arrêt d'un minimum de respect c'est
vous que les gens soient insultés dans
l'arena
jul ce dernier il peut perdre au temps
où il va jouer n'importe quoi non mais
il ya trente secondes de rage par
coudonc doit
il pas n'importe quoi et il perdra mais
ça c'est une autre affaire
mais du coup tu es bookmakers tu fais
les côtes et des rocks
ou pas
je veux qu'ils jouent à 4 stp mais c'est
pas forcément le meilleur quoi 4 un fou
et 3 est aussi assez logique
24 fin mai tout effort bain beaucoup de
que son fort ça en commun le racing est
content tout à fait 3000 drake 3000
c'est notre record pour cet état c'est
vous c'est votre cas c'est beau c'est
beau non trois mille 3000 sebo
franchement ça fait ça fait des grosses
primes quand même
c'est dommage qu'on puisse pas vous
offrir les images mais
enfin il est comme là je le budget un
jour
au tibet y règne mais la daronne à
l'abri dench c'est pourquoi
il est gris d'irène changer greedy
[Rires]
sebo dans les arénas justin vous heureux
que les sacs quand je gagne des reds
[Rires]
se seraient les beaux jours et que
j'envoie les screenshots des petits
paypal pour les arénas maintenant à 5
ans tous les arénas ils la paient les
amirashi la truffe
répondent à la digue face une vidéo il
en sueur et où ils pouvaient fait il est
il est tellement beau gosse gagny qui
serait capable de le faire et du coup ça
voudrait qu'on vient d'avoir les images
le monde triby sais pas mais à mon avis
ça doit être énorme et je sais pas j'ai
aucune idée mais ça doit être se
comptent en dizaines de milliers d'euros
j'en sais rien honnêtement je sais pas
j'ai millions au repos ça la vie tu
imagines en centaines mais mais je n'en
sais rien autant slovène je sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas jock unités
mais à mes bons rails qui peut payer
tout même pas non mais après quand même
les échecs c'est un des trucs où on peut
s'en priver très facilement des images
le foot tu pourras voir par exemple
le fou tu pourrais pas
premium
bonjour c'est un site très bien en fait
qui donne les images gratuitement ce
moment à quatre cores jouais bien je n'y
a plus assez vite non ouais
tonton
des coûtera 4,4 bien jaune
bon ça va ça va gagner
en fait il doit pas prendre je crois du
tout
il a pris ses bas je crois que s'il fait
toujours quatre ferme il va devoir faire
b5
on leur dit ce qu'il faut aussi du coup
meilleur coût
car elles vivent leurs six oui oui et
kamal et c est l francis pardon fou j'ai
cinq échecs c'est d'assurer 8
pour f3
non les auteurs tout aussi ce web et à
ses trouvailles ou aussi au
fait que tu es mal en fait je sais mes
joueurs c'est un intérieur qui est
trouvable sur hewitt n'a pas tardé 5 je
pense v5 c'est le coude en sang mais
faut aussi la prendre je comprends
rouges et 5 échecs ce que dix huit temps
est à tour tu doutes sur la colonnade tu
rentres à 1 100 uras tout quoi c'est
injouable je pense pas
gros début de tournoi donc ça peut juste
être sa barbe et 5 pour prendre ma
charrette je sais pas mais
là
la cote de redescendre un vin la
victoire je pense à tous ceux qui ont
parié avant à 4.4 à 1,4135 je sais plus
quoi ils sont là ils sont heureux d'en
baver peuvent revendre déjà ils ont
cette fenêtre
mais attention pas prendre le cash out
suivant les sites pour enfin
aller tours 4 on arrive à le faire pour
eux quatre
je pense qu'il va tout cas ce sera un
début de tournoi rêver hein j'ai juste
un oeil aux concurrents directs n'est
pas en sueur
ding ok ça va ça nul et attend c'est
quoi qui pourquoi tout a disparu bon
tout a disparu peu un peu importe à mon
retour sur direct
alex n comme on verra plus tard bon on
s'en fout
match y aller petit à l'ehpad où la
chercher celle là
puisant quattron dans les trois favoris
avant le tour à ce serait normal et non
ce serait vraiment un vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un départ en
fanfare un rythme de rythme de champion
après on va pas mettre la pression à
maxime il faut qu'ils restent en sedan
ce moon au prêcheur tu vois ce que je
veux dire ouais tranquille je sais pas
vraiment ce jeu vous défonce ouais c'est
ça y'a pas besoin de se lâcher la
pression peut-être vanté devant ça va
gagner une partie
serez vous commencez à prendre mur tu as
comme coach quoi après qu'il oeuvrait
faut jouer un coup
maintenant votre mur tacle un guichet
pour qu'ils prennent leur place
il va aller le seul le soir il va le
voir rend l'idée va lui dire tu es bien
dormir le soir
réveillez le matin
lire un fichier
pgms révoquant le coach de génie quoi
jouer une partie gagnée les candidats se
présentent pas du montant égal aux in
attention
[Musique]
c'est moins fort je pense ouais bah
c'est fini en fait là bas c'est fini on
sait pas de quoi me la mégère si l'autre
joue parfaitement ces deux nouveaux égal
c'est quoi le lien à différence en fait
c 4 x 6 étapes lui le fou g5 faut aussi
tu as pu fouler ce à quoi il va lier
prend prise
en deux fois ouais de temps je sonne
non non non ça va ça va
mais
non non mais ça va parce que le seul
coup c'est kelly ses trois tours c4 faut
repartir en b 5
enfin vous trouvez ça faut remettre leur
enlève ça aide c'est surtout le temps
seul coup en fait oui mais bon pied
après quand à kindu tas de boue oui mais
bon enfin là encore perdu tour f 4g 6 tu
as tes pièces en périphérique enfin les
blancs sont bien mes
retours à 1,50 la côte sud
finissez pas
il a fait aussi ce
diallo 6 il a fait 6 et 5 e 6
hélas alors dit edf 6 pouces et 5
cavalli ce tour kei ses cinq tours ces
cinq
noms mais petite fille va faire c'est
sûr et tourache c8 seul coup pour faire
vraiment égal et c'est fini
enfin c'est fini
c'est jamais fini mais il a fait le
système pour but la voûte obligé de
faire mais oui je sais ça t'as pas le
choix mais enfin ce
temps on avait gagné les candidats
bon c'est pas fait encore il a plus de
temps l'autre
tombe
non c'est chaud encore
mais il a dû rater quelque chose à la
fin d'une variante c'est pas possible
non pas nous on et pepper avec ton ordi
ça j'ai du rater
mes tours 4
5 mais je dois dire que c'est quand même
un défaut de maxime femme quand même
c'est peut-être russes n'ont pas il joue
trop vite ça je suis je trouve pas tous
présents et qu'ils abusent mais parfois
quand il a les positions gagnantes
iras tu me rappelles regards étaient
parties quand mam est un truc où il
était muet tout ça et mais c'est du
rapide non violent en il ya deux ans un
truc comme ça et j'avais commenté 2,3 à
chaque fois qu'ils prenaient l'avantagé
le sport il est en un coup et c'est vrai
que c'est peut-être la différence avec
un caruana par rapport à ça
ouais ouais non menacées de viol un ding
tu vas caruana été trouvé tour 4 tout ça
il peut vraiment le faire c'est
complètement dans ses cordes tout ça le
truc c'est par ordinateur est ce que
justement
quelles lignes en indoor dit ban à une
épaule à l'oeuf ou des six oui bon ça ça
tu en veux à personne ne pas faire
parce que trop bizarre
[Musique]
ça monte en moi personne non plus en
fait parce que bon c'est mon enlèvement
on aime qui gagne qui perd ben c'est pas
ça qui fait la différence mais ouais
c'est un peu dommage quand meme c -j
c'est un jeu mais bon ok on va voir si
est-ce que c'est pas encore pas gagné
mais pour le coup objectivement c'est
plus gagnant alors que de flirter
gagnant juste là toute façon tu fais
tour agissez vite parce que sur ses six
f-16 pas le quitter je peux tenir à
l'esprit 2 1 je pense que c'est payant
d'abord dû pratiquer savez peut-être
plus facile pour les noirs donc voilà en
étant design
ou
ok oui tu fais ça comme ça et tu tu
essayes de blindés il ya toujours j'ai
craché qu'attache cinq sont fixés sur
blanc et tu peux dire que ça ira
toujours toi doigt les sommes j'ai pris
la peine rangés 5 courge
rouge très rouge ou attend tour français
c'est 3 f 8 tours prend ces quatre
affaires pour lui tout investissement
truc noble et à s'inquiéter
hu s'est pas encore nul c'est pas nul
non ça va peut-être encore il a écrit tu
y joues tu as qui se met mal autant et
qui du coup un
bon tour c'est ça qui va faire cela je
vois pas comment dans quel monde y'a pas
tout repenser cette non c'est cet ours
et qu'as tu fait
c'est bizarre a je pense juste que
vraiment c'est 6 ok cavaliers 7 c'est
clairement le problème fassis fait-on
france et khadafi j'étais quand même
contente pas la même que la partie 7 et
comme on disait ça fou prend 1,6 donc en
profiter puisque seul coup tourcoing la
fuite visiteurs durant visuellement t'as
plus envie de jouer sa
voix semble en outre d'école c'est tout
racheté 8 me un commerçant
lectoure h et l autre qu logic
immo juste une pâte ont plus ou moins ok
mais tu vas record tchèque 3 quai des
capucins et ben non mais ça je comprends
que tu puisses avoir peur et qu'elle
veuille acheter à tout coup mais du coup
pions rangée 5 ça ça fait quand même
plus peur que l'autre quoi t'est sauf
s'ils pensent contre jeu avec le pion
machin il connaît bien les finales ken
loach aucun
cas tu as peut-être wade si ceux ci
la première vue paraît bizarre mais en
réalité
moi j'aurais joué ça comme ça personne
n'aurait pas foutu mon futur des cas 3
c6 tour odéon tuez moi perso je
comprends pas pourquoi leur vie dit
gagnant pour les mains non mais va
déboucher ce nom mais je sais pas ça
suffit de me passe quand tu bouffes g7
c'est quand même cool ouais je passe
étages et 5 d'un en ligne de mire
ça tu en mets peut-être que je sache
c'est bon non mais franchement un truc
comme ça alors ça
tu me poussa à fond est ce que ça te
ferait qu' énormément ce colloque et
c'est sallie la plus humaine on est
d'accord maintenant ça va
et oh quel ordi te dis que tu es mieux
parce que tour des 1 tour 8 il te fait
tour c4 rwc à b5 tour c'est cet égard un
tempo son truc et interpol en vue de
tuer chaque enjeu sans d'automne pour
vous du coup de tête rousse faire
rabaisser ce qui est logique tout
reprendre les sept tours prend 2,6
et 20 ans il prend g5 et ça je peux
comprendre que ce soit hyper dangereux
parce que tu as deux pions passé les les
puits le plus bas et moins inventer des
choses comme ça
mais je peux concevoir que tu rates ça
avec les noirs parce que si tu as vu
cette variante l'acte je fais tour vite
ça va tu peux te et on sait 4 pourquoi
par web est-il d'ailleurs hapaska tourbe
et en maintenant
roissy ses tours ses 7 oui non mais ça
tu peux rater évidemment tu peux rater
c'est hyper dur et quand bien même est
ce que tu es si mal
non tu as he might be égal
puisque tu trouves le contre sur la
deuxième non mais
bon quand on avoir droit
est ce que vous dites qu'elle veut elle
se dit qu'il vient peut-être de passer à
côté d'un gain possible ça s'ils voient
que trucks
se stabilise il va comprendre qu'il
avait mieux c'est sûr qu'il s'est
clairement donné il devait très bien oui
mais là en fait il n'ya pas de super
déçu parce qu'il va quand même en finale
nouveau pressé oui non c'est sûr mes
joueurs après la partie si la gagne pas
il va comprendre que
non mais touré 4 c'est vraiment trop bas
je pense toujours des joueurs de ce
calibre là oui
pour les joueurs de ce calibre là c'est
pas
bon mais c'est loin d'être fini encore
ce qui avantage maxwell yalden maxdome
norman il ya avantage blanc ça veut pas
dire c'est gagnant
un jeu parfait de part et d'autre mais
puis bon n'oublions pas la pendule ya 17
secondes mais il reste encore sept coups
à jouer il va peut-être part je trouve
un truc précis il peut se planter après
si surtout repenser s'être fait roi des
six tours français 4 et à 5 ghz on sait
que là tu peux les vieux cadres assez
vite elle est ce que tu crois plutôt
faire très vite en fait aux de fer à
cinq je fais pas trop de ces deux
tons des killers
tu vois je sais moi c'est 6
et puis tu feras cinq plus tard
peut-être ou tour c'est touchez pas au
moins tu n'es pas g7 le truc qui comme
inquiétant tour trois et à cinq
maintenant
ou hutus rosat un je ne sais pas
je sais pas non mais c'est pas facile à
écrire c'est un concret
il va jouer un coup d'oeil au feeling il
ya tout qui prendra quelques
courses et c'est 3d si tu allais pas
partir en fuite c'est bien ce qu'on
pense et on sait 4 ça va être joué c'est
le seul coup
mais là on va voir il a fait tant ce que
je suis d'accord avec tours h au 8 de
femmes 1
j'ai passé non mais parce que tu force
un peu de toute façon tu veux tu veux la
mettre là cette tour quoi qu'il en soit
là un côté tour h et 8 tours des cas 3
et 6 tours 17 heim est à 36
annoncer une bonne gueule style et eu le
courage celui qu'on va voir
tout cas c'est une jolie partie mais
regardez si je pense qu'il a bien fait
un vrai fuite se mêlèrent très bizarre
non voilée si c'était bien joué bhp a
alors dit nous disions gratuite mais
j'aime pas mal non plus c'est pour ça
qu'on fait on utilise l'ordinateur mais
on on réfléchit par nous mêmes en même
temps on fait les deux alex a
pas il faut que j'arrête de le dire un
gérante mais mes cordes vocales vont
craquer ait enfin à 5000 à bassens bat
yonnais le même feeling que moi oui ça
veut dire beaucoup sur lui
mais je préférais ton cou après analyse
juste comme simple je situe raison pour
gesat mais
bon
le truc c'est que je crois que dice note
il lui reste qu il restait encore une
décision à prendre une grosse décision à
prendre mais après c'est fini
à l'ifac dit la malédiction de femmes
qui est fini enfin une belle partie où
elle est allée je lis à la
fois les geôles ici en tout cas j'espère
que vous kiffez dans le chatt n'hésitez
pas d'ailleurs si vous kiffez les live
vous pouvez suivre la chaîne bitstream
qui est juste en dessous il ya le lien
juste en dessous de la vidéo il y aura
une émission de rijkaard ce soir à
partir de 20h30 maths qui reviendra sur
l'autre partie où on reviendra sur
youtube avec fable sur la partie de max
et il y aura des choses se raconter de
mathieu qui reviendra sur
sur le reste et donc ça et à vous aussi
vous êtes vous abonner à youtube donc je
vais le mettre le mien et comme on
approche des 48 d'abonnés en plus ça
peut être sympa sous les nommer un petit
coup de main on aimerait bien faire les
40000 après et on fera la soirée
quarante mille à paris la poste comme
l'un
[Musique]
des 40 minutes donc n'hésitez pas à vous
à bosse sur sur la chaîne youtube j'ai
mille liens et il ya aussi en avril on
peut déjà l'annoncer fable l'habite
sprint cup qui va arriver première
édition alors il ya encore des petits
trucs qui peuvent
qui peuvent qui peuvent voilà encore
quelques petites questions mais a déjà
beaucoup de joueurs qui ont accepté de
la jouer les meilleurs joueurs français
donc la vitrine cup première édition fab
ça va envoyer du très très lourd
d'ailleurs tu joueras
si tu me demandes je ferais l'armée
attend c'est juste pas que c'est qu'on a
envie de suivre notre rêve quoi contrat
fais pas
tu peux gagner le premier match johan je
jouerai je suis dans ce match
d'ouverture tu seras là
en fait ce que j'ai un peu réfléchi au
format du coup vu qu'on peut un peu de
temps je pense qu'il faut faire les
quarts de finale vendredi samedi puisque
les matches peuvent durer genre 1h30 2h
dont quarts de finale vendredi tu en
fais deux samedi deux quarts de finale
dimanche
les demies et la finale le samedi
d'après vrai jeu parce que tu en penses
tu as très bien toujours une semaine
pour se préparer
manger du poulet darricau tout ce à quoi
donc
la surface corona sera après les 50 cas
dans huit mois est possible
bah écoute vraiment je ne sais pas de
chien ce truc mais du coup mais on a
essayé de faire le plus de choses
possible pour
garder le sourire
on se lève les échecs ensemble il ya les
candidats puis après du court bitstream
cup dim est ce qu'il y aura une compet
des communautés depuis à les enfants les
vachement plus nombreux ouais on va
essayer de faire ça si des sauces et
qu'après je vous cache pas que je
voulais faire un match comme d après des
lives quoi mais le truc c'est que avant
enfin hier en fait j'ai senti que je
commence à faire un poil de surmenage de
stream notamment au niveau de la voix et
des cordes vocales et du coup ça m'a mis
un peu en pls donc je me dis que je veux
souvent faire beaucoup de choses tu me
connais et qu' il faut que je m'auto
ralentissent que sinon je vais je vais
être malade et puis c'est pas trop
l'objectif en plus surtout par les temps
qui courent j'ai envie de faire un peu
attention à mon immunité parce que la
team globules blancs pourraient devenir
utile
quand même un petit peu
est-ce que je m'échauffe la voir dans
les stream non mais
j'ai pas de localisme du petit
lac qui m'a fait marrer le pur d'à côté
dit non parce que d'ici là on risque de
perdre des sabots donc ça sera la soirée
des 20 cas
dans les globules blancs la team
globules blancs va être utile
comment elle va ta team globalement
faber bon c'est pas l'autre normal je
pense est sur le coup ouais ouais ça sur
twitter
là je me suis fait un petit truc pas mal
il ya deux jours je compte là parce que
je veux pas je peux aller faire des
courses tout le temps mais je me fais
je fais un petit fusion avec du citron
vert et du gingembre et du miel
gingembre et c'est que c'est la rose à
deux places en plus non vraiment
vraiment mais au fait qu mais va se dire
oui fallait peut-être beaucoup moins
qu'on peu près il est quand même très
content ne limitons pas à mais moins que
prévu je donne je crois que c'est une
bonne recette non oui je donne un peu de
rome à mettre à drake ou quoi comment
faites vous pour que prévu
[Musique]
non qu
est ce qu une victoire est possible oui
c'est encore possible
mais bien il prend ça pour les prenais
ça pour les partis quand il jouait
citron gingembre
et citron vert attention c'est la pointe
mais moi j'attends que mes trucs qui
poussent là mais citron vert mais je
crois que jamais longtemps
tabou si les abeilles ne te manger des
trucs malines butiner hb henriot fait
qu'aujourd'hui non mais je commence à
comprendre avec une toujours à 2 c les
deux mêmes
âges et de tous les jours ça tombe à
l'eau ont trouvé leur
leur petit jardin que venir tranquille
mais je m'en bats les appels passent
beaucoup de temps sur mon balcon le
matin malsain tout le temps par contre
de nouveau le bourdon qui est venu pour
c'est le même en fait un cfcm ya vu les
repasser devant il a un regard dévissé
mais il est parti beaucoup plus vite que
la dernière fois il a dû dire si je suis
encore sauvés sur le balcon des cons je
peux par raf je le connais je sais que
relativement bon je dis si ce balcon
n'appartient pas de cette position je
parle évidemment les deux sy-diop
d'abeilles sur la question sera alors de
vlad je pars ne comprennent vraiment
rien combien de fois vous allez devoir
venir pour comprendre
non pas réviser leurs fichiers ce matin
ma position appartient à ce pas les
coups
bas et je suis très heureux j'aurais
aimé petit citron vert et touche je suis
en grand mon admiration devant oui je
vivais agrandi fan j'ai également eu des
avertissements vers chez moi j'en ai
plus je crois que ça va prendre quelques
mois quand même là je croirais ça passe
assez lentement avec une sorte de
haricot magique
d'astérix mission cléopâtre
matches nuls paco magique à ses droits
dragon ball mais tu vois il faut tout
poussé d'un coup la panoramique ce qui a
fait la potion mais là je vais mettre à
fond de l'engrais
je vais m'en occuper 'nos très bien
fran francs prend fruges qui annonce
qu'il vit un petit résumé du jour
écoutons tu repasses la partie en rapide
en gros grosse p pas de maxime pour
faire un résumé il obtient un gros
avantage à la sortie de l'ouverture du
tout mal autant révèle qu'il ya
peut-être une occasion de prendre un
avantage décisif qu'il la rate et
maintenant c'est votre position maxima
toujours un avantage mais qu'il choque
sur un jeu parfait doit pouvoir faire
nul mais faut-il encore faire un jeu
parfait voilà c'est bien résumé
bien comme il faut
donc il en fait ce début de partie
ghetto et avait déjà joué exactement ça
compte les pouilles lors de la deuxième
partie du tournoi jusqu'à cette position
l'année peut faire rage de l'onu g4
et donc h4 ces nouveautés théorique il
ya eu tellement le pod partie normale
maxime a décidé de donner un pion et
pour doubler tour assez vite vers la
colonne h et c'est d'être défoncé et 7
tout ça très bien mais green shoots qui
réagit bien et cloud lecavalier s'est
arrêtée rap ça ça joue bien et là le
tournant peut-être une fois qu'il a fait
à quatre cavaliers prend il a pas trop
la suite la plus précise
c'était tours 4 c'est heureux 4 on
aimera de suite en résumé sur la vidéo
ou dans des bars ont fini comme rapport
rien à dire on reviendra dessus
mais toujours est il
que du coup il est rentré dans cette
finale deux tours on force où il
al'avantage mais du coup le roi noir et
va pas s'échapper et les normes le
contre jeu avec le pion à qui commencent
à avancer
vous prend ses cinq baies mangement je
mangeais 5 obligé bloqué au roi mon tour
français 4 et il pousse son tour et on
en est là à maxime de réfléchir on peut
penser qu'il va tenter d'aller s'en
prendre aux plans g7 puis essayer de
prendre un g5
mais pendant qu'il fait tout ça le pion
à vha avancé et les normes du contre je
enfin j'aimerais bien revenir sur la
question des cylons 876 comme on est
assez nombreux et on n'a peut-être pas
mal qui se posera une question puis il y
des buts et il a un petit peu du mal à
progresser et des plus tôt échec donc ce
qu'on peut te recommander déjà tu peux
t'en sers sur chaque point comme tu as
le lien en dessous et aura le lien aussi
qui va dans le chat pour pouvoir jouer
des parties puisque tu peux progresser
aux échecs en jouant déjà ça te
permettra d'améliorer ce qu'ils
appellent en anglais bordeaux en laisse
mon anglais mais ta vision de
l'échiquier pour faire moins d'erreurs
après tu peux utiliser les entraîneurs
tactique aussi tu verras il ya des
outils sur check point comme pour entre
états tactique et in fine et tu peux
aussi prendre un abonnement
diamants par exemple pour avoir accès à
toutes les leçons il y en a cent
vingt-cinq ans français et du coup ça
permettra d'avoir des bases solides pour
arriver jusqu'à mille quatre cent mille
cinq cents ou en gros après tout la
chaîne
chenilles du bain la chaîne youtube je
peux te la mettre tu peux aller regarder
les parties pédagogique les deux jours
en douce que side story s'appelle partie
pédagogique dont on a pour débutants
suivant ton niveau et tu trouveras sur
la chaîne youtube dont j'ai mis le lien
dans le tchat donc ça fait quand même
pas mal de titres de petites choses déjà
avoir tu peux avoir la facilement si tu
réunis tout une cinquantaine d'heures de
contenu vidéo adapté à ton niveau ouais
tout bonnement donc c'est un canter
c'est déjà pas mal j'ai dû pratiquer
machin pire pas tu vois mais ouais c'est
un bon début ouais moi j'irai pratique
tactique un peu les parties pédagogique
si tu veux aller plus loin à
l'abonnement diamant de chasse comme
pour avoir pour avoir les vidéos
payantes qui sont aussi sympa avec des
exercices supplémentaires et c'est
autour d'un voire deux sets joués
[Musique]
suis surtout le contenu bitstream c'est
vraiment topissime je suis passé de 800
à 1200 deux mois grâce à qu'elle va et
c'est pas mal
du tout même
sa remontée vous aurez donc tourner un
roi au set et là alors dit adorent voir
cet immense tour c 'est 3 prend aussi
c'est plus propre fils on est des matins
pas vraiment mais non sur tours de
4,7 tour 17 bref si ce n'en est pas
moins toujours des trois mais ça fait
peur ok tu dois faire un g6 tour des 6 3
et s'est fait bouffer j'ai battu à paris
vii luc émond fait un peu monter juste
on savoir que j'avais du mal à savoir si
c'était si grave si del tempo recettes
mais toute façon tu veux garde le pion
[Musique]
depuis on va prendre
ça peut continuer comme ça j'ai juste eu
tout ça non ouais c'est ça en fait
orange et 5 pouces ou jours après je
fais comme on a vite à leur tour c'est
victor pensait d'eux et d'autres tueries
tu veux me pu faire manquer ouais en
fait dès lors un ton plus mais une tour
très passive en l aidant s'activent à
fond ça sent la gnôle 200 la news
c'est quand même une
vraie occasion ratée mais ouais ouais
c'est la première petite déception une
partie de max pour le mans que jusqu'ici
le parcours avait été parfait sans faute
c'est le premier demi point à l'essai
exactement
bon on attend de voir c'est fini
vraiment mais bon dieu tout cas plus que
quatre coups à jouer toujours cinq
minutes 30 via sa paire d'ailés coup
trop dur c'est roy prend le 6 5 lat
à caruana
il a l'air bien il a l'air bien parce
que
puisque la dame pour entrer tu avais vu
cette chanson improbable d'une chanteuse
avec un à rudolf sur caruana ah ouais
mais c'est toujours la même chanteuse
qui change tout
joe gatta google au carré si vous voulez
jeter un méchoui que peut-être quelqu'un
peut mettre le lien et nous dire ce que
vous y pensez ce que vous en pensez
norman moi je la connaissais avant que
soit connue parce qu'elle venait faire
intendant du tabbee chaque année
j'allais faire voir de la plage a
inventé un ton calabre
c'est pour ab3 fins et les toits matters
mais les échecs mais voilà je sais
qu'elle est un peu de musique et puis
c'est pas tout d'un coup est devenue
musicienne échec enfin connu vite fait
inconnu par l'armée et je dire que
personne ne connaissait brasillach
l'inde était partout machin
voilà c'est sûr tu vas dans la rue
konami
personne mais mes dans les chats qu'elle
est devenue assez connus vous demande
qu'est ce qui nous empêche de défendre
le pion le stis battue peut faire tour 4
mais il va te fais retour des 8es
leroyer bloc est en fait le pion ici tu
pourras pas le faire avancer tour eiffel
entouré fit peut-être juste non mais
enfin tu viens de jouer autour des 1
s'était enlevé la défense du pion
c'est pas pour juste faire attendre
le date que finalement contraint ben
c'est pas un bon signe donc quoi cette
côte de 3,20 sur la nulle
bah bravo à ce qu'une blessure ne sais
pas combien faut toujours maintenant il
faut toujours faire confiance à la drôme
quoi
web ont vu la situation qui avait son
arrivée
il ya de quoi faire
ouais bon accueil qu'ils à 1600 pl
progresse vite ne vitesse exponentielle
et a fait sa com en fait
c'est beaucoup tricheur intelligent tu
n'es pas monter trop
tu as quand même perdu la partie à la
fin
avec les vidéos youtube adabio fait
objectif et ça c'était la qualité à moi
mais tu les regardes tous tu fais quoi
est c'est parti pédagogie c'est le
machin qu'est ce que tu regardes tu
regarde juste tout à fond tu te
concentres tu regardes une deuxième fois
ça se passe comment fait on à bertoua
facile qu est-ce que pas si facile
parmi la musique non chez nous au kiki
mis cette musique d enfermer
mais peut-être que c'est parce qu'ils
écoutent la musique
via le lien qui est passé
le coq la faune quoi
il ya deux cas comment ils se battaient
là ils sont un peu plus
les bâtards
bynum patois les coqs qui sont très
noirs et ne visait pas les autres kaka
des cages bavette via un code qu'il veut
rester là être maître de
l'air le monde se met à la page 12 or
qu'est un autre coque et qui peut
rivaliser que et l'autre cas qu'il est
chaud
du coup ils font les malins les eaux
failli c'est de vous entre temps la
gamme un qui est un peu au dessus
l'autre voie je suis pas rien et qui est
plus jeune que l'autre en tout cas
mais non je pense qu'ils sont je sais
pas trop je n'aime pas trop les liens je
vous promets les deux dans le dos de me
faire pour en confinement une bonne
sociologie des coques je vais regarder
ça se révolte ait bataille que aussi que
oui si je suis là dégage
des études pas aller tuer ça c'est qui
ce qu'on tue qui vont s'allier tous les
deux on peut dire très avis quand même
dégageons le lui
donc
il peut pas faire plus tôt tour des
cases du temps et celles ci on avait
montré tout à l'heure mais on va on va
laisser un peu la partie se
déroulait
c'est bon on est en train de rattraper
on en est encore loin mais ça et qu'on
est assez nombreux j'étais en train de
me dire on peut peut-être théoriquement
même dépassé de chasse comme en anglais
mais ils ont la première page
ce serait beau de les déplacer cours des
3 min disent rien et 3200 3100 ou pas de
premières pages sans faire perdre est
extraordinaire c'est fou non
merci en tout cas à tous de suivre
20 pouces
non mais c'est n'importe quoi les russes
jazz chorus ils font une pause banon
pose de quoi
ils sont fragiles non ouais c'est
fragile quoi c'est ce qui se passe c'est
beau quand fait jamais de pause ah oui
les italiens qui commente
marco enfin renvoyer zidane
mais les portugais va fouiller les gens
partout quoi c'est beau
c'est beau
mais 48 spectateurs pour les échecs
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal mais c'est
pas non plus énorme énorme et c'est pas
mal
de regards vers un retour des mises au
jeu tard les monstres des sables c'est
quand même une vraie menace
la chute annonce
normalement tu veux pas quand même tenir
avait offert à 4 mais c'est contre
intuitif mais tu vas jamais faire à 4
non mais tu peux dire oui tournée c'est
toujours moi tu prends un pion je pousse
à 3 tu là
non tu fais tour des huit oui je n'ai
pas
appris depuis toujours t'énerver 1
ce serait beau de s'énerver
je tenais à la font quoi
là cinquante secondes
c'est pas lourd
cinquante secondes c'est pas lourd 40
peut faire le décompte quoi les records
tombent
malades à quoi il pensait
en fait plus de coups et simple puis les
landes je crois que c'est hyper
compliqué la jouer vite quoi la fête
hors des buts
il a attendu deux heures trente et une
secondes pour faire
tomber un il va faire tourner 8 c'est
exactement ce qu'on avait montré en puis
c'est marrant
on va faire tomber 8 db vite normalement
ses cadres eux aussi l'option pour assad
c'est un peu artificiel mais je situe
diktatur des 8es pas si mal
quai max la sphère tour des cinq je
pense à 400 francs g5 temps j'ai tout ce
qu'il faut pousser fukushima ont tâté
th6 maintenant
elle a fait autour des baies vitrées
sait tous qu'on arrête le tempo aux
siens
tombé 5 à 4 en gestion 80 pour avoir
envie aussi le seul pion à quoi
tu peux calculer mais l'arrêt c'est déjà
38e coup les gars grichka plus de quoi
jouer après récupère 50 minutes donc il
va souffrir
il souffle
ce qui peut pousser gretsch ou non mais
parce qu'en fait déjà les blancs se veut
le faire nous les revenants des la
tonine ya tonini cause elle veut qu'on
dise son nom pour son physique et dont
ce taux n'est ni quoi nicosia winnie
cause dans la trousse dit ouais mais
très heureux son fils va dire oui mon
pseudo a été dit
premio kivu il va pouvoir aller souffler
pendant 30 minutes
derrien tonyg deuxième
j'aime pas la tour ambert oui mais bon
si tu veux tu peux faire tour f1 tour f
8 tours d un tour des huit et fermiers
la nature parties d'ailleurs ça peut
finir comme ça
il est reprochable sur ses coûts gritche
non-demandes heroes and well et dire
qu'il est reprochable maintenant mais il
faut dire que il est passé par un moment
où maxime avait le cas en poche mais
après il fallait trouver c'était dur et
ses quatre voitures sont tombées 5 bat
le truc c'est qu'on pense surtout aux
médecins qui le pousse à 24
ans g5 et or g8 et le truc c'est que
[Musique]
ça fait phil quoi se filent droit
du coup
ce classico un pont plus mature est
passive il ya aussi ce qui va être
fragile enfin nul normalement ce qui
peut forcément entourent f1 tout réduit
tout reprend f8 ouais je veux juste
faire tout
et je l'envoyais à et
c'est assez effrayant sakhalin-1 mail en
vous même perdre avec le mans puisque
alors que puisque très loin du roi blanc
on veut on dort à tour passive devant
comme des idiots le renard va venir
prendre un long terme
non il est peut-être temps de vraiment
prendre la nuit la tombe et 5 jouer bon
bah à 4 tours angers 5 à tour j'ai vite
ça va être oui mais tu peux encore faire
nul
mais là j'ai plus trop de doutes sur
l'issue de la partie facile il reste
deux couacs
sacha avec les noix et restos
façon g5y
compagnie quoi
de quatre normales d'autocontrôle qui va
avoir une minute 41 récupère son temps
et normalement ça va aller pour les 1/4
idée jouer vont pas prendre les 5 je
suis sûr qu'ils veulent jouer assez vite
max et il va devoir de faire ce que je
fais à 3 ou ceux souhaitant j'ai vu mon
temps je sers plus normal que de donner
g700 reprendre mes chèques la tour qui
revient sur le premier groupe
donc mon avis
mon avis
quand les 500 g 8 7 les deux prochains
coups et on arrive au 40e
du coup sacha pouvoir se lever 30
minutes
ouais
ça c'est caruana on retournera voir
il lui même ou alors dit dan perrins
égal mais est réalisée dame de cartes
bon ok ça on verra plus tard irrigué
riani
il a bien sûr eu l'idée comme la tuer
son va tout ça ça à faire mieux c'est
sûr plus ou moins
vieux
support commencent à préférer les noirs
même pas bon
en fait je joue souvent ce genre de cela
vous a été bloqué tu vas tu actives et
les fous avec moi qu'il ya peut-être des
quatre qui avaient trois clés à 5
j'ai tellement souvent ce position côté
noir que je j'amplifie quoi
arias un bus qui passent devant chez moi
je ne peux pas voir ce but
sacha il a joué tournée 500 g et vite
comme prévu et il récupère du temps et
pas du coup on souhaite nous oui non si
objectivement nul quoi
en tournée fois la rina s'avoue toujours
dire la frénaye
158 joueurs mais moi fait la cure le
premier bloc de l'est très fort
est-ce que femme est à canohès ils
varient comme tu peux le voir nous
sommes côte-à-côte quoi
dans un peu des deux
mais c'est ce qu'on voulait faire de
base est ce qu'on avait prévu bon après
le corps n'arrive et interrompre les
plans donc on va éviter des
regroupements non non obligatoire je
vais devenir
femme et à calmer dans la partie juste à
côté
mais s'arrêter cool évidemment ça a été
très bien mais
il ya d'autres urgences dans la vie donc
bon on fait comme ça donc c'est vrai que
caméra peut-être un peu floue et que
faudrait il mettre ensemble et ça a été
plus cool c'est quand même très très
grave la caméra foot est la même
aujourd'hui nous l'a pas dit ça va mal
on peut un petit peu d
un petit peu quelque chose
non je suis un peu déçu mais bon
ce n'est pas passé loin
non c'est dommage parce que c'était
justement faisons
pense pas encore fini mais je j'ai du
mal à imaginer qu'il ya des carreaux à
narrer leurs designers et te dit
complètement égal alors attends pourquoi
on comprend même pas en fait
tant que j'ai du mal à me reconcentrer
sur une deuxième partie à fond tu vois
quand il ya eu un gros truc laïque nv et
j'ai toujours dû mathias et le moment
j'ai un peu de mal à me tue à bagdad ont
droit de faire la peau aux notions vote
ont pu une petite pause ya quand même
beaucoup de monde quoi c'est quand même
dommage faire une pause n'ont pas de
pause pub on off non mais peut-être une
pub par contre là je te dis oui quand tu
parles de plus que jeudi win win mais
pas de pause mais recule quelle cent
pensent ça un bon deal allez je pense
quand même trois mille personnes
no est une pub de qualité comme ouais
c'est vrai que karine belle gueule je
pense
franchement franchement pas une pub de
qualité
une pause comme sait plus trop
d'italiens avec de la musique bien forte
qui cassent bien les oreilles il me
saoule avec leur musique on
n'hésite pas folle aussi la chaîne jeu
pour le dire bah oui le flou la tchatche
com vous et mettre le petit coeur pur il
faut leur machine perso c'est en dessous
vous pouvez foule de la chaîne youtube
qu'on fait avec fabre c'est en lien n'y
a pas de lien il ya un lien qui arrivait
dans le chatt youtube.com cela jeux
vidéo et à bientôt les 40000 à vos
femmes voila voila j'aimerais bien que
ça arrive pendant les candidats
louise très bien
on débouche gens donnent
ouais on pourrait le faire d'ailleurs si
ça arrive quand les candidats fait du
shampoing bien l'éolien ce ouais
voilà le brouillard
a mis aussi mais juste après un poil
trop lente dictée par actif ouais mais
c'est pas en faute et parra lüthi
a lieu il y as
je leur ai mis la pub mon fable c'est
bien
ça fait du bien
au moins nous on peut discuter
tranquille où on attend qu'ils se
regardent la pub pour s'entraîner c'est
bien les échiquiers électronique il vaut
mieux jouer sur chaise comme elle je
pense que jouer sur thiès carafon
non plus ce qui est bien ce que je
compte des gens et chez getronics
loupiots compte landing donc ça a coûté
aussi moins convivial bon après ça te
fait jouer en 3d comme ça c'est un
avantage
mais je pense a plus de limite ce que
davantage
j'ai pas de pub c'est complètement fou
jean charest c'est dommage
non mais il n'en voit pas la pub pour
tout le monde
seule l'élite à me voir la pub j'ai dit
que c'est une petite pub pour le mondial
en chef comme ça etc c'est l'occasion
de progresser aux échecs
théodore zappa kindy max avait largement
du temps pour trait le coup de tours
gagnant il a voulu justifier à quatre de
suite a oublié le coup gagnant
intermédiaire
bon il ya que si le tour prend 6 4
simple
et pour masquer les noirs claude
vanbelle sfg cinq matches on
l'accusé je n'ai pas de pub j'ai le
droit d'avoir la pub bordel mais pour
tech3 et les excuses des excuses au bac
tu sois
tu vas tu veux une pub bordel
ares 1 qui a lui dit aussi qu'il a créé
à un sobre et dit échec pour les gens
qui sont souvent surveillés dit c'est
cool
ce demi points de perdus risquent de
coûter très cher à max à la fin on verra
un des deux en arrière tout le monde
viendra des demi point je crois perdants
après c'est juste c'était tellement beau
de gagner
mais bon
scandaleux de fermer des tubes c'est un
scandale
fait un nul contre intel imagine
alors
la psychologie comment ça va être dur au
je suis pas non non non
non mais ça a été très beaucoup plus
dommage c'était un match en élimination
directe où tu rates la qualif ou quoi là
on fait un truc en 14 ans monde tu
tombes mi-chemin donc qui bonhomme de
chemin
t'as plus après quatre rondes certains
magazines te fait trois nuls donc tu es
bien il n'ya pas il ya aucune raison de
se mettre en place je ne sais
pas en pls 1
ça a bien marché et ouais d'ailleurs
normalement frein réel à la fin du live
fable sur la nouvelle chaîne de mari ce
bague
ya soulevé samedi aujourd'hui
à ça et a perdu contre des jours
seuil de recommande de mettre un
calendrier et de
worodougou point tu vois que bordeaux
samedi lundi ou demain nous sommes
changés à la haye mais il te dis oui tu
peux remettre le réveil la semaine plus
tard le week-end histoire de garder un
rythme de vie quoi mais moi j'ai jamais
vain fait toute ma vie c'était pareil
des jours
juste tu as faim
des genres plus court plus long
quand je donne des cours c'est peut être
le dimanche peu avant tu as trahi le
week-end jamais alors je pars en
tournois joués l'interclubs chef un
job semaine genre de week end voilà
fréjus c'est pour sortir le soir fight
night club la whey là ça change
après tu peux tu rythme et au rythme des
sorties des épisodes quoi dimanche soir
lundi
intercall son look et lalla ouais là je
dis oui
je pense qu'elle aurait dû 18-25 doivent
se dire le confinement n'a rien changé à
ma vie
ok bon là ça va être
nepomniachi donc alors fait surtout
parce que ça a l'air très bien pour
caruana je sais par an ça longtemps
faudra regarder l'émission m'a dit oui
puis en fait non snarr et on la savait
leur dire quoi quel est alors dit cette
dame des quatre qui étaient quand même
très tentant pour
iphone
est juste sublime peut-être pas si on
forme deux autres
parce que je veux dire la leaf à thiers
ça me faisait pas à penser
que ce spécialement
mal pour lui c'est arrive il prend un
risque dans l'ouverture et ses acteurs
mais à deux pas pressé plus avec la
pression qu'il a c'est étonnant
on nous dit félicitations encore eto'o
pour son analyse d'hier indique le plus
souvent qu'elle va faire revenir ce soir
à 20h30 il sera de retour sur la chaîne
bitstream vous avez le lien juste en
dessous si vous n'êtes pas pas sur la
chaîne
donc il sera de retour et demain tout le
tout les gens de repos et vote là ce
poisson vaudra du lourd
fait un peu moins d'humour que la
première fois quand même ils auraient dû
traître et la cfu
bayrou et du très très lourd pas
savez-vous il a écrasé quelques
personnes quoi
est ce que c'est
même toi et ta flash et non
moi je veux faire la redif parce que
j'ai pas pu j'avais un jeu donnait un
cours en même temps dont j'avais un peu
à un moment je suis passé j'étais là et
puis j'ai pas pu tout voir en entier
mais je le ferai la redif ça c'est sûr
parce que je sais que c'est que c'est
hyper intéressant
[Musique]
ça peut être quatre aujourd'hui au final
c'était intéressant avant les blondes
précis partout puis puis finalement well
as à faire un nom sinon c6 ou prendre b4
c'est cette
suite et n'arrivent pas à damer khwaja
le fou
parce qu'on peut ce que j'aurais fait un
x 600 mouvements
genre québec n'en est pas là un trou
dans lequel v3 bang
il est bien en place c'est même pas sûr
je suis pas te retrouver maria clément
mon avis oui je suis d'accord un pion de
moins le pion des peut être pas c'est
donc là non ça à faire nul
je suis pas comment il va faire
exactement mais cette poussée si ce
boulot c'est liquidation totale
les poumons des stocks de métal tête tu
dois faire tout doit disparaître tu as
tu dois faire ça en fait me bats nul
ok on verra maxime va pas bouger caruana
archi nul ouais ben 4 nuls ont vu
ce sera un statu quo et maxime qui
jouerait demain alex enhco avec les
noirs d'après ce que je sais si je me
rappelle bien d'accord
ben écoute c'est jouable avec cenco en
plus ils jouent
ils pas venus pour pour souffrir
n'ont ils pas dû vous faire des nuls
sans rien faire donc du coup
du coup tout est jouable il peut le
prendre
pour le mans en tout cas ils coupent
alex n co reims il refait troisième
gueule aujourd'hui sera et demi sur
quatre tu vois c'est pas la cata qu'on
attendait non mais il serait il serait à
hauteur de guiry de de ding je pense
qu'il va gagner un peu de points elo non
ouais non mais en fait je m'attendais
pas à ce qu'il fasse 0 sur 14 crème mais
un truc aller 4 3 4 et puis c'est un
truc comme ça et là il est parti pour
faire un peu le pen obtient le temps à
-4 genre à cinq
australiens 5 quand même
dans un ton appareil c'est dur
l'association accès des points
donc ça va pas bouger dans l'emphase
auront tous en dix points de plus mais
ça changerait en mode
web alex enhco week-end dernier mais
mais grichting et yari et après si
l'organe unis se relance complètement
qua
non mais ouais ouais
ni
tard il peut peut-être évité la dernière
place c'est peut-être peut-être
bon après son séjour à tous ceux
chauffés petit à petit aussi ça commence
et bizarrement l'ambiance ou quoi et
puis même guéri aujourd'hui malade a
refait le meilleur parti que ce qui d
une fois
je pense que tu en penses tu penses
aussi
ding
écoute il n'a pas gagné il a à peu près
ses fans lui aussi est un peu de retour
donc
finalement c'est pas mal pour max soit
mal parti passe comme ça ça met un peu
derrière mais peut faire son retour
caruana je sens pas rayonnant mais bon
fallait juste pas loin derrière
moi celui qui a le mieux réussi le début
du tournoi c'est né paul bailly maximum
mais n'est pas je crois qu'il a faim max
il a fait trois blancs et noirs
nra je crois qu'il a fait un blanc 3
noir et qu'aucun blanc n'est pas je
crois
mais l'a fait qu il a battu guiry noir à
la première ouais il ait eue avec sing
cotnoir la française il est noir
aujourd'hui donc youtube landes
[Musique]
c'était pas bien dit
mais bon tu vois ça me paraît être un
début de tournoi wpt est
assez réussi
on va prendre la tête ce soir l'afrique
qui gagne révèle aux aguets je pense
alors à temps il a fait quoi il a fait
ses six fours en v4 et au
4t raison par l'idée sur pions prend ses
cavaliers prend menace qui promet m6
vous prend john c'est lui qui a passé
quatre ou six
fours 17 au gamescom releveur fossé
qu'il ya tant mieux on va dire et ont
des symptômes
et jean qui
devrait encore gagner tout ce que j'en
sois il sera gagnant si l'adoption mais
non mais bloqués ont passé mais bon je
vois jeu français nul quand même fougue
mois
cjl en l'espèce des changes efficace
blanche qui naissent le roi adverse
coupe ettu monde ton roi tu fais des
trucs par ci par là
peut-être et merci à dave à 29 97 81
tous 25 58 à
48 pour le tweed à la merci tonton très
punchy et ça serait joué avec les blancs
aux normes là je prends les blancs comme
le roi est coupée j'ai pas très peur du
pion b je vois pas dans quel monde je
l'avais remet à
bon
dieu jouer des matches faciles parce
qu'on va plus ou moins voir ce qui se
passe
hong kong qui essayent de jouanno tordre
le cou fait leur dit je recommande de
commencer par vous ck3 fuite
j'ai changé je fais chez calme après
j'ai quatre
francs g4 et carrey prend le 4
ok mais ça j'aurais choix pas rentrer la
tempe non mais tu pression latente oui
c'est peut être par essence est jamais
bet inse qui dit leur dit
maxime
je pense en fait les trois autres
croient que c'est nul plus ou moins
clair
il ya que celle là où il ya du il ya
encore du vrai suspense encore que dans
les autres partis quelque chose peut se
passer mais à première vue il reste
encore du suspense ici on n'est qu'en
29e coup en plus de femmes ouais ils ont
2037 web oui
je sais très content d'être over pouchet
fin de conneries aussi je sais pas il
peut y avoir des choses truc c'est qu'on
regarde c'est un joueur d'open fap donc
pour lui un mec à 26,98 il a envie de
toi mais le développement il a
l'expérience pour battre ce genre de
joueurs peut-être plus que les autres
d'ailleurs donc il peut avoir envie de
presser et tenter de sortir c'est vrai
que s'ils gagnent aujourd'hui bongo
c'est un temps sur un début de tournoi
en fanfare pour lui complètement
complètement
et s'il ya une égalité à la fin du
tournoi mystère 90 sur un rapide de
départage
fois qu'ils diem max aime les open aussi
ai je crois que vendeur est quand même
plus expérimenté que max en open nom
qui en garde
bamogo il a eu de très bons résultats en
open récemment mais max en fait kiffer
pas 5000 open mais quand il fait
gibraltar il réussit quand même en
général
mais c'est pas c'est pas un manga hausse
par un peu tes pattes de l'open quoi
bomber maxx le truc c'est que ben il a
mieux à faire mais qui jouent tous les
tournois de l'élite est qu'il ya très
peu d'oxygène pour faire un apport est
le reflet du tout les arénas et jose
arrimage la peau de chasse ligue avec
les coques les speech est donc forcément
car on nous dit mme sanchez tours tout
ça on ne dit nulle signer ou non
on dit n'importe quoi et la fage 6 max
julen encore prise en régie six prises
angers 8 prises angers 8 prises en a
dans la clape prison de six puits
doivent plus rien sur l'échiquier
peut-être faire h5 intermédiaire
est nul
je leur ai même ligne houle
fois que je censure non non ça
ouais ça c'est sûr que c'est mieux
vraiment sûr maintenant j'ai à jouer là
c'est vraiment sur ça liquide
qu'elle de porte-bagages
c'est un peu un duel mais
disons après le début du tournage était
pris de sympathie pour digne alors que
normalement enfin j'ai rien contre lui
rien pour je m'en fiche mais il était
dit tiens j'ai rien qui reviennent un
peu
nerveux est l'âme dans le tournoi tu vas
fin au kenya que dirige changement rien
contre lui mais tu vois j'ai pas troicki
no tournoi de bâle gri gri gri mai
caruana ça fera un beau challenge heures
parce qu'elle a déjà montré qu'ils
savaient faire un ding imméritée mais
elle pas forcément dessus de tout et
katchoo passe quand même bien
et caruana ouais j'ai mis dans des coins
où tout le monde ça veut dire il n'en
avait dit rires mais c'est pas qu'on
n'aime pas
ça et là qu'elles étaient un peuple
autre style de jeu
qui est à 100 je veux penser aucune
chance en finale s'il rejoignait
finalement pourquoi ma demie joue pas
tournoi fable je sais pas mais juste il
est déjà champion du monde est en fait
le tournant à l'objectif c'est de
définir qui sera son challenger
donc il va pas ceux d'autres challenges
et voilà c'est malin reste qu'il a fait
avec cenco
il s'est débrouillé en faisant foi f5
pour sur ces huit sacrifier comme ça le
roi époque où peu elle aurait pas coupé
bon alors ça c'est nul en sifflotant
même stupeur ben ouais à la règle
normalement c'est que quand tu as un
pion plus sur lèze c'est du beau
jeu même pas s'il va la tenter
waouh comment l'appeler ao je vois que
le monde son prénom comme le judo de
bombes non attending lire est celle
irène son prénom je sais pas c'est
compliqué on attend à alex and co sont
donc ces wang son nom au cas où son
prénom et un nom son prénom
ces digues le nom à heavy rain le prénom
et c'est raul a
prodigué rhône ces noms de famille
normalement en sens inversé laissera
puisque en fait ça s'est tellement
collés ensemble vachement du mal tu me
dit wang je pense à lui
mais à we
were on ressort donc
ça me rassure plus
est ce que je sois me prend en charge
etc et des gt que je sais pas le potiron
quoi j'ai pas sûr de chasse comme il
prend en charge les échiquiers dgt tu
peut retransmettre avec un bel été sur
deux chaises comme mais je ne sais pas
si tu peux
c'est ce qu'ont fait tellement jamais
la petite nul va être signée
bon
bon dommage mais coûtent pas un bon
résultat dans l'absolu
elle présente peut-être avoir monde qui
va nous le voulons tendre
pourquoi les jeux faits paroisse g7
il veut le faire non enfin je vois pas
de plus value un autre ordre de coups
comme elle je fais cinq avants du coup
tu lui la jouer quelque chose et tu as
tu veux dire
le petit et qui a disparu a glissé
jusqu'à nice paris
peut-être que non mais tu vas pas
disparaît c'est un bug ça me a river
heil et là il est de retour il est de
retour
lange s'est envolé
nul à la la nuit lada commence ça y est
c'est parti est-ce que tu as si on sait
qu'ils vont partir pour des nuls de
partout tout le temps non non ça va
jouer à fond chaque jour mais après nul
vaut oublier que c'est ça le plus normal
aux échecs le plus probable
le plus probable est en gros ce qui fait
pas enfin si les deux joueurs jouent
bien largement gagné les c'est quand
même des bons joueurs donc ils font pas
cinquante mille faute aux nuls c'est
plus ou moins normale et
il y aura bien 70% nul dans le temps
est plus à chercher mieux si froid âmes
et ce à cause de femmes
et l'indicé toile c'est waouh c'est
quand on est au lundi c'est toi non
lundi je crois que je fais j'ai vu là
j'ai pour mon téléphone avec lequel on
est dessus un an l'indicé naturel et toi
c'est après ouais mais vivre normalement
je devais faire un pote bien daffy duck
and i
[Musique]
way
bien on pourra intervertir en vrai avec
tout le monde débloque à la maison
maintenant
oui enfin pour que ça non mais pour que
ça
change
donc oui
c'est génial seif avant sur la fin pour
ce faire
on se
passe chez
l'un des cinq ans la safer du l'on va
aller voir en direct la partie de la
nuit de maxime les pions s'échanger en
b3 il ne restait plus que les rois sur
l'échiquier
est-ce que je pense que faire passer un
si on prend et pattes
donc je te battrais pas je fais 3 6 4
quand même pris peut faire trois mais
quatre
noms
là nul ici ok alors
tokyo bar dommage mais quand c'est comme
ça nulle ding aussi si voilà ça n'a pas
traîné et du coup wang hao c'est le sol
hoc aussi un petit moment sinon oui mais
c'est complètement nul
ça c'est juste nul théorique
qualité de moi un pion sur la même elle
c'est un pion de plus c'est nul là en
plus c'est le pion b chez bord je ferais
bien jce
ont déjoué à toi c'était pas des
coureuses et par l'ordi comme juste
moi de le ronger 6
non mais je sais pas en fait tour c'est
cette j'ai pas nous faire couper
mon prend s'en fiche ça va aussi vers
compte tous les coûts vont maintenant et
evian f54 faire une grosse chaîne de
pions
si on fait 5 nous c'est sûrement un très
bon coup tour c'est cette
web mais peut-être qu'ils ont pour un
prochain jugement fixé par l 3
j'ai pas trouvé
ça va très bien maintenant 3 non mais
oui non je regarde mais
[Musique]
il va un peu la jouer avec les blancs je
pense bon juste normal vu que t'es peut
pas manger de pernes après je pense
projet vite ce serait grave peut-être ça
perdrait pas mais ça c'est grave on ne
comprend vraiment rien
non mais belle journée en belle journée
qu'un succès en voir le gars monté par
elle va on te montrera en fera une vidéo
résumé en fait on montrera tout non les
gars enfin juste là je vois que les gens
disent comment ça il a signé là nul ding
en fait il ya eu nulle au coude avant
rodez 5 c'est ce qu'ils ont mis les rois
mais de l'échiquier c'est pas dernier
coup de la partie
ce qui est 10 h il y a 6 nuls à +3 ou je
sais pas quoi mais oui
ce n'est pas très étonnant
vous en feriez un parti donc et ça se
voit gens qui ont peut-être pas encore
jeu de tournoi ou quoi le cliché 10 gt
il est programmé pour que quand tu
places les rangs d'une certaine manière
au mieux de l'échiquier
il te retransmis en direct le résultat
tu mets les rois en d4 d5 côte à côte
ils te dis ok donc c'est nul voit en le
cadre des 5 ces lampes ont gagné et
n'inverse noir
juste une convention très important mais
du coup quand on voit un dernier coup
blizzard droit au centre comme ça et que
le résultat quoi sont pas l'impression
qu'on avait souvent salué
ces résultats l'intérêt n'appartient pas
la partie
bon
du coup h4 et là moi j'aurais fait 4 5 1
mais une chose que j'ai 5 va aussi
mais en fait le cas j'aurais commencé
par l'a40 là-dessus fixes les plus
lentement et des changes tout ce que tu
peux changer ouais
je fais plus rien je pense ça va signer
assez rapidement encore que wang hao il
a quand même eu tendance à jouer
longtemps
la vie c'est un livre le programme
développement bad et oui c'est qu'en
fait un plan tu pourrais espérer faire
sa maison en gîte mais fait partie des
fonds sur moi
car j'ai trois ou quatre bombes avaient
été bien qu'orange et
là on a vu le cas tu fais f3 admettons
on peut échanger alors les allers
retours avec le fouetter que tu te parmi
60 avec le roi fouet f2 et tâte
élections ont tenu le nul 1 but va
arriver je suis pas dans le même temps
je pense dans quelques minutes 1
sera peut être la journée la plus courte
des candidats
et donc caruana est-ce qu'il ya moyen de
je vois pas comment tu peux pressé sa
jeune vie rendent jamais sur cinq le
père il faut être quatre échanges 3d si
tu vas à la perle ou pas s'éloigner peut
montrer
faut calculer comme
voilà
votre
pas de choses
encore la gagner tout de même
ouais
donc s'il va ranger six ans mais
toujours à des matchs suite si on joue
et on prend lyon perrache âge mais petit
à petit les gones ouais
mais c'est votre machine
en fait comme ça les blancs plus jamais
menacé d' avancée énorme quand même le
roi et nous on va collecter tous les
pions et puis voilà ouais
donc
vous ne passez pas en direct sur youtube
six mois mais il ya aussi en direct sur
youtube le stream mais c'est pas sûr
bitstream oui c'est sûr tu fais comme
ray
faut le savoir
bon donc du coup en veux tu peux juste à
temps avec le fouet
depuis rien ae et si tu essayes
cleveland
d'ailleurs six voitures faits racistes
warren en fait
tu peux tellement rien faire non mais
non c'est dommage qu'il est veuf et
dames des carcans
ouais mais bon un peu plus tôt bon
peut-être aller voir un peu ce faire dix
décès répression en cours
c'est nul signé chez manga au hockey
mais un truc à limbé soit pas très noble
ouais fallait peut-être qu'ils fassent
après juan pitta
mesdames des cas alors l'idée c'est de
s'infiltrer dans le camp adverse m6
angers7 je suis tu je sais pas où et
auquel apple a fallu voir ce qui se
passe exactement s'il ya des perf est en
face mais voyez pas j'ai dû voir un truc
comme ça on est bien ouais bien sûr mais
ok tu as tourné policière je sais tout
je sais pas quelle heure je propose
comme dames 4 de base bref 80 des cas tu
n'aimes pas très rassurant
que terrain mais d'ici là + 4 ou des
quatre c'est toi même
je
sais pas mais ce mélodrame parti comme
ça avait beaucoup apprécié on est
d'accord
mais il peut la jouer assez longtemps
caruana
abaya nous a fait un truc à dire
avant-hier
puisqu'il a joué pour mme ding bah
ouais je sais pas si ça dénote pas quand
même d'une certaine fébrilité
s'est pas habituel pour lui
donc pas tout le temps
non mais en fait tout le temps qu'il
veut il a aucun risque de pain donc je
sais mais d'habitude les joueurs il
s'est quand même quand c'est vraiment
des d'euros à
houthem faire du de se reposer quoi tu
veux espérer mettre une petite exemple
je sais pas comment on tellement la saq
l'eau chaude aux accents c'est cette
note qui est en train de 5 ou bloc v6
mais en fait j'ai juste un truc est ce
que même ça parce que si même ça ça
gagne pas
à te reprendre jeudi
manquer tu puisses pas rentrer là dedans
essayez ça non mais c'est du maquillage
parce que
tu vends h tu vends ashton
dommage de
et tu fais un petit triangle entre des
visages des deux en fait si même ça
c'est nul
ça veut dire que je rame j'aille m en 12
ans -
non mais toujours
à l'aréna est terminée série talent qui
a gagné devant joseph me charger
largement lines
ok les bras au
double victoire de rythme
mais bon tu peux même fait rare oui tu
penses non mais je crois que tous les
coûts légaux ouais
il n'y avait pas une idée pour car en
avance avec une nouvelle pub un écoute
on va faire on va mettre la daronne à
l'abri on va mettre la daronne de règne
à l'abri
ouais mais k stew il faut bien
en fait si on met pas du tout plu au
début c'est pour en mettre quand il ya
plus rien à voir
c'est logique c'est logique c'est
logique c'est logique
au mans mais la daronne à l'abri
mais bon ça fait du bien
de mettre la dorna l'abri d'une autre un
peu plus bas les deux en même temps
[Musique]
donc
tout cas ce soir à 20h35 l'émission late
night mathieu
ce qui a d'autre à dire on a un lien
vers la chaîne youtube vas-y tu la fais
plus de politique vas-y rom érigé quand
perez
temps je peux pas
bah il faut se battre quoi c'est ça qui
est intéressant sac et surtout il aime
ça surtout il aime ça
fonctionne aussi pu bonne vibe
sans qu'il faille soit élu à la soirée à
paris d'ailleurs
fondu plex fonky flex vrai mais tous les
meilleurs à paris comme il vient du très
joli pays j'aime beaucoup le portugal
demandent que ça hypothèque value notre
nul et ouais c'est ça je vais remettre
les résultats de la journée et tu vois
aujourd'hui on a eu trois nuls mais on
va en avoir quatre ça va faire un statu
quo
ça me
courage t'a battu les filles là bas ça
oui
il est pas sur le coup 1 non pas du tout
on l'a rarement vu aussi faible
et les confiner que ces colloques je
sais pas comment ça se passe d'ailleurs
là que
le confinement avec les sept colloque
sera toujours bas faut bien s'entendre
sinon tu te fais ça tu as une sorte de
loft que
tu puisses il est parti
non mais on vous en veux pas un
supporter d'heure où je pense à faire le
raid sur la chaîne 2 de marque je sais
pas je sais pas pourquoi il n'est pas
dans le cadre est ce que je vais dire le
enfin leur est en fait le truc du raid
c'est que je peux pas le faire une fois
que la chaîne allait enfin
quelque chose
comme oui mais l'at on paie les parties
et jour pas dire j'en portais douce
l'armée fait qu'elle n'en son stream
pour que caen sa finition plus on voyait
qu'elle soit sur le coup elle aussi sur
le coup parce que si t'es pas sur le
coup on n'a pas attendu une demi-heure
ah non c'est fini c'est fini
déjà qu là ça va peut être passionnant
parce qu'on va regarder
et donc en plus quand tu auras plus rien
n'importe quoi attention
donc
vous verrez sur mary surratt
de samica ighirri ciocca a fléchi une
heure là il dit en conférence en pensant
qu'elle mêle joreige et quatre bombes a
fait pas de chance il a fait h 4 et du
coup là je suis mort pour rien sur jega
mais tant qu'à faire c'était sûr que tu
vas faire caissettes fait leur nom mais
c'est en fait
pas de chance
mais en fait je fais des fois ce genre
de conneries on veut d'être très très
énervé en fait de faire ça suffit de
charge de l'adversaire
parisé vous
donne quoique classement bas je crois
que c'est le même tu peux remettre
savent qu'ils ont un lit points de plus
tout ce dont tu auras 3,3 à mais c'est
déjà mieux jours bah oui
mais pour deux années pour ados demi
les carmona rhodes
j'aime par est le classement mis à jour
avant la crise des partis
tu peux rien mais c'est quand même
incroyable une nouvelle fois qu'on reste
bloqué une partie caruana complètement
insipide quoi caruana
a pris la droite jouer mais bon faut
qu'ils ont rajouté un peu même je le
droit
prentice qui veut un may hamm et l'on
n'a pas grand intérêt quoi
peut-être qu'il ay la greenshoe dirait
nietzsche ou tu fais de la pub quoi
dans tout train de bien truc
lycée raynouard chivu
- est possible
je crois que personne joui
allemande les noirs gagne en fait c'est
vrai que tu pousses trompions bel et
bien il court après tu bouffes des tu
gagnes
ça m'a taquiné réaliser une émission
match est prête
ça sera quoi le highlight ce soir du
coup
ou alors sa surprise quand on dit pas
du coup 20h30 ce soir
le switch de bus stream elle vient juste
en dessous
sur un peu toutes les parties placé trop
insipide du coup y aura un peu de tout
trois heures comme ça il y aura pas de
tft nordmeyer abate a fait dans tous les
cas
quoi qu'il en soit
jean qui rit super intéressant le début
a
été mieux quand même est ce que vous
pensez pas mal aux impôts potion de
tâches pas
de dingle
non mais je pense que monsieur confirmés
et wang hao avec swing gauche batte ou
raciste on n'a pas trop captée dans le
direx qu
est ce que vous voyez des points communs
entre les échecs et les autos de chasse
a pas du tout croire tom alors aucun
point en commun du coup elles ont toutes
chaussées genre tft c'est un autre chef
c'est un genre de jeu d'échecs en fait
après
ce que tu choisis non parce que tu
places les trucs sur un écrit qu'est
ce t'as bien sûr
mais ça n'a rien à voir
des gones il a trouvé le nom de
l'émission pour moi
échec et mat ouais
si je puis dire ces trucs là
j'ai eu trop mal à la gorge
à cause
des femmes great shoot qui cite sa fille
ni l'arrivée c'est quoi il ferait
regarder des dvd meilleur coup droit de
marc est
important je trouve que c'est son revers
moi le truc qui faisait bien marrer tous
bien mais roberts a filmé ça partait pas
ça parte à fond
bonjour safin
ouais bon joueur
s'il avait été plus sérieux lui faire
une carrière par là federer mais il
aurait pu faire un gros truc ouais
un peu de repos tresques
ouais mais des portraits ce que oui et
non
balbo ces troubles et c'est là peu de
chance alors que marc hâte c'était pas
les blessures le problème non
pas c'est bon parce qu'on lui a dit
viens un peu dernièrement il fait de
moins en moins de phrases blanes coincé
c'est bon quoi je faisais attention aux
gens qu'ils voient qu'on fait des
phrases la dette s'était du coup il est
oui j'en ai beaucoup trop fait elle est
qu on comprit
alors on se donne un tout autre registre
elle savait pas sa part est de faire
intervenir une troisième personne dans
le live donné que deux coups en fait
c'est comme ça et trois personnes
alors
diffuser 5.6 faut s'incliner hmm hmm hmm
hmm même si je laisse faire ça
je t'échange j'envoie b5 on l'a vu tout
à l'heure en fait
ça va tout le temps faire nul
quand bien même tu ferais ça
mais bon en gros les blancs
si tu veux pas de problèmes carmen 3
verset 4 vous savez n'avons pas de
balancer du bessin qui est compagnie
porte
pour toujours plus on va s'éloigner ou
qui vas tu perdais 5 et puis voilà quoi
non pas pouvoir faire autre chose sur ce
plan des demandes de roide et 6 tu vas
mettre un petit coup de chaise a tout ce
qu'il faut éviter donc se déclinera au
roi des six tu as un petit fou avec
quatre échecs de repartir en 17 sur 20
ans et 3 ans et 4 et
mais on absorbe les noirs pour faire
vrai décide pour être passé le fou
devant ranger trois ouvrages d'hommes et
uccle rb6
tête il veut faire ça
notre ligue est pas déçu
mais bon à vrai dire même ça dans quel
monde tu gagnes en fait non mais ne
tiennent pas
bats on le joue à air sénégal t'embêter
pour mathias des six
marianne tu ferais ça en fait pas si je
comprends pas c'est non mais je sais pas
qui joue sur les deux en fait mais
peut-être aucun des deux mais personne
propose mieux mais je sais pas
les noirs
et la raison en maths mais
[Musique]
non mais bon si son disque avec romain
edouard russie et tout ça c'est moi je
trouve dommage c'est cadence qu'ils en
rajoutent temps et
23h34 hansson non non je vais répéter ce
que j'ai répété mais j'écoute un bon
contenu sur quatre heures lui qui
s'arrête sur quatre heures sur une bonne
impression tu vas voir une heure et
demie de gens plus c'est comme ça va du
tout après 90 me tuera ajouté deux
heures servent à rien
que ça tu le fasses est dommage que ça
si tu veux faire un sport un peu plus
grand public tout en gardant le truc il
faut vraiment lever ces rajouts tous
deux joué
tu peux remettre 20 minutes ou 30
minutes mais faut pas même un petit truc
aux moyens même si tu m'as tu mets pas
aux normes
ça tue trop le spectacle
trop souvent après a quelquefois savard
a joué deux superbes finales c'est vrai
aussi mais bon
démarrage de ses trop rares en fait pour
que pour ça il à peine de six à huit que
trop souvent un truc si ça arrivait tous
les jours tu as une belle finale qui
pouvaient être joués quoi ce cas une
chose là dans le droit aura peut-être
une finale ou deux
nous euros
critique annick surtout le café un super
coup fouet ce tissu l on avait analysé
on vous montrera du coup après mes
attentes j'ai mal non
ce qui a poussé 5 et chats qui se
faisait rentrer sur la toile
mais tu te rappelles quand il y avait le
match caruana carlson aussi les finales
c'était bien longue
voilà partie de ma que c'était sympa les
du coup on est dans une partie où il
rajoute ans a joué après encore 15 20
minutes ça fait nul ça ça va
on m'accepte c1 accepte
quand ça dépasse la demi heure c'est un
peu
toute façon les échecs en longue c'est
pas spectaculaire du tourisme et du
spectacle je pense que le format pcl
mais oui c'est vrai mais tu peux faire
un truc un peu à mi chemin où tu garde
l'esprit des parties longues est
longue mais patron tu peux tu peux
limiter la longueur quoi quand même
au delà de m non
trop loin après
ce qu'on connaît qu'on double ouais on
devait d'avoir calmé réseau ou en tout
chacun ou quoi
ouais
y'a eu beats à 4 plein de choses soyez
ya quatre le truc avec les bleus les
airs les oignons rouges
faisaient là qu'on fait qu'il avait
voulu blitz et sasha mais que celui ci
avait tout vu avec limite à la pendule
ray c'est dommage
mais bon ça qui fait sascha
il a encore fait
non mais au kef assez étonnant beaucoup
de choses sacha qui passe une heure à
regarder chez 4 et 2 2 en fait il devait
même pas passé une seule seconde à
regarder les deux suisses est prêt
contre en fait ça que pour moi ou alors
y est juste il dit des trucs qu'on a
déjà vu comme ça je sais pas franchement
jamais fait ça s'agite aussi bizarrement
n'importe quoi mais mais bon que tu sois
je suis même étonné
ouais robiza il ya eu six ont vu tours 4
c'est ça le plus le plus fou
mais ça valait qui gagnent en éveil qui
avait pas pensé à tours 4 du coup on ne
saura pas
en tout cas
parti ne devrait pas forcément duré très
longtemps
mais de l'avis de m arque des nouveautés
aujourd'hui bmvr c'est intéressant
ouais t'es tu veux faire ça en fait
ouais mais du coup vous d'être ici
d'éviter un
genre assez 7 un petit coup de rodez 3
c'est fou j'ai 500 le coût déjà prêt
pour faire nul
c'était à ta tête des petits pièges
encore
sauce il faut être quatre le sourire
dame
pourrait voir le jour dès 8 ans il veut
les faire g5 ou après mais ça n'a pas
forcément envie beurre
peut-être pas si simple ça
et tour de vis de la belgique ne fait
pas non mais il est clair 10 il sait
qu'il a raté quelque chose et c'est
normal d'être un peu
désabusé juste à la fin de la partie
mais je pense pas devoir mettre son
moral en cause quoi que ce soit un
match que foutu menait 1 0 est légalisée
du fait un partout on sait pas d'avis à
la fin je saute pas de joie tribout
combinèrent bras que gagner
mais c'est pas non plus pas tu menais
12-0 ou 12
fatigue n'est pas en train de se taper
une petite sieste
n'aide vraiment très confortables ces
photos et vous tu dors bien comme il
faut quoi c'est bien spectaculaire comme
il faut c'est ça qui va faire le buzz
pour la quarantaine femmes
qui dorment c'est faux quoi
bon allez j'arrête quand se passer le
maximum comme tu vois ça fait nul et on
refera une vidéo plus tard
de résumer après la fin de cette partie
fable a été un petit peu à court de deux
variantes la
non mais les occasions tout cela un
troisième sous des six
bons un coup ces sept
coups
a perdu sa jambe un coup à son
dynamisme
mais genre si je fais ça tu fais ça
on peut comprendre
l'angoissé cette foule si souvent ça
quelque part
cheveux 4
way et on décidera
ça ça être perdu aussi je veux des huit
sûr qu'on se met quatre mois
et puis v3 machin avant tout des vies et
c'était ok
ok pas g5
n'ont pas pesé
en b 6
c'est quoi ça
en fait
caruana cadieux qui a vraiment dû faire
n'importe quoi on va donner quand on
s'est retrouvé mal ah
ouais
c'est fou en fait
mais en vrai la finale quand elle
commence tu peux pas juste passé chez
vous et cinq ici
même le roi des trois-rois c4 est
évident b5l à tout jamais
oui on sait qu'un
pas mais simplement c4
whip en danger tout est gâché
cinq
ouais ok peut-être chez courant à la
niche et pour un
netbook ion des peut devenir chiant à
jouer
[Musique]
comme ça jusqu'à sur x fi gt5 échec je
sais pas mais je le prends pas enfin le
point une fois pas deux
ok je sais pas non plus mais ça m'a
l'air plus
je comprends mais par exemple
ouah
g7
bon après ça cela va régresser au pire
des cas on fera fou projet
bajard brasse et 4 orange et 4 rebonds
détroit
sef et jusqu'à tuer foule cinq
noms mais ok je sors tu as changé grand
chose parce que s'il te fais un fou des
six
doigts tu aimes te faire ca si ces
machins gens peuvent coûter 4 way en ces
sept
on va avoir le cas soumis la
tête pas si simple si on s'est trompé ce
lundi juste il était tellement mieux
toute la partie avec à roanne acte avait
du mal à s imaginer qu puisse se
reconstruire une finale moins bien haut
le deuxième problème c'est que l'ordi
les héros dont jacqueline donc ça te
donne la raison de tous ces nuls sans
aide mais en fait d'après ce que je lis
il dort vraiment néo polar
genre c'est pas une blague
nalbert
mais ça tu vois je pense que ça devrait
être
perte par autant rigolé rohfritsch mais
c'était pas très drôle non plus pendant
bisman mais je pense que tu devrais
perdre et c'est juste un manque de
respect pour le public
c'est le cas maintenant ils doivent
vraiment
c'est quand même un sacré manque de
respect je positive à tomber quoi
non mais je comprends pas comment ils
veulent passer les échecs à la télé
comment tu pour retransmettre une image
pareil
c'est juste pas possible en randonnée
avec des candidats là dessus
10e finances a tellement et je pense que
tu devrais avoir quand même un minimum
de tenue voit par là c'est quand même un
peu ridicule d'image mais sur le dress
code c'est bien d'autres terminaux comme
ben disons que c'est un paramètre de
permis date quand même pas le droit de
faire ça
non aux caisses il a fléchi comme ça je
suis comme ça à mes désirs de diamants
qui des
marges que c'est quand même un peu
limite quoi
parce qu'un sport
ça mériterait de
nombreux sites d'orpaillage pourquoi
jusqu'à 5 heures écrit sa part lemaitre
ont perdu dan en effet qui avait pris un
forfait parce qu'il s'était mis en
bermuda comme
pour la world cup cela s'est notamment
les preuves qui botte à l'eau plus
c'était sympa quand même partie de
maxime cette année
il ya eu nul au final mais c'était pas
n'était pas insipide
mais c'est beau quand même image que ça
renvoie
pas vrai je pense que l'arbitré n'a pas
le réveiller tu as ta grisou qui disait
que c'était fait réveiller par la piste
quoi je pense que leur missive est
laissée dormir tu tombes du tout ou
alors que m forfait face soit tu mets
forfait parce que tu décides que c'est
irrespectueux envers l'adversaire et
envers le public envers les sponsors et
tu forfait
soit tu laisse dormir mais l'homme est
réveillé c'est pas normal c'est comme si
tu es en train de tomber à l'aprue
l'armée dit on joue vite bah oui c'est
pas son rôle mais bon il y avait déjà eu
le truc au tennis aussi quand c'était
kicks un steak thériault
et l'arbitré calme quoi enfin c'est pas
son rôle c'est pas bien mais côté un
plan il veut être un bon tu mets des
warnings des warnings il perd le match
tombe cependant pas son coach mental
quand et arbitre
les femmes du poteau résout pas je sais
pas le dress code pour les femmes je
pense que c'est autorisé mais je sais
pas
donc
si la bouche de notre chaise ou
servir 1
c'est ce qui fait une griffe au
printemps j'ai coiffé une grille vous
cette vague réclamée
bon je sais pas trop quoi dire mais
wayne va traduire un petit moment et les
pauvres c'est de le faire craquer car
elle
reste à voir ça suffit amplement mais
moi non plus ça me dérange pas qu'ils
dorment spécial ans mais ça veut dire
deux choses l'une ça veut dire soit cédé
qu'à nancy sont pas normales les mecs
ont le temps de dormir pendant les
parties ce que je veux quand même dire
beaucoup soit il faut arrêter de dress
code parce que si tu as le droit de
dormir bas dans ces cas là pourquoi
d'obliger être en costume
je sais pas faim il ya un truc qui me
manque c'est
un peu spécial quoi
fatima je n'avais pas pour un match de
foot un joueur commence à se taper une
sieste sur le terrain fait bizarre
comment différencier un joueur qui donne
alors qu'il réfléchit battus doit
infléchir les yeux ouverts assise juste
pas ta cam le droit d'avoir un jeu
pourrait forcer comme les joueurs être
plus ou moins six mois
non fermez les yeux et peut être utile
pour réaliser jusqu'au 27 mai
mais tu as une autre attitude on fait
entre dormirai sa balle énorme et
peut-être pas mais klitschko lui dormait
vraiment donc c'est c'est vraiment
arrivé dans le temps avec un gentil
d'armes
non mais c'est surtout dire qu'il ya
trop de temps
et du recul on arrête de pédaler pour
les dents les d'essence des condors pour
se reposer
non mais tu pédales dans les descentes
les forages sont les descentes c'est
exact acquis et tout ça ça roule à
dessin peinture est concentrée fate est
pas là tu pédales pas mais tu vas quand
même à piloter on verra tout droite emon
non mais c'est surtout du fait que
je sais comme comme le confinement tout
ça il y avait un grand espoir que ce
soit médiatisé qu'ils aient chacun
puisse passer à la télé ou quoi mais
disons qu'il faut aussi proscrire ce
genre de choses se passent à la télé
quand même enfin déjà en à l'image
d'être un truc long et pénible
car si même les joueurs dorment je vois
pas ça
c'est pas ça qui va améliorer l'image
des échecs
surtout que tu peux éventuellement de
lever entre técou partir dormir entre
les coûts et pas dormir la caméra dont
on est fier quoi enfin je trouve que
c'est un peu bizarre
donc
donc bon c'est pas grave non plus aux
fab pour nous ça change rien
de moi vous fait parler
ouais ça ça nous fait un peu d'animation
au final
c'est l'animation ce soit de l'assiette
site
[Rires]
non après la finale il a peut-être
raison d'âge mais elle n'est pas si
simple on a vu avec les blancs
un pion b plus éloignées
ils étaient probablement affalé sur la
table machin mais bon
c'est pas c'est pas top top
à la
[Musique]
fa ba
ba cheveux je tombe à voir quand ils
réalisent là nul
famille refuse de toute façon le truc
est marrant c'est une façon de couper
food & cie ce matin mais regardez c'est
la sallaz
tentative pas sûrement parce que sinon
on peut faire d'autre
bad et tu feras avoir des cistes prendre
à l'échec
des zozos qui chante un peu ouais je
dois qui chantait
réseau qui chante
à la foulée 6 échecs ok on marin 5
fu demis trois des quatre noms
parce que re5 sur glace quand même pas
je pense si tu rentres en rêve si ça
peut être grave
ouais bah ça se calcule louis valentin
battu tours vie qu'il allait tout
bouffer love
ça tu vas jamais joué
au loto
a tout bouffé tous les pions et j'ai
peut-être faire ça comme ça
oui mais coria rennes
wimille
j'ai cinq peut-être un jour non c'est
noté
a gelé faire pousser un dada juste je ne
devais faire montre qu on leur dit qu'on
aimerait plutôt avec gecina qui
s'affolent
oui et non le tfc 3 etf et donner une
option d et sa fille en b2b pas il y
aura un quatrième exemple ou aussi
depuis l'ère du foot 3 c'était ça qui
calculait rang 1 5
pouces et 5
vers des plateformes si ce n'est
ses tendons ok on va exhiber
4 et sa orangé c'est à
3,017 maintenant qu'on est parti devant
vous à le faire bronzer 8 rapproche
cette recette
donc ils m'ont fait pas juste un
communiqué c'est un monde bien
fou des quatre ans et on envoie des noms
donc ça ça va tu veux pas faire fi des
quatre gp e3 wef ou des deux le souffle
maintenant faut bouger on february 3 7
tonnes
ok ouais c'est ça y va ça va mais d'un
film
bon après re5 apparemment ce n'est pas
le seul coup
non mais c'est sûr que c'est là donc ça
qu'il a calculé
c'est là dedans qui veut rentrer
c'est là tant qu'il veut rentrer
notre ami n'est pour marie jo mais une
pub
je te fais une mini pause 2 ans baisse
du cac fait un truc et j'arrive à tout
de suite nazi
suite femme ensuite élite
page une petite hutte bien comme il faut
c'est bien mettre des petites pub là
on les enchaîne
on enchaîne les petites cuves comme ça
ça fait toujours un
c'est le bon moment
c'est bon moment pour mettre les petites
pub bien comme il faut les amis
les petits pubs qui rentre
une petite pub qui rentre
bon honnêtement je sais plus trop quand
vous dira ce fait à 90 qu'on commence à
plusieurs manières de faire du pour les
blancs c'est au joueur de choisir il
peut se tromper quoi mais c'est au
moment où ils se trompent qu'on aura
de quoi parler
actuellement
on est vraiment dans une situation
d'attenté
donc j'avais des questions dans le chatt
n'hésitez pas c'est le moment
de les poser
-selon les poser
enfin qu'il fasse nul pour révèle bon
problème fait pour moi ça change pas
grand chose
selon pham thi une finale tu arraches
exactement
ils sont repris dans la scop pour les
femmes et pour les hommes pour les
hommes il ya un dresscode en russie au
médicis
selon toi n'est plus l'homme de ce début
de tournoi demandera turba willow run
trois fois les noirs quand même une
seule fois les blancs
donc dans les hommes dans les co leaders
avec deux points ni sur quatre celui qui
est juste et noir après le tournoi et
nourrir et se dire on a
que donne la partie de fabio voit ça à
faire nul mais chez soi
ça demande un peu de précision mais ça
va faire mieux
est ce que l'île est devenue milliard
que sa fiche et je sais pas il ya ni qu
il ya des choses qui sont devenues plus
fortes que lille à des variantes de
lille a qui sont plus fortes que lille a
tout un tas de choses
qui existent maintenant est ce qu'on
peut avoir le goût est ce qu'on peut
voir le katanga férois détroit je vais
remonter au classement mais le truc
c'est que
et parfums pas tout à fait mis à jour il
est mis à jour mais des pommiers à chier
caruana n'ont pas encore fini leur parti
donc probable où on aura un dépôt à deux
et demi à la fin de la journée et
caruana à 2 donc ça fera un statu quo
par rapport aux débuts de de la journée
donc voilà les placements à avoir tourné
sur la partie
avec roy détroit qui vient d'être joué
donc
femme qui est en train de revenir
on va remettre le songe et fab ne se
passe pas grand chose
donc il y avait peut-être du roi des six
froid le 4 mai sur fous ces cinq faut
être quatre échecs
je vous retourne croisé cette ong est
roi des trois qui revient et le truc
c'est que sur b4 voitures feront à ses 4
donc en réalité ça va pas bien loin
c'est encore une autre manière de faire
nul
face aux carabins qui revient de pause
avec un oreiller
non mais vraiment temps que j'aille
checkait sa femme y en a besoin c'est
une blague mais
non mais c'est possible je m'attends à
tout mais non
non non nous déciderons ne revient pas
en arrière je peux pas
vous le no fake
mais c'est en train d'arriver sur
l'autre qu'officiel est incroyable c'est
ce qu'a déjà analysé
et voilà d'être en sueur sur le live ou
double turbo plus frais à tellement de
personnes qui arrivent tellement
personnes qui regardent le truc officiel
aussi c'est ça fait flipper si son
ça fait peur
je viens tu es des geôliers par les
hissant dans
l'officiel hm vote ce qui est bizarre
c'est parti davy leçon aux tchèques du
soft
non ça c'est au mail de noms comme j'ai
confiance
ma porte
mais dépouille va tenter en fait ils
adorent ça il tourne il tourne comme un
sans rien faire 1 mon iphone
4 ou 5 points 17 passes détroits et tu
reviens
c'est bruce cette fin de partie quand
même
noté me peux je veux c'est des trucs
peut-être ou là
parce que c'est la fin il était aux
alentours de 6000 tout à leurs riffs à
faire que ça quand même perdu énormément
d'audience quoi
et même si 1000 c'est très peu quand ils
pensent
bas même un match de ligue 2 en france
et plus de personnes dans le stade
ouais
juste au stade jeudi refera pas des gens
carrez datée c'est des gens qui ont
pillé leur place et machin
qu'est
ce qu'on pense avoir mbelek moment
peut-être paul renoux d'accueil soit
venu déjà une fois
il faut s'arrêter sur le site officiel
non un truc twitch
apprécié maxime voir venir n'importe
quand
notre train sera bien sûr le bienvenu on
veut pas lui demander tout le temps faim
derrière n'a rien demandé quoi c est
venu de lui-même
je ne vois même pas lui demander de
venir
j'espère bien
dans le jeu mal venu fanni fait son
tournoi et parce qu'on sait s'il a envie
de venir parler un peu de lui-même que
ça lui fait du bien de savoir et les
esprits juste que volontiers j'ai envie
de dire mais déjà je lui écrire pour
l'embêter avec sa
part été non il va quand même très
simple car
c'est quand même à fabien de trouver les
coûts quoi
je vous ai pas envie d'un mcdo les gars
franchement il livrait un
méchant raté je crois ouais
je sais pas j'aime son vrai je crois que
tout le matos on finit quoi et pourquoi
ferais pas un
match livraison quoi le drive quoi oui
mais bon après faut que les gens qui
travaillent là bas
soit en contact entre eux aussi
assez bon ils ont mis la pub finalement
comme la fidh
bas
voit d'ailleurs j'ai vu que les médecins
chinois qui est en italie trouvais que
ça travaille beaucoup trop court
parce qu'en fait tu donnes tu peux pas
avoir la distance sociale forcément à h
non mais je pense faudra vraiment
essayer de déminer au plus le plus
possible les boulots mais en fait des
métiers vraiment obligatoire sauf un
télétravail crise que tu veux mais je
pense en fait électricité gestion volo
internet des trucs comme ça en fait il
ya beaucoup de travail est indispensable
en vrai nom mais je veux dire les tout
ce qui est justement mills edwards ou
quoi ça c'est hyper vital
mais
pro kemal a du coup ramasser les fruits
les plantes légumes mais
les livres et donc les calmes et les
chauffeurs de camion quoi ça c'est
important ta l'agriculture
est en fait tous les chercheurs à fond
pour ces trois vaccins bon le reste ses
portes
je créerai un truc justement des jambes
qui s'est alarmée des livrets ou quoi
mais qui te livre des courses dans là où
tu habites
plus personne keyyo faire les courses
mais que l'on te fasse
tu se livrer chez toi
s'appelle les livraisons s'appelle vivre
oui oui mais en fait tu faisais même pas
ce que tu veux en fait on va te livrer
des trucs
niveau potter est dit que sainté les
pizzas et put que la plus mais à
saint-élie mangent dans les pizzas
disques anciens responsables de quartier
qui réceptionnait course nommé au quai
je trouve sain je pensais déjà avant que
ça c'est possible même ça me semble
complètement dingue logique
non mes livraisons oui mais n'a pas
d'habitude les raisons c'est celui qui
bosse dans le magasin et ils peuvent pas
livrer tout le monde la france entière
en même temps quoi
là pour le coup ça serait une autre
démarche ne fait peut-être pas libre et
toulouse la même journée mais que tu es
de quoi tenir une semaine chaque fois
enfin roulement quelques le tout je
pensais qu'ils habitent ou comment
machin une fermeture de recensement
et allez quoi mais moi je voulais bloqué
si déjà les gens par département et
c'est
même par ville en fête
mais au moins par département
non peu importe les spécialistes du truc
c'est vrai que
non mais là ce ne sait pas on s'avance
pas sur le origine de la maladie le de
la soie nude à même de trouver un moyen
quant au monde et à manger que le moins
de gens possible sorte les ghettos de
vito marche
même style au but
pour l'économiste être la table je sais
pas d'ailleurs y'a castaic qui demande
si on va entendre une crise économique à
notre avis
là encore pas spécialiste mais je dirais
que oui
mais
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que il
faudrait déjà masculin bien c'est que
les livreurs et puis cette équipe est de
même si ça contient et les supermarchés
qui livre ou quoi pourquoi pas mais que
les livreurs ils puissent être équipés
de
matériels
des masques tout ça te dire
non le problème c'est que il y en a même
passé devant l'hôpital j'ai en fait du
goût serait plus facile en équipe et à
peut équiper la police
technique que les livreurs tkip
caissière les gayssip
des guides tout le monde qui buzze
heures en fait je supprimerai
oui oui mais faudra qu'on y arrive un
moment où l'autre parce que
je pense d'aller faire les courses de
trot de contact en
france
ils ont les wade chine ont l'air de dire
c'est pas encore suffisante
mais je pense que prendre exemple sur
eux parce qu'ils ont quand même gérer la
crise il est y résoudre la gare
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas lésiné dans
les
mémoires
non orthodoxes mais tout le monde à
bagdad oui non mais en fait c'est pour
ça qu'ils soient pas obligés de passer
commande par internet
qu'en fait honte au liban où on prend ou
paie pas un minimum vital quoi
sinon le point positif que les gens ils
sont beaucoup plus surveillé flics et
donc c'était beaucoup plus facile à
mettre en place
chez eux
bon sens où ils ont déjà la
reconnaissance faciale quand tu es dans
la rue tu vois en france on est loin de
ça
dépote spa qui le dit c'est vrai que pas
répartis en trois catégories les cas
graves à l'hôpital les cas bénins dans
les locaux réquisitionnés
et personnes qui ont été en contact et
des affectés à l'hôtel ouais bof les
caisses dès le début mais très bien pas
bien ça la logique ce qu'il faut refuser
formateur
du coup
les gens qui ont pu être en contact ou
quoi les contacts vicomtal une personne
vit candidats
sacha sans aucun doute
mais j'ai donné des ailes mais vu que
j'ai pas le droit
s'achète pas logique et engins fléchi
juste
sinon
sinon et pau
uracan qu'ils ont quand même réussi à
développer une api avec un qrcode
que tu scan partout et quitte autorisent
ou non à pénétrer dans un lieu traçage
de tous les déplacements de la
population et ses trucs comme ça en fait
c'est pour ça aussi qu'ils ont plus
moyen de faire de contrôle et de bloquer
les gens ce qu'ils sont hyper contrôlée
de base
non mais
on doit accepter ça
aucune manière pasteur
on voit suis pas loin l'italie aux
grands maux les grands moyens
mais d'ici 10 ans perdant de liberté
femmes ont la liberté c'est d'être
confiné chez toi si tu veux un jour voir
ressortir que d'être passé par là
en fait je dis pas que c'est un monde
idéal l'autre mais plutôt contre de base
mais en fait c'est quand t'as pas le
choix tu as pas le choix c'est comme si
il ya une menace de maths compte au roi
bon ben ok je vois retoucher un pur
moment rock car j'ai ici j'ai pas le
fomc est au bas je préfère faire ça et
pas être ma taille dame proche 7 au
prochain que un bon ben j'ai pas de
question de mon roi tout va bien je suis
libre batimat
donc je fais g6 et puis après j'ai serré
de voir s'il fera mais de mon front g7
faire un truc puis on parle bricolera
mais il ya une urgence en fait y'a un
truc ces menaces de m'attendre inconnu
voit quand même déjà éviter ça
ou pas
non mais si c'est bien d'être match en
un coup
c'est vraiment compliqué
non mais t'as un truc d'éthique je sais
pas mais il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
trucs philosophique d'heure mais il ya
beaucoup de jeux tenants et aboutissants
qui sont
qui font que c'est difficile à
c'est une pollution c'est une question
qui est difficile de trancher est-ce
difficile même d'avoir un avis c'est en
fait je pensais plutôt à la situation
tant que des mauvais choix quoi te dis
que tu es obligé de vous et en plus on
en fait je pense que tu as plus des
mauvais choix déjà oui oui pas facile de
tout le monde est évident que ce n'est
pas leur cas c'est sûr tu sais pas en
fait ce qui est loin
mais disons pour la santé je suis prêt
mais le sacrifice mais moi ce que je
pensais qu'ils seraient pareils qu'on
apprécie personnage suis pas quel point
c'est possible de faire mais c'est de
vraiment fermé durement au début par
département région direct au département
et après réouvert petit à petit
département par département et interdire
sa photo risation spéciale aux gens de
sortir ton groupe de sortir genre moi je
fais dans le cas des 1006 je fais des
micros frontières
pour déjà que les gens qui sont vraiment
pénètre malheureusement il se rend perez
3 4 5 6 mois va c'est vraiment dommage
et puis comme ça les régions qui se
remettent bien mal elles peuvent
travailler à fond et va produire pour
les autres en fait mais le voilà en face
et dès que tu vas voir un nouveau
contaminés même si on passe ça va te
faire un deuxième vague coups bas et si
tu fais ça sur toute la france soit
alors que si tu bloques déjà par
département il me semble que tu pourrait
permettre plus ou moins de
essayé dit et tout du moins quoi ouais
ouais ouais lorsque m et puis dès qu'un
problème on confine
oued hectares dans un département turcs
ont fuit le département et peut-être les
départements adjacent le temps des sûr
que dans les autres sur n'est pas et
puis et puis voilà quoi tu te pas comme
ça mais comme c'est chou espère y
trouver un vaccin que ce truc là oui
c'est juste une solution
passagère moment le passager peut durer
mon crime
moi j'ai mon idée c'était juste de
réussir après je sais pas si c'est
viable ou quoi
moniz essaie juste de réussir a du coup
avec eux servent que les gens qui
peuvent travailler qui peuvent faire des
trucs comme ils ont pas la quarantaine
qui puisse aider lé fine robe solidarité
nationale tu fais ton ego devenu un
endroit
après c'est sûr pour tout le monde et
tout mais justin paraissent plus viable
que de fermer tout le pays après
maintenant lancer trop tard on obligé de
le faire mais du coup une fois que ce
sera fini pas ce sera fini à certains
endroits mais d'essayer de
d'asie tu vas ça marchera pas ça tu peux
pas à dire on re tester si ça marche pas
on reconfigurer voiture confinement en
trois semaines bah oui mais attention au
luxe a pour nom c'est le seul truc à
faire
mais du coup tu réouvre département par
département et tu espères
je sais pas
c'est pas une solution que tu as envie
de faire pendant des décennies
[Musique]
non faire compliqué
dipak c enfin je vous dis pas que ce
truc laquelle j'avais pensé c'était une
bonne solution c'est juste ça me
paraissait être un des trucs les moins
pires aprilia
faire l'idylle et jean yves ossonce
huras notre base c'est mieux que de
bosser 0 se nomme jamais quoi non plus
je pense que tu as des départements qui
peuvent rester juste sans jamais être
cas je pense que c'est possible si c'est
vraiment bien contrôlée que les gens se
disent pas ou je vais être confiné
demain je vais partir dans une autre
région je vais apporter venir mais dans
une autre région cheval en bretagne jean
boucheron je vais je aller dans la
maison secondaire en bretagne je vais
très heureux à belle île en mer
et vous si les gens n'y pensent pas
comme ça et qu'ils sont un peu
solidaires ou quoi on peut peut-être
réussir à faire quelque chose
bon du coup fait l'élite jouer en tout
cas logique pour pas laisser le roi noir
venir un père à 5 il ya deux ans et la
pression qu'on est à leurs yeux une
regarde mais c'est exact on a besoin
désolé ancenis les y compare un peu
d'autres choses c'est jusque là on vous
a parlé de ça ouais il ya cinquante
minutes déjà cette position c'était sûr
qu'elle arriverait plus ou moins
justes honnêtement l'intérêt de ce qu'on
a en regardant en train de regarder très
limité
l'arrière stark qui dit sauf place
saison de synthés tous à eux
et je crois que les présents de scinder
son hyper chaud pour que l'on reprenne
quoi qu'il en soit
moi j'aurais saison blanche en fait
c'est un thé pas scinder ce problème
d'ailleurs tu vois j'ai ressenti un peu
de la coupe de france ça fait plaisir de
la jouer ou quoi mais bon tant pis on
m'a dit
mais voilà
[Musique]
fichiers
non mais oui il a raison c'est à dire
c'est qu'à roanne a fait une erreur
c'est un peu ça jeanine on aime le foot
18 de bois qui aura passant à 5 et puis
1,4 il soutient le qui ont dépassé et là
tout d'un coup ça devienne gagnon
ouais y'a pas que ce soit une honte je
suis d'accord et colas alors je sais pas
si tu d'accord surtout enfin je
reprendrai parsemant classement dernier
mais que je pense cette année on pourra
pas finir le championnat et ses doutes
donc faut partir de là le trop de
solution chaque sport c'est
problématique j'ai eu alors une ville et
propose un truc pas mal
l'idée c'est de rendre les huit premiers
maintenant est de faire les barrages
direct en fait dégager
non mais en fait si possible une autre
c'est que j'ai lu un mec bain en
allemagne un virologue il dit je pense
pas de foot avant 2021
parce qu'il dit en fait est ok ça va
aller mieux
le foot le problème c'est que tu va
remettre tout le monde ensemble dans les
stades machin savent à 7 soit trop
déconner tu l'aimés à huis clos ils vont
aller faire les cons devant le stade est
en effet récompense tad ils vont aller
dans les bars ils vont se regrouper
ouais ouais c'est pas de soeur soit je
joue au foot ou pas c'est du loisir il
ya beaucoup plus important que
l'audience pour
tu penses le rugby ça va être pareil les
supporters de vie soit à moins qu' un
lobbying très très puissant c'est
tellement de fric qu'ils fassent passer
le truc et puis que hockey puisque leur
ville et les supporters vont pas aller
devant le ca de faire les idiots
généralement
mais en gros tu vois la veille qui a dit
ouais pas tout abandonné notamment de
lui même durant la guerre c'est pas un
charlot meta tennis du coup un petit peu
je sais pas faim oui pour le coup c'est
vrai qu'avant qu'on pense aux sports bon
madern une femme que j'aime bien et
c'est fini ça se passe bien le temps
j'aime bien regarder je suis assez
passionné mais bon ça m'inquiète deux
trois trucs à remettre sur le droit
chemin vont quoi donc encore un peu de
tennis à huis clos
ça va faire bizarre ainsi à une finale
du us open à huit clos et tout ça ce
serait étrange à l'ambiance je me
demande si djoko il jouerait pas moins
bien du coup tu vois je me demande si ça
peut rebattre un peu les cartes c'est
intéressant ça a pas de public ça ne
change l'ambiance change ta motivation
ça change la pression bas ça change des
trucs
et c'est quoi qu'il en soit ça donne
moins envie de jouer tout seul dans ton
coin que citer soutenu qu
intéressant ça le tour de france à mon
avis si tu peux oublier
fois semblables ont permis à double
problème en fait avec le tour de france
c'est qu'en fait même si en france ça va
mieux que en ralliant modern espagne sa
famille en italie ça va mieux mais pas
en allemagne je dis un truc au hasard tu
fais quoi des chorales on les aura de
venir jouer vous courir ou pas
en fait tu vas faire un tour de france
sont interdits 18 nationalités tu
défonce des équipes trop compliqué je
pense famille pour s'asseoir dessus on
fait une année bat cette triste et on
rebâtit un truc mais les échecs je pense
que ça va être dans le mal pendant un
long moment bah oui il va emprunter des
trains nationaux mais tu crois qu à
l'étranger ou quoi faudrait que c'est
peut-être parce que c'est comme ça que
pour la peine injuste et dans un endroit
fermé avec les gens en face de toi
pendant longtemps les échecs pour moi
c'était le truc le pire pire que tous
les autres sports quoi parce que ce que
tennis fait à huis clos tatata des
ramasseurs de mal tu sais déjà horrible
et un majeur en fait c'est
je pense que
mais ces choses puisque t2 s'enferme
dans une seule à lacets serrés
tu touches les pièces donc là c'est le
pire mais ferguson kg réfléchis tu
touches la tête quand et comme ça
je sais pas mais en plus ces échecs qui
peut faire par internet ok c'est pas
parfait il ya des problèmes etc on est
au courant mais gère que tu as quand
même une alternative donc les échecs les
tournois en dur je pense que ça va être
annulé pendant longtemps
d'organiser la clau rockin mars ça va
être très vite réglé un légat oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai aussi la rotule as-tu
par hasard est un cas de figure où il
tombe pas je serai totalement heureux
tout soit la chloroquine et puis on fait
le tour de france on fait tout pour
qu'on le foot voilà tu vois moi je peux
pas rêver mieux
mais j'espère ça marche au la baston
trois vaccins ou
mika - c'est bon quoi que l'on dit on
mais refaire on sera très heureux on
souffre et on savoure va d'autant plus
notre notre vie normale entre guillemets
ça dope et à la fuite les médecins qui
vous enflammez pas avec la chloroquine
et à rien de démontrer bah c'est pas
ceci est un échantillon trop pied c'est
sa
voix qui est faux et filles et attaque
le pion et du coup j'ai cinq je crois
que c'est une faute oui
moi c'est 4
et 6 ok fou et six sur le coup puisque
si on touche laura et robin 5
nous longeons exemple alors que si on a
voté g5 bien comprendre les subtilités
différence entre
4 et poussé confiant des quatre
mois ses 4
des six baies 3
17 fawcett a tant fait des six échecs
les carottes sont cuites
çà et et leur swing et tu montes tu
auras je sais pas
intéresser les gens qui presse on voit
ça ok bon ben c'est des landes robes
liquettes c'est impossible de se tromper
moi des gars troquet donc il est sage 6
mai c'est un coup validé par l'ordi
puisque fawcett le tout poussé
nancroix v6
où il proposait fondé vite au sol on
n'est pas content on rappeler si soudé
parce que roy message transférant ses 5
ouais mais tu encaisses et roissy ce
tueur vient de tuer et tu montes sur
herbe à ses
fins jouets se trouvait faire d'un
d'édition
chaque boîte à docs ph qui vont donc
vraiment après donc on peut écouter doc
l'annuler signé c'est vrai parce qu'on
s'est tapé cette finale quand même
pendant 1h10
donc c'est également un petit peu long
ouais mais ok enfin
bon il a tenté il a tenté et je pense il
a tenté le coup voir si
parce qu'en fait c'était possible de se
tromper
ouais
et donc d'une nulle qu'a tenu
aujourd'hui mais
pas insipide surtout la partie de maxime
qui est intéressante on va y revenir
dessus en fin de vidéo sur youtube tu as
mal jouer à faire leur aide que j'avais
promis
les pille on y va
[Musique]
alors à temps
c'était ici
attends attends il faut que
j'envoie attaque je trouve l'url de la
chaîne
attend dé moi je prends un petit chaton
attendant abou ismail raid et du voile
se retrouvent demain demain se rejoue
midi
avec annick vos commentaires avec
yannick oil et oil on retrouvera
d'autres soirs pour femmes
à 20h30 voilà et puis bon je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée ce soir match
s'ils voulaient voir le débrief et la
chaîne youtube bitstream comme d'hab
quoi alléger le temps fleurette j'espère
que la chaîne et partitions j'allais
dire à 5 heures est donc j'espère s'ils
en fait de toute façon je vais pas y
arriver mais c'est parti donc leur aide
et marty twitter